[Music]
n
n n n n
nah
[Music]
n
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started I am well it's not important who
I am um what's important is that you are
pulling up to the iron Lords podcast
right now as we speak and uh I guess I'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so
um look y' messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being account accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be handable
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Saron up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to started regardless back when you was
messaging people on a check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my City but I'm still by coal I got
let's Swit that what you do don't stop
that was dope keep that keep that going
keep that going go ahead look I guess
you could say that I'm very spoil to be
your dog they very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed
for you I always been a nerd never been
a loser making Vault Tron with a gang of
cougars and I'm going places better tell
a uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
frdy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I get something here
to keep you entertained until it's time
to get this show started so
um look y'all mess up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting and range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
of start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM
check my vocs Twitter but I'm anal love
my city but I'm still Co I
got Don't Stop N that was dope keep that
keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you could
say that I'm very spoil feel them to be
your dogs they ain't very loyal but I
ain't going to hold you I ain't heard
the boy you you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making vron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell a uber cuz it's pretty hard
to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podc right now as
we speak and uh I guess I'm here to keep
you entertained until it's time to get
this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a canable and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
the song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Aron up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the range you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest of start regardless back we was
messaging people on a check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by coal I
Gott what did you do don't stop that was
dope keep that keep that keep that going
keep that going n Go ahead I guess you
could say that I'm very spoil feel to be
your dog they very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the
boyal you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's woo
let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all M up turn me to an animal
and heads be swearing they real but come
to find out that they really mechanical
and yeah I be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being a cannibal
and they say I'm better than money
because you can Bank on me being
accountable I know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable I kill a beat and
they want to compare me to Freddy and
Jason I rather be Hannibal they be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all to Dramatical I know it's random
but I addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is that
this is that Yoga Fire Flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
it department and I get the blame I'll
be running collecting and range you just
a Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
you was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm antisocial
love my city but I'm still coal I got's
[Music]
swi keep that keep that going keep that
going go ahead look I guess you can say
that I'm very spoil them to be your dog
they very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't heard the boy you you
ain't got to say it I'm
[Music]
embarrass
Calla both loud and clear a proclamation
ofation not on
me I C the
ofial near the river St lawence with the
[Music]
through I'mma just chill and watch them
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack can be like a young
Whooper then they would mistake me for
addict if I can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice then invite your
girl to your squadron cuz if you don't
give with that option you going to be
single player like Sovereign you going
to get tossed in the bushes by King
David royalty and not a pretender
detrimental to a Elemental what a avatar
to a need Bend I got to be me I know
it's my destiny work too who cares if
you fly if you stilling mosquito you
swear you ain't something but really be
steo you like to collect stuff and
that's cool but I got bad news even if
you really was that dude King still be
the king of the statu since a juvenile
I've been cursed with a curse to be
Musical and if you hate it we'll meet in
The Crucible other than that it's cool
and it's beautiful we let you know that
your dreams are pursuable whatever you
want to do then it's doable if you got
work on a Sunday is suitable cuz you can
listen to this in your cubicle on the
Lord's
day if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cuz you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a Lord's
day oh yeah
yeah
the mics are hot we're not doing that
mics are hot family it's a family fun
show yeah we're not doings you got wears
no we don't unless they drop a bag for
my man and then we'll support let's
go no doubt mic check real quick just
make sure everything we I didn't do my
mic check during the um the uh waiting
room add let me make sure your mic is
good hello hello hello hello what's
what's up the beard game the beard game
looking different today it's a little
different so what's going on Sir let's
get you the mic situation let me check
his bed out
oh no doubt no doubt The King The
King yeah what's going on baby there we
go here here we are live and welcome to
the iron Lord podcast LLC and also live
on lwag gaming.net episode number
334 it's another glorious Sunday we're
back at the round table on the Lord's
day and the last day of uh 2023 y' it's
been a eventful year you know we had a
lot of going on a lot of highs a lot of
fun stuff but uh yeah we made it y'all
CH together damn
it one whole year baby that's it another
another rotation and today we've got the
game awards recap Marvel blades game
exclusive GTA 6 reveal Avatar
Impressions and Playstation bands whose
topic is that to discuss so we going to
get that's in case y'all forgot y'all
must have forgot Dr Roy you you know you
know you have your own channel for this
stuff right now yeah you
know and you know the video went up
already was on it yeah just in case
y'all didn't remember I got you not
y'all must have forgot y'all must have
forgot the boot will stay on your neck
oh man so let's introduce the four horse
Man Gaming those original gaming nights
in the round table here in the realm oh
the chat is lit already my co-host Theos
my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf my
man Lord addict fact the back how we
doing sir doing pretty good I played
Dishonored half the
morning I know what it is I figured it
out he cut his
mustache yeah he that's what it is I'm
like he looks like an Amish man now yeah
he got the joint going people people are
saying that um I I look like Wolverine
yeah I was like no no no you look like
the white LeBron James LeBron
James oh okay okay yeah so I'm playing
uh Dishonored just uh I I didn't play
um a lot like the first one I played
multiple
playthroughs because I I beat the first
one uh I beat the first one after I beat
the game with not killing anyone uh but
when I played the second one I just went
straight into not killing anyone uh so
I'm going back through those games right
now like people say
like the the map layouts like crazy and
you know games like like Dark Souls and
stuff the map layout in these games is
intense like I forgot about them like
what's funny is like every time I tell
people I I I've beat the dishonors
without killing anyone they just like
they get just like mesmerized how' you
do that yeah it's called patience it's
called patience and using the entire the
entire map to your advantage yeah it's
great great game design right it's
amazing oh my God yeah the way you do it
is like you can't technically kill
people so you have to either put them in
situations where they end up dying on
their own like setting people up like
exposing people's weaknesses or there's
this one time where you like strap some
dude to a chair and make and make him uh
confess his sins okay all right over an
intercom that's what's up that's what's
up Salute I see a lot of in the chat
little blade little hell blade little
Sega chat ever born in there okay Sor I
I I beat the um I beat dxx uh without
killing people too I beat that game
without killing people too you are an
animal a lot of Arcane lover us yeah
well what's funny is in was was you
playing it was you playing it with the
blade voice like hey black
suckers well the funny thing is I I
played I can't remember if I played all
of Fallout New Vegas without killing
someone but literally if your speech is
high enough even the last boss you could
just tell you could convince him not to
fight oh that's crazy I didn't even know
you have to have a 100 speech to do it
but you can convince them not to fight
oh that's E I love stuff like that any
other stuff you've been playing so just
been getting your decid I I play a good
a good amount of of Avatar uh so you
definitely talk about that a little bit
want to talk about you purchas that
thing yo you
stupid that's some disrespectful stuff
that's very disrespectful but
uh you want to talk
about you want talk about it now thank
you to Ubisoft yeah shout out
for
providing let get out that PRI part all
right there we we will discuss that
later during the topic he's about to
have me put on my my glasses because I
was like oh maybe this is a glasses
show and yes me and King will be
streaming Boulders gate I don't know
what time it's going to be this week but
we will be streaming it eventually I
think I'm going to go in there for
Berserker I think that's the class
because for some reason I have a feeling
uh king king's going to be dying a lot I
don't know why so I I got to go in there
prepared for the worst like got to put
that best multiplayer to the test you
you play you played it already right yes
so good obviously I'mma die
more yeah that's the point you're
ridiculous go I'm going in there with
with abilities where I can hit people
multiple times don't don't he sound like
Jamie yes right
now he have the up yes the up cuz like
make sure he has the up and then when
you call out his beastin he he always
gives a c nah but you
know hour game in hour kbu the way they
game is very say they have to have the
advantage they have to come in op they
have to assert their dominance in this
situation you know to let you know where
you at where they at assured assured
Victory yes yes absolutely Sol Victory
but yeah it's been a pretty pretty crazy
week you obviously we got the Video Game
Awards stuff going on how's your to
doing pretty good now uh I I've been on
antibiotics for a couple days at this
point my bad I'm sorry I didn't text you
yesterday and AC that's and there
there's the channel that I'll be uh
we'll be streaming that off of it's is
that arena is that the arena yeah the
arena sound like fighting games should
go down in hot K in the arena right I
mean it's the arena that me people go
head tohe right
so we'll do the fight games over
there yeah step into the ARA shout out
gang it's going to be it's going to be
attic and
friends yeah that sound like a place I
would be comfortable at to fight I like
that do they s
beer I I want to like you know that
picture that still picture in Gladiator
where he's like at the bottom and and
like he's got his swords and he's going
like that I want I want my Avatar
recreated in that POS with that whole
background that's going be the the
picture ridiculous is there anyone else
I'll need that one anyway that's been
pretty much it sir yeah that's pretty
much it you know it's uh this this
week's just been a a chotic week yo asro
par you going time he said what type of
head tohe head stop
that super you that's why they be say
acknowledge that that was it was so out
of pocket I was just like I can't let
that just slide it's not even in color
you acknowled cuz that's our men that's
our men that do do the joint we met
Astro at
being it's wild out of pocket but it was
funny as hell and that that that's even
that's even worse he knows exactly how
to get you off of your
flow or off your squabble off your
squabble exactly off your if you
will and of course we have returning
almost technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lived for the single player
selfish experience and unfortunately for
me the sastra
damus the godbody whatever title he
wants me to call him six times what was
it what am I seven times what am I
supposed to call you sir the Messiah the
M of the game award voting who has an
inside snitch in some level
you know what next year next year
whatever you pick I'm
picking I told Co I said after he won
this year I was like he's he's going
first to every topic next year I don't I
don't there's no going back and forth s
what are you picking you know what it
remind me of I hate to interrupt your
your please this but it reminds me of
the days of me and you remember King ad
you don't realize this man was so
dominant in those B b games and when we
tried we just you just got to give up
cuz it was it got to the point where he
just consistently beating you down and
you're just like this guy I I I lost
twice and I remember those like it
yesterday and it was it was embert
stepping into pitches because he hit me
so he was literally getting hit by
pitches in Triple Play So in Triple Play
you could literally it doesn't matter
like if the ball was in the strike zone
you can step you move into move the
player into the slide started cheating
towards the end of of a game that we
were playing and he wound up beating me
like literally by just getting hit by
pitch and then Drew and then Drew beat
me one time he beat the great Mariano
yeah a n he beat the great Mariano in
the bottom of the night that's the one
that you came out with ENT the sand man
and you
lost yeah anyway but uh yeah uh the
Messiah Lord of clarity lord patreon of
the iron bank and PC Master races on
short your buil lord Sovereign how you
doing sir doing very well Excellent Man
the past week yeah uh was celebrating my
10th
anniversary um joystick no no
no side pieces don't get that pie y'
been relegated that's what it is what I
told y I told
y yeah 10th anniversary of Lady s it's
not hyperbole when I say that this woman
is uh she makes me better every moment
that I'm standing next to her she really
is that special so 10 years with her
which is is funny go it's my second go
around on 10 years if you wow yeah yeah
yeah you see you see the difference
right see the a difference there's a
difference so we celebrated that and
then this past Friday was her birthday
so we celebrated that in addition to
having like family here from PR uh so we
were like hosting them and running
around taking them places showing them
like took to the Rockets of course of
course of course you know you going to
do his play Broadway and all that all
the all the you know New York holiday
stuff told you keep I told you keep them
away from New York man it's scary he
live in New York I don't think he keep
from yor the in New York was fun though
we put him in the middle we we didn't
bring him to the hood though we BR to
the hood we I'm good all right so when
he comes in January he staying with me
okay so you close enough to the hood you
you're not there but you no no no the
Bronx is down the hill
Contin you so so I did that um I didn't
play too much in the way of games but I
did manage to beat Spider-Man but you
beat what okay I finished I saw credits
on it game let's go so I didn't do all
the stuff did you give it any awards
either exactly not one all right cool no
and this ain't cap man telling you right
now happened I I love that game for the
open world what they did did with the
two characters the gameplay of it they
they progressed it in a logical and
great way from the first one and from
Miles Morales I I thoroughly enjoyed
that the moment to moment in terms of
how tight the game felt was a little it
still feels great but it doesn't feel as
tight as that first Spider-Man or Miles
Morales like there's just little things
like like I keep telling you about
running up the building and doing that
you know when you hit X and and launch
yourself like so many times I go up and
do that and I don't see that X prompt
and I'm like y it's kind of it glitches
man it glitches so I'm like okay there's
a lot more going on I I give it that but
overall gameplay wise I loved it I'm
going to tell you right now that the
narrative and the way things played out
the the some of the acting spider team
no I oh no no spider Team No Spider team
I just you know let's Heal the World no
you not feeling that B I'm not listen i'
been I've been out of the comic book
Loop for a long time so I got to ask
King this King in terms of like the
maturity of the writing in books has it
progressed to a point that is beyond
what we saw in this game or we've been
seeing comic book games because I feel
kind I kind of like the writing it
should be if it doesn't feel super
mature still feels like it's catering to
it's because it's Sony well all right so
but then you look at the last of us
right it is insomniac but we you know
even the last of us like there's a lot
of things that people just did not like
that they strayed away from like then
you look at something like God of War
where it's like anything involving
humans and you know they were very clear
on like don't have like limb damage or
blood too much yeah but I think the
writing I think the writing feels more
mature the writing in Spider-Man oh yeah
yeah definitely is is geared towards
where Marvel is now and they're learning
because readership is down you know uh
uh uh copies and and site traffic is
down movies you see is down
they're they're going to make a pivot
and they're going to go into a different
direction they're going to go back to
what made them great so you can see it
and I know you noticed it in the game
because it's a lot of belittling
commentary between Mary Jane and um
Peter that is absolutely unnecessary and
and I thought it was borderline
harassment on certain things with for
certain people was certain things that I
saw I just didn't like the way you know
you you obviously Peter gets the symbios
suit and his personality changes and I
just don't I think honestly the best
representation I've ever seen of that
was in the cartoon like it it just and
obviously Spider-Man 3 told McGuire Love
You Toby no you
know I don't know it just that kind of
stuff turned me off I was like man I
expected this to hit harder like the
first one you know when you have that
moment at the end it hits harder you are
looking at a different time we are in a
completely different space from 2018
2018 conversation
Spidey they didn't like the rhetoric
around Spidey remember he was juggling
Mary Jane and black uh Black Cat yeah
yeah that whole
like does she have a child by
him is Spider-Man a dead beat dad that
thing and that conversation was really
deep that DLC was the best DLC that I've
ever purchased I remember you was going
for that yeah it it was dope and you
don't have that same level of
conversation here actually Peter is
secondary in his own game
100% it was it was a setup for Miles
right um I'm talking I'm talking about
Mary Jane because at the end remember
when they doing the house stuff and all
that stuff whatever and Y whatever sorry
let's not go that deep no no but you're
doing certain things and she's like say
it tell them he's a whole hero he has
been doing scary stuff his whole life so
he's able to have a conversation with
somebody that he's almost died before so
I didn't understand her telling him to
tell somebody else something it just I
felt I felt there were moments when you
when like when you look at the last of
us right and you see those that you have
you have the moments that they take the
time to show you those difficult
conversations those conversations that
feel very human and here it felt like
all that was jumped over like like like
you said that part right there the story
is all over the place right the
conversation never happened right it's
all of a sudden they just do it and he's
like oh yeah yeah uh you know I'm I'm
going chill for a bit or whatever I I
think that's why so many people was
upset that it it seemed like they were
retiring Peter like way too soon and
like way too before he should be
retiring it's like you could easily roll
with both of them for a while until you
eventually put the the sled up for one
of them
like how did you feel in the game to
that how did you feel about craving and
the methodical going through with
certain characters that you just didn't
see n that stuff you just had to read
about it or get a video I mean audio
tape right and that's the thing that
well I didn't do I haven't done all the
side stuff yet so I haven't I've done
little bits but I decided to just be
line the story so I know there's more
there but the little bit that I did do
of it I think when you think about
Craven's overall story I think fits and
I think adds texture to that character
that I really like I think if there's
any character there that I really liked
it was it was craving and they could
have even done more to sort of flesh him
out a little bit but I his motivations
were pure like it was it was very very
very pure motivations and I love when it
when a villain has that so beyond that
everything else felt like I said the
game play it's a great game but there's
something about it that just feels like
some parts of it rushed and like got you
take it away
from the best question is do you think
starford deserve that game that spot in
that game of the contender over over
Spider-Man man I I don't think either of
them deserve to be there spicy I'm going
keep it a
keep everybody on the on Stars should
have gone in there yeah everybody on the
internet that's arguing you got seven
nominations and no W's not this year it
was a crazy year crazy A crazy year
every people talk about they got exactly
what they deserve I love you hip hop but
that was not Spider-Man's not g it the
year y I saw K that uh he was going
crazy but it's not ging a you funny so
that's been it sir after your that's
been it hopefully over this break I will
play Alan Wake that's why I hope that's
your next one no doubt no doubt and of
course we have the incredible hocus aka
the EXs gamer ooh the prophet of Xbox
swamy King of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the Xbox
Frontline movement ooh beloved Lord K
how we doing sir I'm doing fantastic I'm
doing better than reg just PR great uhoh
bro you was the
champion uhoh you came in looking like
the
Challenger you didn't win one round on
my scorecard oh damn your trainer your
coach was out of pocket the whole time
his mouth was running and he left it for
you to back it up you didn't tell him a
pull his coat at any point in time and
tell him tone it down because all he was
doing was giving Devin Haney Fuel and
what I've noticed is ever since Devon
Haney beat lomachenko yeah in that close
fight Devin Haney is going up he is the
best new crop he's better than tank to
me oh whoa whoa and let me let me tell
you why he's better than tank whoa
opposition okay you see the competi all
right right his opposition that he's de
yo Devon Haney's last 10 fights not one
of them was easy M every last one of
those fights could have went either way
and this kid steps up to the challenge
he be he was unified champion in his
Division and went up through the belts
away and went after the dude that nobody
wanted to fight reg prog that's what's
up and made him look like an he looked
like young Floyd and you can see his
time with Floy pretty not not not not
pretty boy he looks like a young money
May oh okay okay defensive right very
defensive very cuz he had reges hurt but
didn't finish him got but um other than
that you know Xbox front line show was
crazy on Friday see um I'm
just uh I I don't know humbled yeah you
know by everybody that comes through
that shows love that you know supports
and they getting the hang of the Callin
so that is dope um I got to give a super
shout out to adct uh yeah y'all really
don't know how much I depend on him and
like yo why isn't he not on everybody's
show I feel that I'm seeing it get
better though I'm seeing I'm seeing some
improvement in this I want to see it get
a whole lot more better like yeah you
know like get on the show like you know
what it is I'm going tell you what it is
I'm say I go like what it is but man you
know he he's strong in his convictions
right so whatever he feel he going to
say I think certain people be scared be
like yo if he k i don't cuz some people
some people when they run their show
they want to control The Narrative of
the show so when ad is in when adct come
around you not going to tell I think
it's that tell you what I think because
I be seeing the same people invite
people that I know for a fact they can't
control on their show like I'mma tell
you what it is what is it they don't
think he's as
important as he is no people in this
community think I'm the token white guy
let's keep it R okay well you you you
try to get our demographic you just here
for the num yeah right no I'm just here
you here for the Caucasian I'm here I'm
just here for the for the people of my
complex we got one shout to West
Virginia we got we got one one all we
need that let's get er er for the wi we
we need ER and Asian Asian female and
then it's over it's over what's up baby
girl it doesn't matter if it's a woman
or man the No No we got to get the
female as and then we going to have a
full Cipher we we should probably do
that
thing oh yeah about that maybe maybe
after this
transition this ain't the good
transition to do that I'm saying before
the show ends yeah of course of course
of course of course of course yday uh oh
for everybody that RNR with the Lords I
went to go see Godzilla minus one
yesterday and I know some people's like
oh the only Godzilla I know about is
Godzilla X Kong is coming out okay no
too released I think it was December 3rd
or December 1st Godzilla minus one this
is the first Godzilla movie they went
back and rewrote the story to you know
that movie didn't even have $50 million
budget it didn't oh wow 50 million it's
better than it's the best Godzilla movie
I've seen in the last 20 years I have to
see it now the fact that you're this
hype and you got me to I don't I've
never watched Joy until the last one cuz
you told me to watch it why was crying
in the movie theater oh damn at the end
who's crying in the Godzilla movie wow
okay she was crying so it's set in the
in the the the early 50s late 40s and
it's a it's a love story to be honest
with you Godzilla is just an overarching
um entity that's there but it's it's
it's a a story of redemption and it's
the best story of redemption because
there's a lot of people that get
redeemed in this movie okay and you know
Godzilla himself is it's a reason for it
but I go check it out I don't think it's
going to be in the movie theaters long I
think it's going to you know get out of
the movie theater soon because it wasn't
even supposed to be launched over here
but um too fought and and they thought
it was great Pro promo for Kong um X
Godzilla um what I was gonna say what I
was playing this week fortnite
definitely the switch over it was
incredible this stuff is
incredible did you see what they did to
Peter so not only did they bring Peter
from Family Guy into fortnite this dude
is buff he look like he look like he
make beefy he make beefy Cognito look
look small he beefy out that's that
episode when he he got um he take all
the steroids hold hold on where's my
phone where's my pH yeah show me the Jo
when you get when you get a chance it
that's dope I was playing that um
downloaded Boulders gate and then was
told you can't play until we ready to
stream I was like what why why can't I
play game of the years in Xbox oh
I said I waited all this time for them
to drop this game I can't do it he's
like nah you got to wait until I say so
and I'm like I don't like addict like
that D
much but um I was playing my um rag oh
man I that's where I play C Stars yeah
you you like yeah you you you like to do
the traditional almost like the 16 bit
you take you take your handheld back to
the essence I know what you do you don't
like to play the the more powerful the
roag is like your Game Boy yeah he like
a noad or something you yeah look at
look at him look how big he is Chill
hold on wait a minute let me pin that
that's that chill he hit it hard like
that's crazy that's crazy and then when
you take his shield down and stuff like
that he grab his knee go oh he do the he
do the knees he do the knee you got to
find them they in the map um oh that's
lit that's lit I was playing that and
then uh my son and I was playing some uh
Mario mushrooms I got to finish that
game stupid I can't anyway and sorry you
going to say something I was going to
say and I do want to I forgot to
say another sin on the Video Game Awards
this year is not giving one one award to
octopot traveler to like get award
domination that's I mean not getting one
nomination
off nom for anything hell no oh bro you
got flame out here flame is like our
boycot bro I know people that going hard
right now it's disrespectful I would say
I'm actually ening this game just as
much as I enjoyed C stars did it release
in game pass on Xbox yeah it's not even
in game it's not even on Xbox no
octoo listen good good you shouldn't get
nominated for nothing yo you penalizing
over here you play that's what you do
that's it that's right if you not over
here we don't care oh my Lord I cannot
no doubt definitely a fantastic game and
of course we have the gamein himself the
Shinobi Lord Cognito spread that real to
the r P not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear shout out
to Mr M plays had a good defiling du
talking about obviously gab Awards which
we going to talk about as well shout out
to uh T gu Travis and ebontis for
holding me down while I was streaming
the game was so I'll be back on last
word this will be my final week on that
and then uh yo shout out to The Graphic
God man cuz you know as you know Lord
kog is out here promoting that healthy
lifestyle that health is wealth so we
outside that health is wealth is done go
check that out it's in the team store
right now Emoji up right now go check
that out man he did his thing he did his
thing man so we going for that's what we
try to promote cuz I know the game is
out here you know we out here playing
these games mad hours sitting
stationary dope yeah he killed that he
killed that man shout out to Young
dreads with the inspiration you know
what I'm saying for the vision but um
yeah I'm trying to promote that because
at the end of the day we got to be
around for these games yall know the
type of year I had you know physically
you know what I'm saying it was a really
scary year and they told me yo if you
wasn't on your health is wealth if you
wasn't a healthy guy guy this could have
took you out so it definitely means a
lot to me and a lot of my brothers
that's suffering in silence y hit me up
and say Hey coog you motivate me a
couple people that told me they had
Bells when I told my Bell's posy story
on um Duke they were like yo that
inspired me I had it I listen you know
what I'm saying that kind of stuff so yo
let's keep doing it let's keep that
rocking for the New Year healthy Gamers
healthy lifestyle all that good good as
far as me what I've been playing I'm
playing um finish cocoon finish cocoon
um love the game love the game fantastic
um like I was telling you King last time
um remember the inside developers had
kind of split and then it was you know
the guys that made Somerville people
that made said Mom and Pop mom and pop
now look mom did her thing it's just
that I feel like she's extremely puzzle
heavy so if puzzles is more of your
focus and solve it's almost like
Inception like Puzzles though these are
some ill puzzles like there's like four
times I'm like all right put your ego
aside Co you cannot figure this part
like I had you had shout out to MAA
shout out to MAA 91 you saved me bro you
saved me the game is so deep he one of
the puzzles with in his video that he
that I got stuck at he put incorrectly
had to put an edit it was like hold on
y'all if y'all see my video cuz I was
like wait a minute I did this ain't work
either he was he had to put an edit in
his video shout out to Bak said get
gonna say something to this day I
remember like one of the puzzles like
when I was really young that like really
frustrated me there was a God of War I
can't remember which one I think it was
the original God of War when you was in
um what was that Temple that you was in
the original Pandora's box or on the
back of uh U one of those Titans I can't
forgot it's been so long and there's a
part where these pillars came up right
and there was you you had to bring the
pillars up but you had I went up to top
I was like I don't get it there's
nothing at the top of these pillars what
is going on the problem is on the on the
to the left at the back on the side of
one of the pillars that you bring up was
an was an entry down oh so they wanted
you to bring the pillars up and then go
down when the pillars arise and go down
and to this day is like that was like
some of the most like we we we going to
we going to mess with you puzzling I've
ever seen yeah this is that this is all
that there there's a couple like that
that's insane and you're talking about
interdimensional worlds worlds inside
another world where you can travel out
go in it's crazy I'll salute to that um
I can said the ending was cool I still
want to give pops his his dudo cuz what
it is s Somerville still has that I
guess because this is more of an alien
and Inter calacal Dimension stuff
Somerville is more grounded in humans
right and feel tells more of an
emotional story if almost War of the
world if aliens came to take us out and
then at the end it has a has multiple
endings in um some of them I heard kakur
has a secondary ending but this the way
they did it without spoiling too much
there's a part where you as the humans
is like okay what now we up and you got
a choice on how you could handle dealing
with these Invaders so to speak at the
very and it's so well done it's like I
like games where you try to make sense
to the end like what were they trying to
say you know what I'm saying like well
it's one of them joint so still play
some of it I know they got a little
technical issues but I still say Seville
is the joint okay I got to shout you
out King Arthur tale that you put me on
to a la term based newno apparently this
is a big PC game um it's King Arthur kns
tale it's now down with ID at Xbox in
their um demo program yo fully Vo voice
acted on some Camelot Joint King Arthur
died him and his Nemesis m whatever
killed each other they died on the
battlefield somebody's they resurrected
it's a you got to form the new night to
the round table bro it's it is fire this
game is double a energy on certain
things no doubt little little graphical
here double a energy you know what I'm
saying but fully voice acted on
everything it is it's fire bro like yeah
Xbox I'm glad y'all got them down with
the program this is demo for free right
now on the Xbox store again King Arthur
nights tale I'm I'm loving that so I've
been rocking that and then of course a
little little Destiny sneak in the new
season of the wish and that's it but
that's been pretty much it for me I was
going to tell you like so they some of
the the devs that broke off to do uh
Somerville and the Des broke of D cocon
the Somerville guy is one of the main
guys from Play De cocon guys those are
just team members right okay okay the
main other guy is still with play dead
so he's oh so play that still played oh
so these is oh these the wuang
Affiliates that did exactly were were
devs from like some of the star
employees so so so also mom is still mom
is still over
there this whole time I was talking and
I was muted okay this whole time you say
probably W going to say did you say
anything about K cuz I was like damn I
was giv I was like yo I was like it's
dope I was I was saying a whole bunch of
stuff yeah I was like cuz he say that
about G man forget you I was muted and I
looked I was like why ain't they talking
to me was probably spoiling something
good looking good looking on that King
on though that that right there yeah so
that's been pretty much it but um what
else we got want to do the super chats
we got things we got to talk about yeah
we got some super chats we got yeah we
got we got some bills that we'll pay in
in the middle of the show and one that
we could do up front now no doubt um
after after the stuff we got a nice bill
for you guys too yeah we got Doctor
Strange Love member for one month Lord
bronze be back maybe if Jeff didn't have
dumb puppets and celebrities who clearly
want to be anywhere but there talking we
would have more time for devs to speak
Amen to Amen to that we going talk
discuss we going talk I mean well we
could we could like answer his chat I
mean his his text listen that Gonzo
thing the muffet thing Jim Henson that
is a staple in award show and for for
him to get this I thought that was great
just just for me for you for yeah I know
this ain't Hollywood yeah and that's
that's my thing with it it's like you
don't have to you don't have to follow
don't don't they record it out there in
Hollywood mean it's in the mic what
theater is it
in hold up let's let's talk about it
what we actually talk about doubt cuz
it's a long discussion this is a good
it's a good discussion it's a good
discuss fact then we have Robert kellet
$2 chat Jeff is after kojima's joysticks
back his face is bubbling his face is
bubbling he call this man out we'll
discuss we'll discuss shout out to Xbox
CH move baby I love what you're doing I
love I know the whole move I see the
play there we got Robert Kell again $5
Super Chat blessed dayl Lords despite
the good announcements the ad Awards the
ad Awards should be called the Winter
Games Fest at this point the awards
don't matter wi to E3 and I disagree
yeah then we got Don Sega the
otu he come full circle I love it in
light of Sega getting its first non
Atlas or RPG related W since publishing
Bayonetta one I have changed my name to
put respect on that name thank
you evening it was bro from a Nintendo I
had grow man we going to talk about that
seg sure shout out we already
have in theat I got to talk to
that I need to talk to you the person I
was thinking about besides you beat us
inward but for that I need to know what
he's feeling right now we gonna get
well go ahead listen we only got 200 and
something likes that's what some of the
likes It's the final one of 2023 come on
if we get over 600 likes king would do
handstand walking up the steps why you
always trying Tock King behind content I
don't know why he think I'm going to do
anything physical yeah it's always
if we do this
King it's always trying to get King to
do something say I always say the most
out without without his
discussion continue so yeah I mean we'll
talk about it in at length just real
quick I get we talking about him doing a
handstand I need my this my Sega brother
hand stand up decep understand like when
we was the only one that saw it in the
chat when I cuz I put it in our chat I
was like
I was yelling in the chat yeah it was a
moment because for me I remember like
years ago we've been talking about this
for years like yo bring these games back
and make them like treat them like
double A triaa like like properties and
really bring them back and modernize
them and rethink recontextualize these
games and they been doing it shout out
to everborn because ever czy has listed
as much on on on Twitter um so yeah they
they were listening to us for sure we'll
talk about
we got Pat F member for four months Lord
bronze let's end the IOP 2023 with a
bang cheers everyone yeah yeah salute
salute then we have Craig holigan
gifting one I membership put the crest
in the chat for Craig CRA Julie's on
Deck then we got Danny passion official
real the real one chat yeah not the fake
one not the fake one stop with that the
fake one never fake drin to love from
Florida Blaze Blaze said blaze blade it
is exclusive oh we G discuss we will
discuss we will discuss we got uh Cedric
H remember 41 months silver put the
Cress in the T of Cedric h no doubt we
have Don Sega the otaku once again
follow Super Chat what Sega just did is
what I need from Nintendo with 1080
snowboarding star Tropics mother/
Earthbound 3D Donkey Kong and muras
sama's Castle 1080 coming back would
really like excite me would be awesome
does it run any better and I know they
just added it to Nintendo uh switch
online I don't know if it's running they
just do like a Donkey Kong not too long
ago well they're bringing back uh is it
Donkey Kong versus Mario they're
bringing I love that yeah I love that
they're doing that but not I mean little
Mario like got little hands they look
funny I want them to micro I want them
the work of Microsoft and see they'll
that rare remake um uh Donkey Kong 64 oh
wow okay they don't want to do that
they're making millions of dollars and
actually make it fun yes I love that
continue There we got Michael Mooney
five pound Super Chat what if blade is
part of a bigger game say game say with
ID working on Ghost Rider than other
studi Studios getting their Marvel
character that' be crazy why can't
people just get one
game people can't be happy yo we got to
a day and age where you ain't even get
what the product you already not
satisfied now we can take over the world
I'm like just get let's get what we got
first don't forget we got another
giveaway from M zip I put it in the chat
don't forget that one don't forget that
one so who's who's reading that one get
that one
Davis we'll do that later we continue I
see Z in there zi the DP I see you and
we got Robert kellet $2 Super Chat s had
to fight that those cat-sized rats damn
that's right wow NY rats baby New York
sler a full
effect acting like he don't live here
this exactly then we got neopet God $2
Super Chat Lord s to joystick please
wrap it up
[Music]
wow back to me that H different that it
different pause crazy wow boy I didn't
miss that last we yeah woo okay moving
on me see where we're at there we got RR
Jr
10175 super chat did you notice during
the Sega reveal that two people were
using Xbox controllers I didn't notice
that oh
W yeah we know what's up very nice tag
team to kill
come then we have country big
94 remember for two months Lord bronze
happy Sunday Lords just want to say
thank you for all the shows this year
hoping more success in 2024 also chat go
sub to addict and King's channels yes
yes that's a fact shout out to Country
big man y out here doing it real big I
see you out there doing the wrestling
promo y out here all the shows doing
your thing we we see you when you blow
up don't forget us man cuz I know you
about to blow up shout out to uh uh dipt
he's actually you know putting a lot of
effort into his Xbox Channel definitely
got guys go check that out too man go
check that out the dip down he's got
another crazy patreon question for us
too we can't spawn new Talent if no one
tried it looks to new people yeah for
real yeah dip down and he plays fortnite
with me so go check his stuff out go
check him out we'll check them out
salute and we got let's put the crest in
the chat for Snake Eyes 327 welcome to
Lord bronze shout out to you sir
appreciate
that now we got Robert kellet $2 Super
Chat kellet King's been right King's
been right on fortnite rocket racing is
lit yeah yo
Kelly that's Lord G me that net y'all by
the way let y know that's the newest one
of the newest members you know what I'm
saying Lord's G but yeah man yo what
doesn't fortnite have at this point it's
crazy it does everything everything it
is and what's crazy is it should be in
every genre every year oh technically it
should win live service every year it
should be a flooding of this the J it
doesn't it never wins it didn't win this
year right it's won before but it won in
the beginning the yeah like a couple
years back when it really first got on
the scene it won like one year yes one
year no and then they just started
giving you know let's get other people
in the cat but isn't it Epic on the
board or something like that and I kind
of like how a game in 2005 came out and
it had opportunity to win something now
it's back let's give other people more
opportunity let's see what it is
continue he said isn't Epic on the board
they they are on the so maybe they say
yo don't put us no don't have us win
because it's going to look look crazy we
already know what y'all doing with Kong
Tim swe about that about that smoke he
wants that W I
know then we have Michael lcu Jr member
for 38 months bronze third person Blade
game for Xbox so proud for the culture
yes we gonna talk about
that and we got Robert kellet once again
$2 super chat iPhone owners don't sleep
on Sonic Dream Team I Heard mobile joint
mobile all right then we got Michael SK
junor once again $10 Super Chat the
finals game is crazy it brings me back
to Bad Company 2 Vibes that's the
battlefield D full destructibility it
looked good I heard did Dr I get a
chance to yeah it's doing what Crackdown
was supposed to oh D there you go
technically there you go then we have
the doctor 63 $2 Super Chat drop Blade
with the new sexy series
X I don't know that'll be ready by that
time'll be ready by then but listen part
of me does feel like Blade's going to be
a launch title for the next
conso yeah feels no I mean they just
started though King they did say they
just started on development but they got
the AI thing going on so oh now
you be ready next year yeah so the
development time going to be half it be
crazy you
stupid but that's dis BL sry mersa
and and Wesley snip it it come out the
same day as the movie uh the movie Blade
yo let's go King doesn't want Wesley
Snipes anywhere on the the no I don't I
don't want I don't want him to touch it
at all oh shout out to Asa from game on
daily I seen him in the M Sonic Dream
Team looks like the most Sonic game in
years hope it gets outside of Apple soon
okay all right oh you talking about that
dream that's inside the Apple Store that
um everborn was going crazy I got to see
I haven't checked out yet I got an
Android it didn't hit over here sorry oh
damn it's just like Game Pass okay okay
that's what we doing okay if it ain't
hitting I don't hit it all right I see
what we doing mobile Wars now on that's
right okay I see what we do Microsoft
about to get the store so it's it's all
they the Ops now okay okay I get it I
get it now it's front L Xbox front L I
get it I get it
Google when I see you Google I see I see
you in the streets again I see you in
the streets when I see Catch Me in
traffic
Google I see you killer that's like the
next evolved version to catch me outside
yeah oh catch me in traffic fact yeah
cat me traffic let's go Jesus what we
got we have elemental po $5 Super Chat
oh God of War actor joke wasn't the sin
it was him saying a company I would
never work for that would piss people
off no he said they I listen I I'm not
even mad at what he said if
he I think people need to relax I mean
it is a game show to celebrate devs and
you disrespect well I mean it's a thing
it's the themed award show that the
actual person that created it didn't
care about the awards so why should
he the dev what I think it is I don't
think that's slandering the devs though
that's that's that's real Will Smith
slap you in the face ener like I it was
over the top like I no not what not what
he said was over the top the reaction is
Over the Top If he had this if he said
the game sucked that's one thing but he
just he commented on the shortness which
everybody's commented on he didn't say
oh the game sucks or whatever right that
that to me was fine now the whole thing
and then people misinterpreting the fact
that he said that's a company I would
never work for no he's saying that
because he like he quote unquote diss
them so they'll never hire him joke
people are taking it as he said no I
never want to work for them to me people
just don't know how to read to me it's
like the same people that are that are
like saying he was out of pocket it's
just like they're the same people that's
saying
comedy it's like it's going downhill
like comedy where y it's it's just a
joke like it's not like just think is
the people that don't like him took
offense right me he did hold up the
awards last year he did hold up that
part okay they had they they made a WAP
it up B box yeah it's so it's those it's
those people that didn't like him or
whatever that had a pre-bias to him and
then when he said it they like yeah let
me go and they threw it on him too as
soon as he started talking they played
the music you know like they did they
did nice joke they did that that's they
should have got Anthony Mackey off that
damn stage that's they should man we
talk about who they should have gotten
off that stage let's let's let's
continue back to you back to you yeah
spart go 17 two Prim Super Chat BGA is a
Hollywood style show format accept
it we'll
see true then we got hary chanani member
for 29 months Lord
goge hardge the homie blesss salute most
important outcome of TGA Nintendo 3 Game
Awards One Xbox 3 game awards one
PlayStation zero game awards one get
your B K get your B happy holidays Lords
God bless to you and your fam will see
next it's just like the God of War a
what he saying that's
false he's telling the
truth he's reing way to he's reing the
fact that PlayStation get it once I
can't he just said it once it a say like
he said it a bunch of times
we got zip the drip Davis $2 Super Chat
all I want for Christmas is a big oh weo
oh we oh
we we got to take care of zip later with
the for sure slute then we have Doctor
Strange Love $5 Super Chat Jeff is
giving me a run for my money he rides
kojima's joystick fast and harder than
that do yo
yo that's the other one that's the other
one k k that's the other one you got to
give
other back to you
s yeah you see you show back up and this
happens crazy thank you for your Pat
always in support of our independent I
appreciate oh man then we have a second
they got jumped we have
kante bless salute to the Lords in chat
and salute to Sega for finally reading
all of everborn letter and using actor
that looks like him in the a facts they
got all a fan mail from everborn they
did exactly what we wanted facts shout
to then we have Stitch uh
6669 member for 48 buds Lord gold can we
also address the comment from the cookie
cutter cradles voice actor about a game
that is bigger than God of War I can't
jum we'll get to that Xbox guys deck
they not feeling it they not feeling
that then we got Grumble Grumble $2
Super Chat 1080 folks did VR
snowboarding game no uh 1080 is there a
VR snowboarding game I don't know I
think so not that I remember but that
seems like a nightmare yeah that seems
like
a pro to I think I've I've actually had
night like that
so like someone it's like a saw J saw
thing where they put a VR head over my
head skate you got a snowboard down this
mountain you're gonna like it there you
go sow one then we got uh let's put the
crest in the chat for Cedric H gifting
membership I wonder what that Al was Boy
R me along put the CR up the Christmas
happy holidays for everybody thank you s
that's what's up memberships that's fine
that's thank you and we got Doctor
Strange Love Again $5 Super Chat you
Xbox dudes better not come after my man
Chris judge for giving Activision that
deserve smoke he was speaking nothing
but facts I mean he wasn't wrong I'm
just saying for balance purposes sled
sled Hamber was forced to make that game
in less than a year and and dud still
pull out us a quality product
considering the situ so there's going to
be emotional I just want y try to
understand the other side that's why a
lot of people were in their feelings
those wrong well they made the game and
that they got they were forced to make
in a year less development time than
everybody else and you ripping it they
they he a they ain't gonna feel that I
love the fact that Microsoft made sure
that that game was out so that's the
last one on the do get out of here I
think I think I think listen I I don't
agree but I will say this maybe when you
think about the audience there and how
fickle they can be may maybe not the
place to say the joke I I I don't think
I think he did exactly what he needed to
do to keep his name trending people are
still talking about him right now so
whether you love him or hate him he did
something that was powerful enough to
keep us still talking about him I'm for
it hell yeah I'm for it because to me
these these the these companies and I
don't necessarily think he was attacking
the devs he attack a mainly act Division
and it's like that it's no no
accountability you know he he two hours
and instead of people saying yeah maybe
you should have worked more on the game
people attacking him for stating facts
so if you want to attack him for what he
said you got to attack IGN gam Spa who
else reviewed to
set they
on I'll say this though I'll say this he
yeah he I don't think he knows enough
about games to be attacking Activision
over he was like he just he's going to
catch Whoever has the the front line was
funny but at the same time he is a
consumer and if he bought that game and
it was that matter long don't you think
he has the right to say something yeah
he has the right to say whatever I'm
just people have the right to feel away
if you actually made the game was in a
swe be honest with you you said you
don't think he played God of War no I
don't think so wow probably not probably
not I think he's I think he's that vain
that he would yeah I'm kind of curious
besides that if Jeff knew he was gonna
say that I think he freaked out yeah I
think not no I think no I think I think
they knew exactly what they knew the
balls was coming oh they going to say
Xbox tax be careful careful and you know
what if the reason why I say that and
I'm not going atad him being vain I'm V
if was they they've never made negative
uh NE negative remarks on there you go
on a on a Activision game in all these
years see I knew it was coming open open
I knew it was coming you know what cogs
on to something you know what he's on
something I knew it was coming I knew I
knew the tax I knew the tax people were
coming the tax was it's not over tax is
not over even though y'all won all the
awards and so win we we didn't win all
the awards we only won three y look like
you had a rebate this year no we a got
no rebate we just got the game that we
supposed to win one all right we going
to move on we going to move on I can't
wait till we get to that we get there
time it's gonna be lit then we got uh
dub member for 22 months Lord bronze so
hype on blade peeps hating online it
that it's Arcane but I think they are
perfect hope it's more hit man/
Dishonored than DMC I hope it's be
honest shout out to D the
T my Lord I lost front kick you s a kick
yeah you know he do copper weather too
that boy get busy
Contin then we got Atomic Customs $2
Super Chat blade should use the Afro
Samurai sword mechanics I I don't
remember what they were that game was so
dope I love that game there's only one
of them I more than one afro afro I
don't know I was on my PlayStation cuz I
was watching the movies then I went
straight to the game I don't remember I
think it was two I think it was salute
salute then we got Spartan go 17 5 pound
Super Chat that blade beat was crazy as
a friend speaker I like the introduction
of those French trap drums also did
y'all feel about how did y' feel about
Jordan Peele I fell
down yeah
brev I love the fact that you the the
whole time during that whole segment I'm
looking on my watch okay WRA this up man
wrap this up Jordan pill Jordan pill is
a big thing the atoro when he was out
there they went mad long yeah buto
was kajima they did a long segment so
you got to give him the same respect no
we know what's going on and he said none
of the respect get off the stage oh my
God Jesus that's that's beasty oh shout
out to your man Super Chat because I
also was really feeling the beat that
they used during the blade joint it it
was definitely it felt like current it
was current it was now the the the
language was now you know and and blade
doesn't hold his tongue so you heard the
curse so you already know this going to
be a rated all
game 18 no he already said it's mature
mature let's go and for the we going to
talk about we going to talk about
continue I can't
wait oh sage in there the tax gag is in
there oh I can't wait
we got Craig hooligan remember for 15
months tuning in while grinding my PE
organs so I don't experien so many pies
of L
wow shout out to co for recommending
cocoon as a nice break from the
pain I don't know what else you're doing
but salute to your enjoyment of
K let's just keep the enjoyment there
everything came before we don't know
what's going as long as you have fun
playing Kon that's what Co talks
about then we have J Boy On The
Run he on to run he on to move all right
let me know if you found R
Kelly be safe out there brother be safe
though yeah we got tell Batman he can
take a break Xbox taking over okay all
right people like that blade Batman has
taken a break trust me he has taken a
break the dirt
nap shout out to go M then we got Lord
Metroid remember for 26 months Lord
silver super CH sending the Nintendo
Inquisition on this Don Sega fraud
dude sees him sees oh he called da Taco
tur tur wait this Metro coming at him
Benedict Arnold oh wait who is coming at
Don and taco who this Metroid Metro he's
there he's holding strong okay okay said
Mario Wonder is my game of the year
Nintendo Nintendo civil war going on yo
it's Nintendo beef it's not even it's
not even tars of the Kingdom you said
Mar wonder that boy said you a turn he
said you dropped your flag yeah he
did yo not you're not popular anymore yo
Dam it was Blood In Blood Out over there
V
Locos Locos
forever s what he said
next time it won't be blood on my
night you know
what yo that scene is crazy I know is Yo
blood and blood out watch those locals
forever yeah oh man
Street shout out to my man Southbound on
God God yo he official southbound
official southbound is official
salute
then we got drive drive by
Joe we got Man On The Run and we got
drive by Joe today oh it's it's lit in
the street we got uh Minecraft ran my
four-year-old daughter's life fortnite
Lego drop she looked at me last night
and said I'm bored of Minecraft fortnite
Lego is fire
yeah yo D How You Gonna out Lego Lego
yeah crazy it's crazy night is just next
L and yo I'm going tell you right now
too that Roblox I don't know because I
to this day you tell me what I don't
know what Roblox is my nephew was
watching I think kids like to watch the
stuff in Roblox even more than play it
and he was watching some videos on like
what is that he's like oh this is that
the other it was super popular I got how
many people watching it I was like what
is that he's like that's Roblox wow it
was just some random weird you see 3
million uh views yeah it's crazy yo I
want to ask anybody that's in this chat
that knows this the other day I turned
on of fortnite I went inside the store
and I do this all the time because I'm
looking for the skin and they had the
Invincible uh package they had uh um
Mark they had uh his father omn man they
had uh Adam uh uh Adam Eve and they had
like some other stuff that was going on
there right and then it had them IND
individually it was up there for one day
yeah and then I went back in but this is
not what they do you understand like
you're able to have it it usually for
three or four days this is the first
time I saw Invincible skin and I said
you know what I'mma get it tomorrow I'm
not going to get it right now because I
got some stuff that I'm doing I there
like a week and a half ago yeah that's
that's what I'm talking about and then I
saw it and I went back to get it and it
was gone and I was gonna text
Bill what happened I think I think they
made a mistake and put it inside the
store when it wasn't supposed to go up
yet yeah because they didn't announce it
or anything okay okay yeah yo that that
game has it those two games have a
different energy I was with my nephew
yesterday right and he's like yo what's
your podcast again Theo and I'm like
iron Lord's podcast he looks it up he's
like you guys only have
20,500
followers he was like you're not that
popular and I'm like I was like yo he
was like you're not like you're not like
Mr Beast I'm like really compar Mr Mr
Beast is literally the most popular
person on the whole
platform I'll take that him the funny
thing was then say your this your sister
child yeah the small one oh the one that
we want to strangle up me and K who want
strangle him sees him so then he he says
then he looks he said he looks up our
net worth no this me did not do our
analytics yo literally I was like n what
do you know about net worth he looked it
up he was like oh deal but oh he saw the
do yeah we well funded we funded Dam it
yo he I was like where did this child
come I don't know this child sees him
man KATU I never liked him I'm just let
know I never when I used to come over
the crib when he was born I never liked
I knew he was going to be a prop shout
shout out I I always liked him he was
very SM n n he had a way about it he's
always slick talk a lot of slick talk
you talking about are you talking about
the oldest or the youngest if you met
the one that I used to come over there
your sister your sister he's the oldest
he's the oldest so that's not him oh my
bad this is
11y okay I was giving a St I thought
this was him would see him now cuz he
still think he's a kid I still think
he's small him now I think he's big bad
big a problem for me yeah he's a whole
man right now oh all right my bad I want
no smoke but the little one the little
one no but the little one may just be
the most gangster one he the most
gangster he the
shooter tell me yall y'all whack but
your numbers though y good yo that's
crazy he said I think I should be
getting some more Christmas presents y
I'm like go over Mr Beast then no no no
what it is is we the we the Xbox it is
we don't sell a lot of units but our uh
our financial situation exactly we don't
move lot console the console numbers
ain't there but the revenue of the
profit is lit the revenue profit is nuts
facts exactly we heavy weights with that
revenue of the prop yeah right we
punching above our weights fact the man
said net worth out that's crazy these
kids wow yeah they out of pocket right
now they oh that's that's crazy when
somebody can look you up so yeah I'm
more concerned he's able to look at
this yo adct that SC the hell out of me
because if his little behind could do
that you know when we go to these pack
shows and stuff like that you know some
groupies outside that be like yeah they
net
worth mad pocket watching going on right
now pocket pocket watching I was like I
didn't even see where he got this number
from but I was like
wow he said don't show that to my tax
lawyer what's wrong with you hilarious
then we got combo uh $7 Super Chat dud
dudes only want to know if blade is
exclusive so they can decide if they
like the game or not # Xbox tax keep up
the great work y'all you not lying I
will give him that this whole thing is
causing out did you see what greedy did
K yeah okay what did he do yeah he did
something and took him down yeah yeah he
put the we going to keep going we going
keep it going we going keep it going we
keep it going we have hard to find for
30 bus Lord
Bron my
brothers been a while I hope yall are
good peace and love likewise to you
brother yes peace and love peace and
blessings then we have blue with the $5
Super Chat Damon Hatfield from a IGN
said Xbox has no games to Dustin's face
the Xbox tax lives yeah yo y yall F I
see this clip y' got going around it
it's kind of funny but I'm leave it
alone I'm leave it alone I'm leave it
alone
got some Jutsu sage5 Super Chat let's
keep it a buck judge said what he said
because Xbox now owns Call of Duty no
excusing that Jerry C he said that
here's the thing he got a things going
on the Jerry is the least of it I don't
think this has anything to do with like
an Xbox tax or anything this particular
thing it's like look we when we speak
about Call of Duty or something nine
times out of 10 who are we referring to
the publisher we rarely put any kind of
attack on the developers in any way
shape or form and I highly doubt someone
that's voice acting in these games is
going to be attacking the developers
either he need to be clear he need to be
clear who he that aim was for AC
especially somebody that is a voice
actor that could be doing some voice
acting work for them yeah and it's just
like look at the end of the day we can't
we can't scream from the top of our
lungs that we wanted them to say some
form of of of push back on some of these
Publishers and someone claps at one of
these games that these same people
laying people off are saying people
automatically want to act like they knew
exactly what he was talking about well
he better be careful don't act like you
secure with Sony because it was another
God of War guy before
you people get fired every day B yeah
that's right man people get laid off
every day
B just saying be careful be clear when
you taking your shot who you taking it
at that's all I'm saying of Duty be like
we got a small rooll for
you we need someone to yell that's
getting shot we we we need mercenary to
over there did you see did you see what
solid rev said oh no what rev said solid
rev said before uh I can't remember his
name uh before he he apologizes I just
want you to think what would what would
Kratos do and they said oh never mind I
played the last cratos you would
probably apologize oh damn and take your
kids to school oh man y mess move it on
move it on what if he what if he was
just reading the tele aprom had no
idea mad smoke that just smoke for a
batim joke that would be funny he said
that first part from the prompter and
then realized what he said and be like
well they ain't never hiring me it is
what it is salute all right then we have
BT Maverick 707 $5 lot of super chats
today I mean not it's a bad thing but
man there's a lot of super chats for the
last year well this is the last this the
last one they sending they love they
sending they love they trying to keep us
here they trying to keep us here yeah I
already know what they do that's what it
is that's what it is y'all do know adct
and I will be making videos and stuff
right and having shows right since Y
super chatting on y'all could get these
lights up though what for it's
1100 n it's a lot of PlayStation dudes
here oh you think oh that's what it is
that's what is yeah cuz they they want
to know what we going to say we the end
of the week we we the end all be all so
they trying to figure out what the what
the front line going to say what is s
going to be even is is is car going to
hold
back I want your guys' opinion how we
should handle this so uh you know I'm
not going to say his name because he
might not want his name being uh public
yes but someone made us a uh a statue
for the game awards the code of the
winner we just got to figure out we
should figure to get it started next
year we don't need nobody to get their
award
now
it's not going anywhere anyway so so so
we got to figure out a way of of getting
that cuz we don't want to dox ourselves
so he G to he going to drill it into his
table cuz he know it ain't
[Laughter]
going my heart man my heart was right
here playing World Series Baseball all
over again you someone said put a
picture of it someone said put a picture
of it
picture of the wall feel like I'm
playing what was it high heat with this
man heat all not a fun time I was not a
fun experience the same as playing you
and Tekken times it was like oh God I'm
not stop that stop that stop that
stop some days there was some days days
just go in it was a lot of people that
had some days but you
my are very
few playing you in basball seeing you in
basball that's a fact you you know the
bad part about wanted to play BB nobody
wanted to play baseball anymore cuz of
you nobody wanted to play no baseball
with you was it the days Tom sort and
all that what it was was we would pick
the easy um like easy hitting easy
pitching and all that other stuff yeah
he be doing the most complex he pick all
the difficult pitching beat still beat
you with the he playing with a handy cap
he individually controls everybody in
out I is fact I remember that like maybe
that's the reason he was beating you
guys though cuz he was individually
controlling them you guys were letting
the auto do it I remember that time I
was playing you and I said how did you
do that you was controlling A-Rod he
said yeah yeah I'm controlling everybody
myself I'm using pitch selection control
4 I'm not playing where you have to you
have a triple meter and you have to make
sure for Precision in my personal
opinion I just feel like they were out
class and didn't want to learn the game
that's pretty much it that's pretty much
bit of a baseball Sur he was ridiculous
that's that's why I'm trying to get you
to do the baseball he was he was orts
before orts in baseball that's what he
was moving on to updates yeah that's
what's up let me see where we at right
now let me see oh BT Maverick 775 Super
Chat how long is too long to announce a
game like blade if it's really four
years away from now the whole gaming
landscape could could be unrecognizable
thank you ILP um listen man get your W's
when you get that W get people excited
about I actually have a different
opinion I feel like they could have held
this in the talkg I know I I say this
right how what in the talk blade blade
yeah I don't think they should have
announced it yet oh we can't get these
people anything we we don't know what
they're doing what are they doing they I
need to be excited so I can see
something they need to show me they show
up oh they shouldn't show
nothing G bro no my thing is there just
there's plenty of [__] they could have
showed us that's coming out but see what
what I think is they understood that
they was going to show some stuff that
would not be in their next showcase okay
and those stuff was far out cuz we
remember Phil said they was going to
stop doing that far out stuff right and
then this is the direct result of the
ABK stuff we have so much stuff that's
how I feel can show you far out stuff
I'm tell I agree I agree I agree 40
Studios we outside I agree I think I
think the game awards was a perfect
place to announce something like right
that's right we a million people
watching I'll get it to when we get to
the topic cuz I feel with that I think
we get it if we can get to it it and we
have Senpai Kaiju $10 Super Chat he s by
Kaiju thank you Lord for being a a light
for most of my year when I've been down
you have been there with joy uh with my
recent diagnosis for health Cog has
inspired me to be on my beefy grind hash
Health as well salute to the
beef salute to the health as wealth go
get that Health as wealth there get I I
got I got to say something right because
um I had posted um a statue M that I had
got and a dude said wasn't you the same
dude that was here begging a couple of
months ago selling a statue saying that
you had a family
emergency and I was just like wow that's
kind of crazy um begging is somebody
putting up a GoFundMe or please help out
send money that's begging Bing and
having goods for sale
is something totally different right
right you know what you have of value
this is called assets so when something
goes wrong you can give up assets and to
give you some clarity my uncle passed
away didn't have any health insurance so
what I did was take my
savings what I had put myself in
Jeopardy so he can get buried properly
so I took all my savings that I had
because I got devastated dur during co
co put set up for him m i was $5,000
short so I said let me put up my my
favorite statues my Spider-Man statues M
there go so to see somebody say
something like that that's wild and I
was just like wow you could have just
hit me in a DM like King are you okay
there's a lot of people that hit me like
King are you okay no no it wasn't per se
me yeah it's about what you was doing
for it was it was my family member that
didn't deserve that he was the the the
the patriarch of of the family right so
it's like
damn you can't post stuff and be happy
for what you
have that's that's some sad stuff and
I've never seen that before I've seen
dude you could Twitter and social media
typ you can put your your baby just B yo
why your baby look like that yo bro you
can have the most heartfelt moment
there's always going to be some dude in
every comment in every chat that got
something slick to say cuz he miserable
with his life I I'm telling you that's
how it isare HT my though we dare you to
roll to any one of us and say that oh it
a not doing that these dudes is living
on the internet nobody coming outside
nobody we already know and nobody ain't
showing their face and they ain't on no
camera we know what time it is so that's
why I don't to me it's it's fake it's
make belie you you could do that behind
the keyboard when nobody can't see you
that's all that is of hurt my feelings
though it did because I I said I said
damn like really bro like anytime I see
something and and this is what I do as a
person if I see something that doesn't
concern me I don't need to comment
people everybody think they need to have
an opinion on everything yeah it's
ridiculous I trust me I feel
continue let me see hold on a second
find me in the bushes we got Stitch with
the $5 Super Chat my issue with this
comment C Kratos is that this is a time
of
Celebration he was celebrating that Dy
was short I feel you I feel you not
short as your new DLC even though it's
the apples apples the apples no one had
no issues when homeboy went up to said f
the Oscars that that that wasn't part of
the celebration everyone rejoiced him uh
so it's just like look man you guys guys
go for what you want then you don't go
for what so it's all the same thing at
the end of the day you know he went up
there attacked another Organization for
no reason during this night and people
people to this day people bring up that
situation in a very positive way so I
mean it is what it is yeah just stop
being offended by he said George Bush
Don't Care About Us I'm Yo Wild you wild
we not doing that move
on he said I love Turtles I
cannot ass
off again this is funny though $5 Super
Chat imagine somebody from the condem
team get up on stage and shout out to
God of War for having me fight the same
ogre in different colors for
hours
facts yall getting hype for the arena
mode that's not wrong though I mean I I
get it man I get it I get it Community
Real yeah like troll pink troll was
nice he he was over in a rock over there
next to Green troll I could not continue
then we got slowo back slap B for 41
months Bron blessings kima's response
and then the translation to just one
question took more time than any
acceptance speech from actual devs who
delivered games this year it's a fact
somebody broke down the actual breakdown
on time who had the most time for
minutes and then anytime the devs came
out it was like the least and they got
ran off the stage yeah yeah it's a real
it's a real issue slow then we got Dogo
padra with the five uh I guess this is
Swiss Franks Swiss Franks uh five Swiss
Franks people hating on kados I would
never hate on someone who lost the
ability to jump yo yo that's wow that's
what's up that's wow that's a good joke
I like that wow you get one of
these then we got Nikki B $10 Super Chat
what up Lords you're the goats Xbox
burning in the Stables I'mma get out of
here and go watch the video I found of
joystick and Strange Love running a
chill a buster on S
peace
yo hey
hey back to you s thank you for your
support nck the sad part about that is I
can't Revel in it I could just press a
button and hope that it does something
so when you when Co goes hey hey yeah
I'm just doing it for you keep your yeah
I can't hear my voice no more I don't
like we'll get that fixed we'll get that
fixed for next [__] y'all been saying
this for weeks we
event yeah yeah we'll get that
fixed sit down and shut up we'll fix it
l moving on see everybody's excited that
s's bad I told him how to fix it oh oh
there it is somebody Ain doing no it
doesn't do it like that for some reason
it just I don't know we we have Tech
Corner me add you have a tech cor this
what the what the update did was it
removed it and it doesn't make me loud
enough like so if I if I do it my old
way keeps me low we I can't hear y'all
let me know we'll could get take care of
it this week
okay there we have King is over when we
off when we off when we
off yeah now that now that we not going
to be here no more we fix it now we fix
it fix it the new year we'll fix it boy
we'll fix it next
year that for the next three weeks
exactly have King is overrated
$10 that's hilarious King Can't Hold the
Line because he can't hear the line hear
line line what's up glad to see
you what's up Lord glad to see you guys
in good spirits I just gotta say I was
streaming the game awards with my buds
who would take who who would take a shot
whenever they got uh a guest right it
was a whole mess oh that's crazy that's
C wow that y'all got lit I'm not built
for that anymore I can't old
days I thought you said that then drink
liquor right I can't be doing that
anymore
right doing a they was doing a drinking
game yeah every time vodka vodka salute
hell no that's not Advanced
vodka continue you be drinking cranberry
juice like
me let me see we got SJ Jitsu Sage once
again member for 31 months Lord gold I'm
pissed off that King even had to explain
that because of that clown that cat
deserves Street Justice for that n he
doesn't he just needs a strong talking
to because he doesn't know the
circumstances that are around him and
the sad part about it is I gave of
myself from from my savings and then
from my my collection facts and
and some people won't do it in this life
they don't care that much and it wasn't
like like me and my my uncle was super
tight it was just like like damn he
lived to 80 something years old for that
to go down like that and it only went
down like that because of Co right like
they they they messed up his SSI they
messed up his disability everything just
down down the tubes it sucks yeah sucks
man salute yeah just you just people
realize that everything that comes to
your mind does not have to come out of
your mouth thank you especially
especially especially if I don't go out
and do malicious things facts yeah
exactly that part no but you real
malicious with PlayStation so you had to
no but I want I want them to die though
see that's what and that dude cuz he
feel way about that hurt his soul so now
he he need to tell me King stop it hurts
me when you say they can't save K they
can't they can't say that they the ego
can't say that
part then you then we have you can't
find me in the
bushes why we can't find you this one
pound Super Chat shout out to you I hope
we find find you in
the he don't want to be found in
the then we have Miguel Ivars with the
five euro Super Chat check out all the
Disney IP reveals from recent years Iron
Man Black Panther uh cotor remake we'll
see Captain America Indie Etc pretty
similar to Blade yes yes yes yeah and we
have Dean Rivera $5 Super Chat did
Greenberg put the blade pick with the
Xbox logos to show it's exclusive
without having to say it bro subliminals
subliminals yeah I can't wait till we
get to that joint whenever we get there
yeah we'll get there
someday I'm just convinced we're never
going to get there bro I've never seen
this the Super Chat this is the realm
this early yeah
show last we have Lord Metroid $2 Super
Chat joke about everything sensitive
people be damned I agree damn it
fair then we have the everborn got $5
Super Chat Jet Set Radio Crazy Taxi jobi
shobi Streets of Rage Golden Axe Sega is
back baby and this is all paid for by
game not confirmed yet surprised me not
confirmed yet sir what surprised me was
Streets of Rage yo really yeah because
we just got we just got
engag but it but it wasn't Sega though
you understand so Sega was like we love
what y'all love what y doing right but
we outside yeah yeah bro I gr man man we
gonna get to it then we got Don Sega
theu $10 Super Chat Xbox got Jordan
Peele on OD south of midnight blade and
a wuang clan game coming they are for
the culture I'm looking at my I'm
looking at my melanin enriched anti Xbox
Brothers like Dr Umar yo I cannot
not the Omar reference oh man the
outside that's outside we have King is
overrated once again by Super Chat oh
adct you don't
you oh adct you don't want no more Super
chats but what do you what do you hate
money I like my time though trying to
keep the super super alive salute shout
out to y'all appreciate all the topic
all right so so what you want to handle
do all no I'll do that after we do the
patreon all right sounds good all right
we have two Pat oh another Super Chat
I'll get it uh sju Sage $10 Super Chat
King you are a real one you for ever
have my respect to sacrifice what you
love and take pride in others and to
share it publicly is the very definition
of class decency and humility respect it
just hurt my feelings that's all you
know um and not a lot of things hurt my
feelings on Twitter but that I was just
cuz I was super elated with what I had
and I had traed something that was
obscure and and the guy was like oh yeah
I I want that lizard statue and I was
like oh dope for real what you got for
trade and he was like oh I got this and
I was like okay good so I posted it
online and the dude said that I was like
damn that's kind of messed up bro like I
I I was like I don't know where these
people are coming from now yeah they def
all right patreon question we got two
I'm going to read one the second one
will hold off for reasons user not found
sorry if this question is too late
didn't see this until now just wanted to
ask if the Lords had a take on the new
paid mods creation system added to
Skyrim early in the week and possibly
how it could be used for Starfield and
other bgs games going forward for those
who don't know Skyrim had a 12 GB update
that changed a modding interface now
creation Club Community created free
mods and are all under the Creations
menu instead of being separated with
this there was also the new verified
community community Creations program
where mod authors who go through the
verific apption process can upload their
own pay creation this is a long payra
question I'm just let you know the good
thing about this in my opinion is from
what I've heard the modders actually get
a revenue cut 30% is the cut from what
I've heard could be different whereas
the creation Club they were contracted
out to make the content for bgs and were
just paid initially to make the content
if I'm remembering correctly that was
reported the pricing for the creation
club before was also a contentious Point
$4 for a single bowl with no questions
asked $2 for a decently sized dungeon
that also seems to be rectified with
this new system the most expensive thing
as of right now is $7 East Empire
expansion it also adds a lot of new
systems to the game again sorry if this
too late and sorry for the long question
hope everyone has a great Sunday so what
do we feel about these changes as far as
the take on the uh paid mods and
creation systems added to Skyrim and
then obviously you know while future
projects could maybe potentially
Starfield things of that nature what do
you think about it bab I mean unless
you're unless you're selling the Seas
you shouldn't care about this you know
people spend their time making these
products they should get paid for and
you know the thing is is the best
developers that aren't working for these
companies they're not going to do
something for free now if they feel like
they can monetize it you could
potentially get content that's better
than the actual developers content yep
and it's just like look like that's the
only way you're going to make this
process work is you know you give them
money they give you content that you
feel is worth your money uh you know
like I said only reason people would not
like this is if you sell in the Seas
like like it's the only reason you
wouldn't like this and I mean um
fortnite's doing it right
now so it's like this isn't new this is
this is kind of outdated to a point it's
like this has been done for a while and
it's just like I'm for it because I want
games like Skyrim to live on past like I
mean damn we what 12 13 years after
launch I mean I I want that to be starfi
in 10 15 years and the only way that
works is if there is incentive for
people that know these systems and know
how to make this content to get paid to
do it yep so yeah I completely agree I
said you know this is stuff that how do
you keep a game alive or you need
Community to be engaged and you need the
people that are creating for you to feel
like they're like they're being seen
like they're being appreciated and you
know uh with creation club and stuff
before that it was passions it was it
was passion projects also you know then
when bgs did see the quality in certain
things they you know obviously there was
some sort of payment for that but beyond
that it's just about passion so when you
couple passion with hey I know I'm gonna
get paid for this stuff especially if it
pops off that's that's a double win
right there so I think for me you
know enabling this now is going to get
people excited about okay let's jump
into Starfield let's see what we can do
with Starfield yeah what other
complaints people have with Starfield oh
these planets empty what if we start
building out bespoke things to do on
these empty you know the these these uh
these generated planets right things
like that like Starfield with this type
of support Starfield looks vastly
different in five years not to mention
10 years right right um and that's the
beauty of these games it's always been
the beauty of the game so I think for
them to really say hey we're we're going
to grow this with the community and and
allow you to benefit from it in every
way possible now instead of kind of
creating a little bit of a wall there I
think it's great I think it's a smart
thing to do your game lives on that's
what allows you to sell Skyrim 15 times
over whatever right so I think this is
great it's only going to get better
right um and let's see what these devs
could do with with with Starfield right
people have issues with little things UI
stuff or whatever there's somebody out
there working on that guaranteed and the
thing is I see people in the comment
section saying like it's a scam then
just don't pay for the stuff that's not
worth your money yeah but I guarantee
you there is something on that store
that you're like man I bet this game
would be better and wouldn't you
appreciate the fact that someone else
can be making what you want in the game
and you don't have to solely rely on
Bethesda cuz the thing is like the
difference between giving other people
doing like right I don't like Fallout 4
uh compared to the other Fallout because
I feel like a lot of the RPG system
isn't there I would easily pay
someone if they made a mod that implies
that RPG system from newas and stuff
into Fallout 4 and to me that's worth my
money right but f is clearly not going
to do that right so so it's just like I
don't want to be
100% on on the whims of whether or not
Bethesda finds it Priority to do these
things yeah I feel out yeah no doubt so
I'm K bars on the the mod oh he's talk
he's talking about uh the destiny 2
eververse that's what he was talking
about okay my bad all good all good um
thoughts on the creation system mods I
didn't know about mods in games until I
had went into to play I think it was
Skyrim or Oblivion one of the two and it
was like you know turn mods on or off
right and then I went to go look and see
what the mods was and they had one mod
for like 60 frames per second oh and I
was like oh this dude made
it like he did it and then you know they
ask for donation like you know it's
whatever fortnite does it all the time
if you like some of the rooms that these
dudes create and they take time to
create these rooms um adct and I I think
we applied a couple of times uh to get a
create a thing for
fortnite that engine is so robust they
actually give you a strip down version
of the unreal engine five and if you're
able to create something that pleases
somebody's eye don't you want to get
paid for your work I tell people all the
time I don't want to be a beta boy
because we're not getting paid you
understand and and the fact that they're
saying we will pay you for the work that
you do to keep our game relevant and in
traction could you imagine you become a
millionaire by doing this and I know
you're going to say how right you making
a lot of money doing this stuff right
but you start a tutorial on showing
people how to do it on your Channel
streaming your stuff on how you're
building a new world and I think that's
incredible I think giving the tools to
the masses and see what
happens it's no longer video games is a
fad it's a dead end thing literally the
game that you get can be your ticket out
so I I don't I don't think it's a bad
thing somebody said they're offering
money for you to play a game you like
right so that pay him pay him I don't
yes please I'm always about I I can see
if they said whatever you submit you
ain't get nothing and anything that we
get we gonna take that off the top you
ain't getting that now that's the
problem but you know it's give them give
the people the money yeah long as long
as they get their fair share and I'm
always about the the creators getting a
bag and you've talked about that you
know my thing is look I am all about
Starfield I think that game is perfect
for this I cannot wait to see what
people come up with and yes I be there
cars I want cars on planets whips on
planets they there's so many options
they they could go into this so yeah
good questioners oh man it' be lit it'
be lit so that's all we got from that
dip down I know you got one we're going
to use that your uh what you call it cuz
it's relevant to the game awards part so
I want to save it CU he has a good one
we save it for the game awards so you
going to do your thing well let me
finish these extra super chats that came
in after that too okay cool all right
then we got David hotti $20 Super Chat
agree with the previous chat salute
shout out to y'all's David is uh
agreeing with sage on what king said
then we got everborn Saga once again
Super Chat remember Sonic dream team is
also played on the Apple TV with an Xbox
controller don't sleep this game might
be better than Sonic Frontier
we won't know because it's not no police
house um don't do them like that yo we
got 1,200 people how come I only got 500
and something of likes maybe we got to
start saving rare animals again what we
saving K here we go we we going to save
the
PlayStation we going to we get lik
listen listen listen from the Xbox
Frontline Army We're Gonna Save the real
the the the rare alaban
Kong now now they're going to dislike it
thank you ke
I
cannot all right uh so anything else
that comes yeah killer killer oh killer
I get it if you want I I got it killer
e305 $5 Super Chat it's going to be a
good Christmas King out here with the
Santa beard leave the Jim Ryan salt
cookies out for him with the zero award
milk good e zero award milk wow salt
cookies no this man said was having a
good time with with the with the gym
cookies they said we want nothing y'all
here the gy cookies everybody
hey not the gym R oh we gonna sell him
that DLC that we made for free ah just
give it to him yeah I but I'm with
everborn man if they'll if they'll pay
for it charge them charge him more oh
man all right last week's po was end the
people are spoken with rumors of Xbox
having a p Presence at the game awards
which of these would have had the
biggest impact on the show show the
winner of the fourway IP 4 at 37% of the
vote is sega's super game project people
wanted it wow that's crazy coming in the
second um was 28% of the vote Persona 6
group third place uh 25% was a a new
Virtual Fighter Group wow and in last
place at only 8% of the vote was I don't
care big Sonic movie is
out shout out to all the Lords s the
people felt the biggest impact would be
super
game so did they confirm that this is
super game or they officially confirmed
it I think Super game is still some sort
of whatever online thing with with their
properties or whatever the case might be
but they have it announced that delivery
model of what this is going to be what
this is going to be right I I think they
because they put it in a montage people
think that it's all together kind of
like on one disc or whatever but I do
think they're separate projects um what
if it's on Apple yeah I'll be soad then
then everborn gonna be popping
B that's crazy we got to stop them
guys that that that will lend into the
stupidity of Sega because I don't know
why y'all threw Sonic over there y'all
y'all keep doing dumb stuff got to get
that money every demic but why they got
to keep putting Sega out there like that
D but they got to B put yeah they put
them out there to stre to the streets I
mean that's what to be fair Sonic kept
them Sonic persona persona and and lock
Yakuza Yak kept them aat kept them alive
fact alive really so yeah you got to put
them everywhere it's like yo they going
they have so many IP that they all and
all of these IP want house no this is
the thing though right so many of them
come from a simpler time in gaming so
their Core Concepts can all be
transplanted to Modern games you can
make modern games with them all you got
to do like even core story lines like
story stuff you have to expand upon it
right because you know but like a modern
shoba game a modern all of this stuff
can be modernized in ways that people
will find appealing not just the fans so
yeah they did it yeah they did it they
did it we going get to it thank you s we
going to get to it so first topic is up
unless we got we got that yes we we got
things to do yeah we got yeah I got to
pay these first bills and then we'll pay
the second bills so do not turn off your
mics congregation cuz I will be
referring to you guys
momentarily all right that's what's up
Santa Baby the season for fresh cut is
finally here here with the sponsors of
today's show mancate the leaders and
below the waist grooming have just
launched their fifth generation lawn
mower to help you avoid another silent
night in the bedroom this year take care
of your special snowflake with manscaped
and watch watch your South Pole shine
like never before at the best stocking
stuffer of all by going to manscape.com
and using Code iron Lords for 20% off
plus free shipping Mrs Claus will thank
you so let me defer to my panel here in
this season of giving gentlemen is there
anyone that you want to gift with the
the the the the beauty of a shiny
yo come on
yo let me go to you got to go to me I
can't even play the music I got to go to
Cognito first look man you know it's the
seasons you got season giving season
givings and you got to make sure the
tree is tripped right the tree you gotta
you know you gotta you got to make sure
everything's right you know what I'm
saying so I get my manscaped on and you
there's a lot of people out there again
a lot of Master swords that ain't right
out here and if you want your partner to
be happy during the holiday season make
sure you get your poll your situation
corrected that's all I got moving on I
had to go to go first because he sounded
so disgusting so disgusting with this
man I was like how you GNA do me like
that Lord King about you sir anybody
anybody is going to be uh find a
beautiful gift from manscaped under the
tree although for whoever maybe you
don't celebrate right season of giving
season I don't celebrate it but um I do
give out gifts for solsis so so so this
is during that same period of time I was
just talking about this the other day oh
right all right because wifey was like
um do you have any more of that manscape
stuff from my brother there we go and I
was like why is he
unapt and then the second question
listen listen and then the second
question was how you know this like so
now definitely I was like um I got some
stuff and I'm going to definitely order
some stuff for him I said the underwears
dope oh bro oh Addy got a story Addy
could contribute for that
one Addy got a real good story on
manscape for that one yeah so that stuff
is super dope so I'm sending him a
little package of manscape and I know
he's going to enjoy it because I enjoy
it yes every week I enjoy it facts Lord
addict the underwear story this sh so
when me and my girl talking about like
Christmas stuff uh you know she I ended
up getting her like an Apple Watch and
she was like well what do you want and I
was like I just want some manscape
Hunter yo I a go for that the manscape
boxes is official bro silk she she she
ended up uh getting me like eight or
nine
something so I was like yeah just like
look man like she like how to package
not even not not even just keeping you
know the the master sword uh you know
upkept man if you want to use the master
sword you might want to upcut and also
how you present your M Master Sword to
your loved one right you got the
manscape under after you handled your
business that's what's up man I I
respect if you two want to get nine
pairs of manscape underwear just use
code iron Lord that that discap
facts their stuff is is is extremely
good but I'm gonna be real with you guys
that that underwear man always like like
I've always sweated everywhere it don't
matter where it is but that that that is
like the best underwear I've ever had on
that just felt comfortable no matter
what
it's moisture all right so what could be
better than giving the gift of good
hygiene in a few Labs starting with the
lawnmower 5.0 Ultra this is the Crown
Jewel of the holidays and dare I say the
best ball trimmer of all time the
electric Razor's Advanced Skin safe
technology is a lifesaver and known for
reducing Nicks and cuts on his Santa
sack but the fun doesn't stop there
anybody in the family have too much
scruff look no further than manscapes
beard hedger Pro kit and handyman
electric face shaver for all of the
facial needs does Dad have nasty nose
hairs saved a day with the weed whacker
2.0 those are M nose and ear hair
trimmer yes as we get older hair just
grows out of places that you didn't know
you had man and the the weed whacker
2.to nose and ear hair trimmer gets the
job done now also is there boxer game
week take care of the chestnuts with
manscapes two boxers 2.0 featuring their
signature Jewel pouch to keep you calm
cool and collective's been very calm
lately yeah I'm telling you guys man you
guys ever wonder how I've calmed down
I'm not as aggressive as I used to be
not as aggressive for for for for every
Angry man there is man you know there
there's H for every actually would be
for every non angry man man there's a
there's a pair of manscape underwear to
calm that that oh I almost Cal your sack
down Cal your
downal aggressive
sack why his sack is bad aggressive it
need to be C got a wild sack he got a
wild and now this is new to the family
have their nails seen better days
landscaped has you covered with their
new shears 3.0 nail grooming kit oh we
got the they got they got they got
everything got I
need head to toe they have you covered
so right now get 20% off and free
shipping with the code iron Lords at
manscape.com that's Lords with s right s
yes with an S with an S that's 20% off
with free shipping at manscape.com and
use code iron Lords say ho ho ho to a
well-groomed missl toe with
manscaped salute salute I have to get up
on there we got to get up on that right
there what what the you know what man
you you know it they would be more
effective if we had women a lot of women
that watch our show because it' be a
good gift man you can get your girl you
y you can get your girl your stuff for
for for her Christmas present they don't
they don't be caring about that they
they don't care about that they don't
everything's unisex to them they don't
yeah that's a fact I found out the
harder I prefer to she going to like
that you B you that stuff
present yourself salute no doubt we all
set yeah we're all set we can move along
now we want to do the other thing we got
two other giveaways we we spread those
out how y want to do that let me know
how y'all want to do that yeah might as
well do one of them now yeah let's do
one which one you want to do we got some
nice giveaways what you want to do I do
I'll do the NZXT one if you guys want
all right we want to back to back it on
that yeah and then we do the zip Davis
right after yeah oh we going okay all
three okay yeah let's do it all right
cool what we got
yeah okay so um you you do you uh do the
zip one something's going on in here all
right cool something's going on in here
damn it got crazy excited about
manscaped underwear that's what they are
they take care of the zip joint if you
don't mind okay okay I have to go to my
it's in the chat yeah it's in the chat
we got we put it right in the chat you
know what I'm saying give me give me a
moment professional said I know this
females watching hook your man up I'm
done but see there's a lot of women out
there buying that landcape cuz they know
that their Tremor is real mhm oh hold on
we got some really powerful super chats
too wow in there too okay so question
are we reading my brother we played the
other day are we reading the whole thing
from zip or just uh um use your
discretion however you want to handle it
yeah you know what I'm G to read it
because it's a very nice message um this
was uh directed at Cog hey C sorry to
bother you I wanted to donate a code for
you to give away on the show tomorrow
I'm hoping it could make someone's
holiday I don't want anything in return
just tell everyone the code is from the
zippiest with the drippiest aka the one
who taught Spider-Man how to web zip AKA
little little beef little beef
beef aka the ooh we kid yes and it is a
code for the Starfield Deluxe Edition on
Xbox all year
so how am I going to do this am I just
going to copy paste it am I going to
well let me read the end of it thank you
and thank you all on ILP also Maddie for
defining Duke for all you do and I wish
you and your families a happy and
relaxing holiday zip DAV Starfield
definitive let's go Starfield deluxe
edition for Xbox what should I do with
this should I do it the king way and put
we going to draw this out or no no no no
no just get it let's let's just give it
to them because we're not going to put
it in the chat and they can snatch it
we're going to say it I'm going to I'm
going to read it it out loud the person
who gets it correctly okay you you know
what you do what put s never mind that
would be too Beast I was going to say
don't say it in the in the right order
oh that's crazy that's crazy individual
the individual Parts like the five
letters a different part that's too
crazy we got to switch it around so get
get get your get your keyboards ready
yeah we got
v9 hold on let repeat it let it repeat
cuz people list B9 V
W7
kvt x
h p m k r
h t
g92
p
TZ Z as in zebra all right you you heard
it here first go get that do what y'all
do you got to say it you got got to say
it like how the military says it like
you see say d you say Delta
Alpha drive people crazy no doubt no
doubt all right so if you got if you're
the one who wins this please put it in
the chat and thank zip Davis but let us
know that you got the code ZIP thank you
no doubt and now ad you want you co to
do the
giveaway yeah so we'll do the giveaway
real quick all right so look we we we
guys we we got you a nice little
giveaway man so consider it our
Christmas gift from us to you yes uh you
know I hope you guys uh enjoy this so
what we have done is uh We've uh you
know uh parked it up within zxt and
we're giving away a player two
PC it's got that what's that player to
about it's it's it's got a AMD ryzen 5
5600x CPU in it and it's got a Nidia
GeForce RTX 470 GPU we 470 out here yes
with that PC you don't need your
PlayStation cuz you got a hot PC
relax GLE uh you know there there's
different variety things you can do to
you know enter multiple times uh but you
know shout out to NZXT great giveaway uh
you know they we will be deciding the
the giveaway uh in in 7 days and then we
will uh make sure that gets shipped out
to you so I hope you you know I hope a
content creator wins it because this GNA
upgrade whatever nonsense you got
now yeah into that now adct put it in
the chat I'm also going to put it in the
chat and also pin that yeah you going to
get yourself a nice play that is a
beautiful thing NX bro you can win that
is a beautiful thing right there with
NZXT let me just go pin that you're
getting a 2,000 or some
change that's crazy crazy crazy yeah go
hit that okay get your chance to win
oh man oh man crazy very nice holiday
gift here man there as you can see the
realm look at that uh on the on the
overlay you can see we're powered by
NZXT you too can be powered by NZXT and
get your uh PC on see if you get enter
in there get yourself a nice little
stocking stuffer right there yeah and
really play Starfield yeah play that
play oh yeah yeah yeah really play
Starfield Starfield take it to take it
with Todd said it was it was the way to
go yeah yeah that's what he said
you know the other thing they said too
um when you get those PlayStation ports
that's over on the PC they run
dope turtle look ill he's out of pocket
get your chance you know what else looks
ill Ratchet and Clank they said that we
couldn't do without the fast you are out
of pocket shout out to our good friends
at NZXT we're not mentioning other not
talk about them we that segment is
already yeah oh it's over now okay okay
back to our regular schedule
program some heavy editing having to go
on here yeah edit that part out yeah
edit KS Bess this please get get
yourself a shot to win a PC content
creator is really really important if
you want to take your content to the
next level I know a lot of you working
off little laptops whatever you do it
get yourself a real rig it's trust me I
was that guy too and it'll step your
game up you know what I'm saying trust
me when we took IOP to the the desktop
it's different y s I was telling [__]
the other day I said my PC I put my PC
on I thought my PC was high powerered
and xxt is he's high power he does what
he does whatever I put
on yo I put it in it was like we don't
run that like like what are you doing
over here like list every PC has his day
right and I looked at my PC when I got
the one that I got for Doom three and
half lifee 2 I was like this is the
Beast it's a beast yeah kid you know nah
yeah n it is what it is no
doubt and then the topic Yeah couple
super chats hold on let me bro this
back okay
so we got
killer okay I got that Sinister X2 shout
to shout to sin $10 Super Chat I'm
living proof that this team always got
your back when I lost my grandma my
father and then my mom within 3 months
they were here for me King you did the
right thing F Twitter Warriors yes yes
thank you brother I love you always love
brother we got Mike
L5 $5 Super Chat it's amazing to finally
see licensed IPS on Xbox now first Indie
then blade and now let's see them take
on spawn John Wick TMNT and Punisher
next salute what's up why can't we just
get you open the flood like they open
they so when they got Spider-Man ain't
nobody yell out yo what we need next
right you know what we need we need a
wolverine no that came after Spider-Man
was successful let blade land first yeah
that is true the last vampire game
didn't work out so and these are the
same guys no it's not the same guys but
no no I'm just saying not the same guys
minute I thought they were adding they
were adding blade to Red fo no who whoa
whoa we're not doing that we're not
doing that this is Leo
Le okay but what if Leon they do blade
right and
then if blade is successful this is how
they fix redf and make it a shared
Universe how we fix it is we finish with
it and we have Harvey do something
else is that's how we fix it let's move
on you gave us 60 thank you for your
support thank
you then we have Karma God 91 $5 Super
Chat King you made my day Friday it was
was an honor to call calling in as
nervous as I was salute to the realm God
has blessed all of you peace and love
brother bless he called de to the show
yes yo and what is so dope is after the
initial uh nerves is
gone that's when it kicks in that's the
flow that's what the fun like yo yeah we
family baby you call in we family man
let's have fun that's what's up that's a
beautiful thing then we have
p1553 d uh $2 Super Chat next giveaway m
now you have my attention you see it's
like give away PCS people perk up like
oh hold
up there we got Joe refco AKA flame $5
Super Chat well Cog on the same week
more nasty dirt arm Bungie was found
Warframe was up on stage at the Game of
Wars loud and proud you're not saving
con wait hold on I got to C for my man
first of all how would you know he was
on stage if you didn't watch that's one
two um let's check the most played EXP
box H Destiny 11 with all the
controversy and people where is Warframe
H
20 number 38 on the most gting play
thank you for your service you go hard
you need to get your community go
hard I love you FL love you don't come
for me unless I S for
you continue I think we're caught up all
right let's get to finally chees all
right so game awards time y'all game
awards time lot to talk about I'm just
going to kind of power through yes I was
looking the whole time I was waiting for
you f I knew you was going to say
something slay anyway oh moving
on oh yeah we got a lot to talk about
man Big Show a lot of announcements the
whole bit so really quickly I'm going to
do uh kind of like a shotgun blast uh
metaphor fantasio came coming out for
2024 that's the uh Persona kind of I
mean Atlas coming out with their own you
know new RPG Exodus was on stage
remember from archetype those guys
original Mass Effect crew some of those
guys making a game God of War Ragnarok
Valhalla the DLC free look like a Rog
Light DLC coming out on December 12th
hellblade 2 Gameplay was shown in the
trailer CA outside finally some combat
that was good no rest for the W Wicket I
don't know if you guys saw that Moon
Studios jump off those are the a Rec
creators look absolutely nuts Sega was
in the building s announced five live
remakes jet said radio crazy T if they
don't have Offspring and czy I need
the I I need that Golden Axe what it was
funny when I was watching the stream
because I was driving to watching M I
was like how Cog didn't know that that
was golden
ax I was so enamored cuz like the minute
they showed the trailer with the two
people the brother and home girl that
was in there I wasn't even looking at
them them I yelled out yo it's shobi
they had the arcade joint my arcade that
y we all took pictures with in the back
I saw the mar they had the full arcade
board just like my I said yo this is
Sega this is Shinobi so I was already in
my shinomi bag and I wasn't even really
paying attention at first I had to
rewatch it but then when I saw oh go to
that I didn't even realize um what you
call it was shown um not the the street
of Rage I didn't even realize Street
rage now when I saw them they fighting I
was like oh snap stre rage but and that
that was C
because they just I guess this is their
official um my question to you was um do
you think they do Shinobi or Shadow
Dancer that's a good question I it
looked like Shadow Dancer it looked like
bace in the classic revenge of shobi
gear with with the gray suit you know
ninja suit so not going arcade style
without I would him with the face out
but I got the what is it almost like a I
don't say cell shaded but very stylized
art style reminded me of Mark of the
Ninja K hav haven't played haven't
played sure know's funny it's literally
on my steam deck all right I got to get
that on the Rong and move that on I
forgot yes yes I need to play that I
completely forgot it will actually doing
it today so we got that and then um
Crazy Taxi looked in Wild I don't know
Crazy Taxi looked in Wild so yeah Gro
man is absolutely nuts for me um DBZ uh
this is for adct I was in clown in they
was making fun of me I didn't know the
correct names of the heroes sparkling
zero Gameplay trailer and um and we had
casting of the Frank Stone as a
cinematic horror experience by De from
daylight massive look kind of had me
almost pee on myself why is he going in
this still yeah yeah yeah what's he
doing yeah then uh visions of Mana
Square Enix coming out the spiritual
success King secret of M and the Super
Nintendo you know what I'm saying I I
think I was
probably the loudest in my house cuz I
had just gotten the house at that time
cuz people was like your king is in the
chat why you Ain here cuz I was just
getting home and going to we just making
fun but it but um I waited for a minute
for a true you know sequel to it I mean
you know tears am M was but I think this
is the true Sequel and the fact that uh
notice new IP from the square Xbox was
present now I saw when Sony dud was like
yeah yeah and inste Xbox at the end it
was
like ridiculous he said said what you
talking about Willis speaking of Sony
they had the exclusive rise of the
Rolling S how long is the exclusive you
know they don't got money for a long
time I mean but it look like it's funded
and done by them kind of deal six months
yeah well you know so is MLB the Show
so you know how we do with that all
right they they don't have a choice in
that one they might not have a choice in
this one cash looking low baby and you
know we got that bread and uh kajima had
his moment y'all yeah he had more than a
few moments D overdose let's announce
big surprise though I guess we we were
probably thinking I think me and adct
were probably thinking maybe uh what you
call it um death strandon too but no
overdose weird kind of speaking thing in
the beginning Xbox Cloud Tech it's a
horror game he came out the door people
told me he came out the door that was
the same from PT so the thought process
is that PT is coming back in some form
with this game and then um Jordan Peele
and then he also said that they're going
to have an Avengers level of directors
that Jordan pill is just the first of
many involve with the project so shout
out to um kajim shout out to key was
very excited you got that uh Jurassic
Park survival I don't know if anyone
caught that um first person action
adventure black myth woong y'all oh
another trailer another beautiful
looking game we got a release date how
come people don't say that with this
what you mean oh this is like the 20th
trailer that we've seen from this game
Xbox shows three trailers of a game oh
that's enough already true true you're
right you're right right but but in in
defense of Wukong they showed the combat
with someone who three times finally
show they com no but but I understand
that part right but what I'm saying is
the only reason why they keep wanting to
see uh that game is because they want to
know who's it announced for and the fact
that they keep dangling the fruit out
there I think they in a been in war for
that game kind of feels like it right
like there's no
platforms yeah game size Phil no now
with Sarah B Queen
please let that game get out of your
hands I mean it may be I but they know
they know that Wukong is one of the most
anticip like they know they value right
so maybe the bag price is just wild
crazy maybe well just get the marketing
yeah that's true that's true let's TR
see who gets the walking that's going be
interesting SE Squad side Squad trailer
was show know if you got King is feeling
that all right King was about that one
all right he was about you you with it
that game is dope I heard all those
people saying and yo shout out to f I
love you to death F I played the game I
wish and I could talk about it this week
said I we we we clear are we this easy
Breaking anything was Suicide Squad yeah
was C I don't think you can talk L was
like yeah I know think there's an n on
that to retract we need to retract the
statement ker just having fun playing
games this week that's
all he talking muted on
purpose but uh yeah I watch the trailer
I watched the trailer K was EXC excited
about the trailer y'all the trailer was
dope I think the game is going to be
super hot he was so hyped about that
trailer he watched butail trailer yes so
um oh for me Tales of canera of z i play
Z come the African warrior Shaman the
brother came out there of siwa that was
that was you know that was see that's
what I want to see a guy he's a voice
actor SL you know regular
turned to a dev has a game commemorating
his dad and the whole game is about kind
of like kind of like call it when we
think about um never yield right think
about never y has a theme that has a
central theme that really it that was
heartwarming I really like bro I really
love and then I like let's be real a lot
of times s we see these games and it's
for the culture and it's made by the
right people but sometimes the
production you be like damn I just wish
the production
I was like brother I'm pulling for you
like I shouted him out on Twitter look
phenomenal and then my thing for King is
for us right like you know what I'm
saying like African culture Black
Culture kind of separate you know really
represented the I got black panther
vibes from it I got a lot of ay VI I got
a lot of Vibes for me it looked really
good I'm glad the game is coming out
because it seemed like ever since black
panther came and went that that pride
thing that's the pride is back that the
co to make games about the coach was
really good the EA I think EA is hopping
them out on that one I think it's the EA
original I believe I believe so salute
to them yeah that that looked good that
bag is crazy that bag is crazy so they
had to be impressed for what they see
you know no doubt um lost records um
Bloom and rage is from the life ex
strange team I don't know if anyone
caught
that okay um no no it look like okay
first Berserker in engine trailer
everybody had any feel about that one
that was shown it look good all right
then we we had an apex Legend Final
Fantasy 7 crossover event me and ad was
was bugging out on that one salute they
had to do something shout out to them
saying fortnite getting everybody and
they went and got somebody it's like we
need to be in the conversation with all
this crossover and this was a big one y
I saved the the commentary but we got to
at least mention it was shown
blade now in development arcan Leon
third third person the man came out and
said third third person action adventure
single player game set in Paris and uh
yeah like we we'll talk about the talk
of exclusivity but as far as the game
itself I think someone in the Super Chat
said it earlier I love the music I love
your man who's giving him you know a
shape of a fade he had a little Blood on
the head he's a little a little shook in
the situation cuz you know who he
dealing with you know I I just thought
that was now to be honest you know for
me I'm thinking this is arcane
we just have to accept it's first person
like and I'm I was willing to rock I'm
willing to rock cuz I'm like this is
Arcane when ding came out there was like
third person he was dressed for it too
and he had to bro he had to Tren he was
dressed for it too and then to see
Marvel the rep was like we love
everything Arcane does we love this HED
we love death Loop what was Y what was y
feel why did he say red
fo that's Arcanos we we love everything
arcade does except that game Leon
talking Leon but uh yeah then and then I
don't know if yall caught with Dinger he
said um it meant a lot to him because
obviously he is of mixed background and
that Blaze story is obviously half
vampire half you where he from from from
Paris he doing it for the culture for
the city what was y'all thinking of the
blade joint
man well
brev that's not Paris let you
know listen Hey listen I'm uncultured
anyway now I thought well what what I
don't like about my DMs is it was
spoiled already for me yeah streets
going to it now it's about what is it
going to be there right now it's just
confirmation then when I saw it I saw
the confirmation to it and I was just
like this is it y'all y'all scream y
kicked y begged y cried y needed a
superhero game when the King was saying
y'all didn't need one I don't know why
you're doing this and to see the
reception of it for that's what I said
that's big for you that's big cuz I know
you you've been yeah no I got I got to
respect that I respect that from you
that's big from you cuz I know we've had
this debate yeah because I was I was on
other fence that we don't need it n but
um obviously it's necessary and it's
needed but what's even crazier it is so
needed that the
opposition is in denial so you got to
know the property must must have hit
right and it must have been a great time
to drop that trailer at that moment that
they did because the opposition is Port
begging for it right now Port begging y
you know why you know why I'm I'mma find
exactly what port begging is and shout
out to my man Christopher har oh you GNA
put myed on fresh
stre where this is you putting this up
Port begging and I'm like come on and it
said new profile pick he changed his
profile pick to portb oh man and then
one dude put to Phil Phil put something
he was on vacation and it was like the
first signs of snow and the dude put
please let's get blade for PlayStation 5
oh well since we talking about it now
that King already opened the subject up
um did y'all see greedy's tweet of um it
was this it was yeah it was that the
Xbox let me see you got that hold on
hold on let me let me this is this is
Christopher har right now go to go to g
go to go to my timeline go to you follow
Dinger and Dinger retweeted what greeny
said and greeny had a very when Chris
har got that picture from what he
altered is originally something that
greedy put up so he was F gazy with his
yeah basically he he edited what greedy
put up cuz greedy put up play Xbox yeah
joy and dingo retweeted it it's kind of
interesting how quick greeny removed
profile picture it's like someone PR
message him like what are you doing we
ain't supposed the do that yet so let's
talk about the controversy adct in the
sense that you know obviously the talk
about it people were excited but what
platform is it why hasn't Xbox
explicitly said this is um you know an
exclusive we noticed the Xbox account
didn't tweet it was the Bethesda account
that tweeted it was coming out you know
um there was one article shout out the
window Central but then they did kind
that said it was exclusive talk about
this one right here right yeah there Go
the real one right yeah yeah
there you go there you go we got it in
4k you know what I'm saying so um yeah
so what what do you guys think about
that whole situation and so I don't know
if I got a chance to hit your thought
about the game also include everything
in that because I was curious to see
where you were at an addict I
think I think this is all Microsoft's
fault it's just
like there's but there's too much
inconsistency with their messaging it's
like you
know if I remember correctly and maybe
you guys can vouch or not after the
Bethesda thing was done you know and he
came out cuz hellblade was supposed to
be a multiplat AOW was supposed to be a
multiplat Elder Scrolls was supposed to
be a multiplat when they did that
Trinity thing when they did that that
couch thing with the Bethesda oh right
right right and Phil just came out
openly said look we bought this to value
our consoles at the end of the day it's
going to be a case by case on what goes
uh I do feel like I remember seeing
people when the ABK deal was first
announced where it was like people
automatically assumed it was exclusive
like I remember no that's a fact people
saying that's a fact that was a fact
it's going to go just like Bethesda
these games going to be exclusive but
but the thing is is when you
consistently change up the messaging you
have where this game's an exclusive this
game's not an exclusive and then you
have the the CFO a couple week ago
they're talking about multiplat this
multi PL that stew comments good point I
don't blame people for for being
skeptical if the game's exclusive or not
exclusive now I think if you're actually
paying attention in the industry you
should know if it's an exclusive or not
let's go off of what Microsoft's
actually doing right Microsoft has not
formally announced that Indiana Jones is
an exclusive but guess what we know that
because of the FTC well let me ask you
this I mean cuz you you you on some fine
with some stuff um do you think cuz this
is another trail of thought right now
now I don't know if y'all know the FTC
that's what I was going to say okay they
are still battling Microsoft right now
I'm not on your joint but I'm in
agreement that was
funny yeah that was crazy cuz you always
catch me when I'm out of pocket to catch
you cuz you set me up last week it was
good it was good you funny that was
funny it was funny so yeah they still
fighting the FTC over the activist
blizzard deal shout to Tom fighting and
FTC is appealing The District Court's
decision not to block ABK you know the
whole bit and that um they saying in the
appeal Microsoft is threatening the
cycle FTC claims that they're
threatening the cycle of investment and
Entrepreneurship that drives America's
Innovation economy and they continue to
go through the administrative process so
their whole mindset is that you know
they take games and make it exclusive go
against the spirit that's a valid thing
do we think think that this is part of
the reasoning why hey let's not reveal
it now with a logo let things play out
because the gab ain't gonna come out too
long anyway they gonna know later any I
think Microsoft is waiting for the
appeal process to end where there's
nothing they could do I think they're uh
you know put the boat on in your neck I
think they have I've been told that they
have been having you know uh meetings
and stuff with the FTC but in that case
why announce it cuz cuz now the online
conversation is whether or not exclusive
no one even is really talking about
where storyline they can go into what
type of gameplay they can happen
everyone's talking about whether or not
it's an exclusive if it's a matter of
six months to a year when this game's
five years uh in the making you should
have just waited till you can put your
brand right up on that stage next
scenario I want to tell you cuz I hear
where you cooking I hear where you going
um again shout out to Jess Cordon
Windows Central shout out to Xbox 2
je made some interesting comments as
well now what do you think about this
Attic in reference
to part of the we know for a fact CU we
we we're involved in a way that
Bethesda still operates independently
like for example they their PR and the
way they do things right if you go to
Microsoft and you try to say hey I want
to deal with but there the though they
send you there that that's where so so
so the mindset is and again shout out to
jez he he brought this up that part of
acquiring these Publishers right is that
they're still subsidiaries they still
have to operate independently and we do
know right but desda does move to the
beat of Their Own Drum and we do know
that even in the what is it the old
documents remember when they had to be
like yo Starfield Microsoft was like you
know put a to use a king reference
delete that uh Starfield PlayStation
joint delete the red for joint right
they told um but that's the this and but
that's just culture instinctually is
really not that and maybe like they
they're so used to not having to do that
type of stuff so do do you think go
there's been talk about that that maybe
that you know his um he was very
outspoken with certain things and hey
the way we do things versus the way
y'all do things and maybe part of now do
things over here relax yourself the
heart of acquiring a publisher is to
allow them to say it whenever they're
ready and Microsoft says okay you know
what we know it's exclusive but you you
you get to announce it in due time when
the way you want to do do you subscribe
to that thought process I feel them on
that but there are some things that if
it's going to involve your decisions
making us have bad PR then we are
overseeing your decisions on certain
things we've seen them do it in the past
I know for a fact that they've had
differences on how to present stuff at
E3 and we clearly see who pulled the
rank card in that scenario so it's just
like look like that this this blade
thing is I just I find it very
frustrating Cobo put it on Twitter he's
like yeah let me read it let me read it
big yeah okay yeah you cooking you
cooking Cobo said exactly what ad's
talking about we could be talking about
how amazing it is that arcade Studios
Leon develops a mature singleplayer
third person Blade game instead platform
talk dominates social media and the only
one I have to blame for this is X Box
I'm so so tired of this so people were
saying I got you K I'm going to let you
cook I know I'm just laughing all right
yeah he said so somebody said hey man
you know what about you know hey you
know uh that it's early you know and
showing it and then CL bro responded
he's like look I'm not the industry he
said I'm an Xbox fan first and last and
I don't understand why every small bit
of criticism about what he's saying
always gets downplayed he said no one is
saying this needs to matter you that's
fine it clearly matters to a lot of fans
and many simply want Xbox to do better
so a lot of people want Xbox in your
words King to put the foot on the neck
and say definitively that it is Theirs
to other bases let's just say that is it
my time no let let adct
finish here's my thing it's just like
look at the end of the day the person
who told me the game existed also said
it was exclusive so I'm pretty confident
it's exclusive but it's just like I hate
to see such a huge announcement wouldn't
necessarily call bad PR just not good PR
either it's like a lot of neutral PR
where people are discussing ital and I'm
not the I'm not the type of person that
I don't believe all publicity is good
publicity um you know I I do think there
are some publicity that's taking away
from the core of the core of the
conversation and this isn't the core of
the conversation the core of the
conversation is Xbox has an exclusive
game but all that has been drowned out
by is it exclusive or not and to me it's
just like you take one step forward and
two steps back CU it's like now instead
of celebrating that Microsoft finally
has a superhero game uh in competition
to stuff like Spider-Man Wolverine now
that's not the conversation the
conversation is is this game going to be
exclusive is that going to and and not
to mention it puts more energy behind
what's going on in in general with third
party stuff because this is Bethesda
this is not Activision this is Bethesda
they bought Bethesda before the ABK deal
and I understand the FTC thing and that
that that's perfectly fine cuz you know
why come out there with an announcement
that could potentially cost you more
millions of dollars arguing with the FTC
for years that's perfectly valid wait
for the uh for the for for the approval
thing to go over wait for all that to go
over then announce the stuff oh so you
don't even want it there because it's
like why why come out there show all
your bars and say it's not my balls
though that just makes no sense to me
it's like why come out there and say I'm
putting my style on this okay that's on
you I don't know what's on I don't know
like so what about what about greedy
with the subliminal bosss what about
greed he's doing that for us okay okay
okay so it's not real Jesus Christ I'm
just asking he asking y y how is me
saying us not real explain that no I'm
saying you said he's doing that for us
he's doing that for the people that's on
Twitter I was thinking it was just for
show okay he no he's doing that for the
people on Twitter that's asking the
people that that monitor him now we know
for a fact which I knew okay there's no
reason twe Aaron be changing these if
this wasn't some kind of fruit to this
stuff so it's definitely he's doing it
for us so what if he changed it because
was going to play station he they filed
out then at that point Aaron come on man
like at the end I just all these years
all these Xbox people been coming at me
they don't need no no comic
talk to talk to him but guess what
Bethesda and Xbox disagreed with you
read
your speak your
truth because if
they truly did not need it they wouldn't
have if they truly did not feel like
they they needed this in their stable
they would have armed for this fight we
got you would have heard me give you
your flowers if you was here when I gave
you it's just at the end of the day it's
just frustrating that a don't get this
is still a w massive W massive but it
sus you make it sound like it's not well
I can still criticize and still give
them props I do it all the time this is
true true I would say they took a
massive W like a capital W to
a cuz now it's like we know what's
happening but it's just like I want Xbox
be like we got blade like PlayStation
does with Spider-Man Wolverine we got
blade this is awesome feel it make thr
console in garbage make them SP I don't
even I don't even mind them showing
games this early I just I want afraid I
don't like them doing stuff when they
have their hands to hide behind their
back it's like if you're going to come
out there and formally announce stuff
announce it put your brand on this is
our it's not their like that that that's
what I want because it's like because it
gives you the illusion okay BL if blade
isn't going then what else isn't going
that stuff going over there because it's
just like Indiana
Jones if that game was multiplay I would
give some conversation to exclusive talk
but it's not it's it's only on Xbox so
it's like now Indiana Jones and blade is
being developed only on
Xbox I'm just going to get you going but
I have to read sarcastic towards adct
Xbox need a superhero game also adct why
even announce it no it's it's it's not
about announcing it or not announcing it
it's what's the point in having a super
Hero game if you can't put your logo on
the box what's the point of spinning
$6.7 billion and you can't have Xbox on
the logo okay fair enough all right we
going to keep it cooking I just want to
give you your props though for one tweet
that made me laugh he said everyone that
has attacked me the Xbox don't need
their superhero game for the past years
don't let me catch you outside playing
blade when it comes that was hilarious
he's like y better play those I want to
see you play that that those are Cog
balls those are Cog I felt I felt I
inspired
that anyway Sol You' been patient I know
you've been patient problem we haven't
he wasn't part I haven't talked to him I
don't know what's going on yeah you
clean up you knock it out the park
everybody's getting on base right now
you you come through all right so so
still yeah he so real quick I do want to
add one caviar to the conversation going
forward yes people say doesn't matter if
it's exclusive it's in Game Pass I want
to add that to is that right doesn't
matter if it's exclusive to the Xbox
platform if it's in Game Pass day and
day so interesting all right we'll see
we'll see what happens but uh s thoughts
on blade this game your feeling and and
the
controversy uh so first just seeing it
when I saw it after taking in the fact
that it was a blade game and it was
being made by Arcane Leon you know
what's funny sa was the only person in
this podcast that didn't know before it
happened yeah I didn't know yeah we
didn't talk to him yeah he was on
anniversary mode I told you guys a
million times don't tell me I know
people tell y'all things in the DM do
not tell me so what was your being
surprised when you see this so I was
like I was super excited right um but
then I had to go back and rewatch The
Trailer quickly cuz I'm like I'm super
excited um at that point he he Dinka
hadn't spoken yet right so I wasn't sure
about the third person yet and the first
thing I put in our chat was like hope
it's third person I saw that I saw that
um and then when just let you finish it
yeah when he confirmed that IPS is H you
get mad when we do that I'm just saying
I'm just saying I love you though you
sound like Nori so much yeah I love
continue he he confirmed it and that
made me so happy so my thing is this I I
love Arcane period this is red fall is M
misstep let's be clear about that talk
about that talk about that but
arcanes the way they design games the
way they think about design the way they
think about combat is very special
because they've taken the tenants of the
immersive Sim and added uh and added
visceral combat to it right so you add
that to a character like
blade um and then you decide to take it
third person boy that is something that
really it's I mean again I can't I can't
really even picture what they would do
with it all I know is that I have the
utmost confidence in the the only thing
that would that worried me a little bit
is that wor the art style if the art
style of the trailer oh is indicative of
the art style of the game with that
disqualified has gu what because seems
very stylish very high five rushy no not
not to me it wouldn't but I when you
when I think about how people would talk
about this game in the general gaming
Spectrum somebody's G to look at it
right because you know it's GNA happen
somebody's gonna look at be like oh it's
not of the quality of a Spider-Man it
doesn't feel like Wolverine it's too
cartoonish why isn't it gritty and more
realistic looking that's that's a
comment I know is going to happen cuz I
thought it myself and I'm like I know I
would play the game regardless of course
but I would be I've always said this
about if you're going to and listen
there there's there's conversations that
PlayStation just wins in when it comes
to certain things right and a lot of the
place if you think about the love for
PlayStation that goes back many many
years but recent PlayStation that love
that love comes from the fact that when
they talk about triaa games there is an
archetype of that game that has
convinced people that this is quality
this is the best there is correct you
when you look it up
at at an insomnia game when you look at
the last of us when you look at a ghost
of tsushima people consider that top of
the top best of the best and the fact
that they've done that now with VD with
with um with uh superhero games right
we've seen Batman before him but now
Spider-Man with this yeah superhero
games stand in that Echelon now so I
just want this game to have every leg up
that possibly can have without people
finding dumb reasons to dislike it and
to and to shoot it down and I guarantee
you whether it be press whether it be
people on the internet whatever they
somebody's gonna be like I wish it would
looked more realistic I looked it look
wish it look more visceral right so just
that but at the end of the day I know
gameplay wise that game is going to hit
I I know I know at the maybe I eat crow
in four years I hope I don't but I
listen I love the way they develop games
I love the the way they think about
action and movement and the idea of hand
to hand combat forward- facing combat
and stealth right incorporate that with
incorporate that with vampire likee
abilities I I think they're really like
Dinka said like Coop abilities no none
of that no no that solo abilities are
they are they forcing a multiplayer no
no not at all baby it's all blade it's
all blade um I'm very excited for what
like Dinka said let us cook yeah let us
we're cooking right now let us cook um
I'm super excited for it did you hear
the part where he said play BL blade
your way way exactly so that was Arcane
Aran the arcan of it it's like what does
that mean what does the skill tree look
like what is what what is it what are
your options going to be in com
red the good thing the good thing about
the good thing about blade is I feel
like Blade's a very versatile character
he can fight multiple different ways so
I think his type of fighting style and
the way he can go about of combat works
good for
Arcane I I'm excited for what they can
do um we'll see what the art style pans
out to be or whatever but um now talking
about the the quote unquote controversy
yeah yeah controversy I I agree with
addict in that like it's like man I get
all the stuff behind the scenes and I
Microsoft is the company that's always
going to think about that right but
they're also a company that especially
Phil Phil is very much aware of what the
community is saying oh he got his pulse
on the C he has he has his finger on the
pulse he knows what you know the Twitter
streets are saying he and he he wants to
push back against that which is I wasn't
here to talk about this topic go back to
the whole the third party thing and
whatever Xbox listen Phil is never going
to tell the Xbox base that they are not
going to get a console and I firmly
believe that under him right him being
the over of the whole thing overse we're
always going to get an Xbox console even
if it's to their detriment because the
numbers say people you know want to play
except whatever game someplace else
whatever the case may be we will get a
console okay so you think Su be out
before Xbox oh
God I don't know where I said
that I'm just
asking if son many goes out before Xbox
it's because an extreme drop of the ball
and no like they doing
nowo blade why what does it Happ to do
with blade oh my God I'm just I'm just
messing I I don't know none of this
makes any sense to me continue s when
when do I make
sense we just want Kong it back back
back to that discussion so Phil you know
Phil Phil knows y'all crazy back to
seeing this Phil knows that y'all are
crazy he tell he's not going to give
he's to be like yeah you're out no no
more console for y the streets would
burn he's not to do that he got the
street even even if like you know
whatever the future holds may may be on
multiple platforms whatever the case may
be but a lot of different things have to
happen for that to be the case right
um the controversy about this I I do
agree with ad I was like man I get it
you don't I think they I they definitely
should have talked about it here I think
this is the stage to bring it up even
his four years out Sony's been doing it
forever and a lot of times when you
think about you know this idea of Sony
kind of maintaining momentum even when
they don't have some stuff going on it's
because the expectation that stuff like
this is in the pipeline right yes did we
need to hear about Wolverine when they
talked about it no but it helps right it
helps so I think that was totally fine
um obviously they didn't say it I don't
think that they're being wishy-washy
about internally
this is I don't know maybe this will be
exclusive maybe this internally they're
not wishy-washy about it even if the
messaging feels that way cuz we saw that
internal Indiana Jones exactly it was
like n this is definitive nah let's go
right so they know what they want to do
for whatever reason and I think it makes
a whole lot of sense that yeah the FTC
stuff isn't done Lena Khan is not done
with them yet she's fighting tooth and
nail and nail wasting my tax dollars
absolutely they want to run it they want
to run it back
but she know she she needs to justify
what she does right they like the
scoreboard like went I'm not I'm not mad
her cuz she yeah she needs to justify
what she doing I had to do my shot they
was coming for me I had to get my shot
shot work I understand them being quiet
but it just sucks because it's always
them that it's always them that feels
like they have this mixed messaging
right and it's never like and to King's
Point I know King wants to see the boot
on the neck yes and I think with the
showing that they had they showed like
Hey listen this is the mayor culo we
didn't give you anything last year I get
it here here you go right and even then
and even then they dropped the ball on
on their last mic drop which was hey by
the way game of the year winner blah but
that wasn't for that was your
man that was your man in a hot T suit
yeah 10 man was supposed to do the job
suit he he apologized he was he was the
one that was supposed to say yeah he
literally he said he said I only had one
job
was to get out there accept game of the
year and tell it that it's now available
Xbox and I messed it up so he literally
had to go on Twitter and apologize to
Xbox they had to get back that bread too
what you had to s a check back oh man
you got to give back the bread that we
paid you to say to say man I like that K
give it back but again I I think listen
the Xbox base has been battered for a a
long time you know there's Winds of this
nature have not happened right even
we've gotten the stuff that we've wanted
as Xbox fans right you get your Halo or
whatever and they and you enjoy them you
don't enjoy them they underwhelmed the
general masses they whatever the case
may be you like getting wins that should
be wins across the board that even the
biggest of haters can't can't can't be
mad at like you got to eat that right
and when you have this type of stuff
you're like damn the discourse is
someplace else the discourse isn't oh
wow Arcane is making a blade game what
can that possibly be the discourse is
who's going to get is everybody going to
get it who going to get it exactly and
it's just like I you know I'm tired of
that I'm tired of that but but I get it
but I I still do think it was the right
move to me the biggest stage of the year
everybody's watching even the casuals
are watching the industry is watching it
is time to announce it and you if you
really want long term to people be to to
be excited about the Xbox brand you have
to do things like this so I think it was
the right place to do it and I'm excited
for I mean listen man I I don't hide my
love for Arcane I love those games I
love the way they play I love the way
they think about game design um and
applying that to to to Blade perfect
character yeah no doubt King you've been
patient what are your thoughts first on
the announcement the vibe you're you're
a Marvel head but you know you have your
thoughts on the games you love
Spider-Man and then obviously the whole
controversy after so what was your whole
thing cuz we did not get a chance to
watch this with
um my whole thing with these individuals
where's CH at she's inside um I have the
I have a guy texting me about it um my
whole thing is insomniac comes
out says
Spider-Man uh Guerilla games comes out
and says
Horizon
[Music]
um y'all don't sit there and say yo
Spider-Man coming over
here y just know yeah logo PlayStation
logo be there yeah just you just
know we're developing this for
Microsoft
Xbox oh um is it coming out for us we
need to
know no you
don't there a court case going
on we don't need to give them any ammo
to say see they just announced blade and
blade isus to them this is exactly what
they said they was going to
do and everything that comes out from um
ABK is going to be exclusive we need to
stop this now
no why do you need to know for sure and
why are y'all so weak that y listen to
the PlayStation dudes why we got to be
like yo
literally y'all are saying back the
stuff that they're saying to you yeah
Microsoft needs to put the boot on their
neck no Microsoft needs to announce it
and walk off the stage it's ours m
that's it until they say it's
not but you supposed to assume it's
yours oh so you say they not even
confident that it's their they they have
no confidence I seen a bunch of jelly
back dudes we oh they not Advance the
line the jelly back dudes is back the
The Mustard Seed dudes you know what's
crazy when dbat got to tweet me mhm that
we need to get these dudes to hold the
line wait they weak as they can't do a
push-up they can't do a sit up debats
don't ever add me in any
tweet and it's getting to the point now
where you dudes are too damn soft like
like what do you do you need the
confidence do you need the Boost like
you don't need it like stand on your
Square listen this is the reason why
they they able to rough you guys up I
got chills right there I felt like
Vaseline
2.0 cuz I'm watching it I was de I'm
watching it you supposed to be
happy Spider-Man got
zero why they got catch they show they
show God of War Valla which is a Rog
like uh they they fight on the corner
they fight on the corner with the same
ogres and they switching them out for
red blue and green I can't and he going
to get some Rogue like
moose and y'all guys it's a whole
game hellblade it's whole
game y'all just want the show
win this is this is the this is this is
why I don't like you dudes it's just
like you're like a boxer who only picks
people that they can
beat you will never be great never be
remembered because you don't have
confidence within yourself everything I
saw Microsoft dropping that's us that's
us and and and and Blake why would I
question if it's Microsoft they said
Legacy titles do he have a legacy over
there there is a blade
game on PS1 King In fairness there is
was it
made by uh uh these dud no no no all
right be Bethesda didn't make it Arcane
didn't make it facts and they own and
they owned by King I got to ask you this
I got and then we got to get addict yeah
part of part of putting a boot on the
neck right is I'm I'm going show you
something that's a boot on the neck in a
second my thing is like I get what
you're saying right and a lot of dudes
come off like they're scared like they
don't believe but a lot of people want
but a lot of people just want the I love
howed but tell me this right tell me
this right I'mma tell you what these
dudes are when you when they when they
come out and say it directly you the
first one R yeah you be outside with
your chest outside with the chest my
chest was
my is is still outside I feel in your
heart of hearts you don't need to infer
anything you know in your heart of
hearts right I get it but isn't it that
much dudes is weak isn't it that much
sweeter when you come out and you
because you can't say that you get mad
when they come out and if they had come
out and said exclusive You' have been
screaming from the Raptors too okay all
right you know why it's more sweeter
like this why why I get a chance to see
people Port
bag I get a chance to see you get to see
the weakness I get a chance to see the
opposition cry for it and then so so
wait so you implying that if XBox would
have jumped out and said they had a logo
for the jump they' have tried to dismiss
it but now that they know now that this
hope not if this hope that he come to
like yo Christopher put the conversation
would have been different right they
would put it to oh it looks whack right
so Pro so proof of the tax that's what
we doing this is
okay good get get it let he wait he wait
to me especially like look everyone here
I'm pretty sure we we're confident that
this suck is exclusive
blade dud blad and all his 4K Glory
gonna be on that Xbox whatever system I
don't know if it's be the next system or
this system yeah he gonna be there man
him and his sword everything and and the
only reason that I I was pushing back on
announcing at this event is cuz I didn't
want no back no P you want I wanted I
wanted shut down like see King wants
King wants wants to go back and forth
with them he wants to give them back and
forth King wants to give them hope I
didn't want no hope I wanted I wanted
the light in their eyes that is true
king so so what about so what about the
the the dudes that you call a muster
heart they just like yo we yeah jelly
back right we we just want to put the
boot we want to be with you K we want to
let that no no no no no no see we would
to let the other bases it's ours
Microsoft can come out and say this is
exclusive okay jelly bags dudes will
always say something well I don't really
like the art direction of you funny
though you know what I find hilarious
King we clown on Playstation when they
don't put only on PlayStation on stuff
and when they put the little things at
the bottom saying time exclusive ends at
this dat like we we clown on them for
that we do I it can't happen both ways I
don't clown on them when their first
party Studio comes out and announces a
game I don't expect it to show up unless
it's MLB to show that threw me for a
loop right and why why is that the
reason that you don't clown on them
because PlayStation has made it their
life's goal to tell you our stuff is our
stuff that's not it that's not it then
why don't you ever clown on them what
what it is is cuz they don't put that
only on on PlayStation on anything
anymore so why why a we having this
conversation with every single releas
why why they not having that
conversation because me personally when
when when Spider-Man came out I didn't
expect it to show up on uh on Xbox but I
do expect all those Activision
Spider-Man to show up at some point but
I only say this to say let's go I'm so
sick and tired of you jelly back dudes
this is what made me do the hold the
line jelly back dudes you dudes aren't
strong for anything y'all got a job like
this is your night everybody is saying
Xbox cleaned up Xbox did this Xbox did
that and you guys are talking to the
half knots all right but but fair but
can we
say but not but can't we say that this
is somewhat
self-inflicted from Xbox's mix
messag is outside all right you but see
you're in the no king you are you are in
the trenches for real for real
yeah here the thing so wait wait let me
let me get my ball let me get my ball
quick I'm been P so my thing is there's
certain dudes are like General King we
want to finish
them cuz Tim Stewart the other the other
corporate Corporal is saying maybe
things might go other places and then we
got to wait for dominis to come outside
and say otherwise so people like what's
up with the Corporal what's up with the
dominis how come we don't have a unified
message on where things is going yeah
here here is my thing how come you are
not secure do you see when hold on a
second adct when turn 10 comes out and
say Forza Motorsport right we out right
sck not one person says is it going to
PlayStation I now one person says is it
going there why would we have a Victory
you let these dudes put blood in your
snow stop doing it leave these guys
alone they leave the door open for for
someone to come through and sneak
through the potential they said they
said they said blade and close the door
they they they said BL there was no Xbox
logo order for the door to be closed
okay said we purchased by Microsoft we
doing
blade King here's the thing I am so
tired of for years it's say starfields
exclusive is is is it
exclusive but that's not the point how
many times on this podcast have we
debated on whether or not Xbox gam then
we got to wait for the dominance to come
outside it's always the dominance got to
come and straighten it Phil always got
to come content creators I for that part
got it I got it I got it all right let's
go let's go General cuz you got to ad
Phil always has to set the record
straight that why need to be set
straight get it let's go let's go so
when you go to Wifey do you go into the
room every day and I are we still
married every time do you see her all
right all right
but you
ask what happens if your wife declared
to someone that she she ain't married
what if you you walk up every day and
you don't see the ring on you be like yo
where's your Xbox Rings wifey all right
all so so check out so and Sol as a
married man will noce does a ring make a
marriage that was a b all right you got
me got it all all right it all right all
right but I will say this it's a a out
time out time out and you know like I
know a ring is an attractor so so let's
check this out Che it out attracts drama
that's for sure it does attract drama
cuz they feel like I can get to where I
got to get to and this dude ain't going
to leave with he anyway so this is for
you dud some jelly back go ahead L I was
wrong go ahead exactly so listen you
guys need
reassurance You're So Soft you're so
beat up from before Xbox one did it to
me man I'm scared kid Xbox One
Man bro we've been beat up we've been
abused it's more than that for these
dudes these dudes I can barely walk
these days bro soft talk Sund they
secretly brought a PlayStation they
secretly over there they secretly
capping I openly cap but what I'm saying
is guys come on man stop it have some
pride I did say I know it's coming to
you see these guys Port begging like i'
I have I have never you know what's
funny King gets so much enjoyment out of
PlayStation people making a pool of
themselves he doesn't care whether or
not they have good messaging or not I
hope Microsoft I hope Microsoft never
come out and say said only on Xbox I
hope they never come out and say that
they purposely don't tell you every game
release you know you know how Hal they
don't tell you yeah check this out you
know how you keep a fool in suspense
yeah how you
doing the
silence silence silence is how you keep
a fool in the suspense Mt booty is a
damn genius you are a genius sir listen
we got stuff going on we're going to
spend these dudes out of business you
love that line you
love and we're going to confuse the F
out I mean is psychological warfare oh I
got it I'm with you I'm advancing the
line I'm advancing the line now I got it
I'm back I'm back on point I'm back on
and I know I I do I do think there is
some there is some truth in that I do
think that they they low-key know if
they don't address anything they're
going to get way more coverage in the
industry but I don't believe all all
coverage is good cover to me we should
be highlighting the fact that Xbox has
an exclusive superhero
game but it just because it reinforces
the idea in the general community that
Xbox is mad wishy-washy about everything
it don't it don't reinforce none of that
wife
talk out the house point wife goes out
the house knowing that she's married to
you sir
exactly but what about what about the
potential suitors out
there okay but it's up to her as she
walked past to be like y ma'am may I may
I have your time see but here's the
thing here's the thing you know I got
something for that AR that's what I mean
I got something for that argument why if
sa popped up and his wife don't have his
ring on why don't you got my stuff on
you I did that's what I said that's
that's a level of insecurity that
doesn't need to be had he is right he is
right he's right I will say this if you
are insecure after 15 years of this up
camera I come home I come who me
no listen I come home every
day years are you gonna ask me tomorrow
you coming home but here's the thing
here it might happen one time but ke we
talking six seven times I walk home my
wife don't got her ring on half the week
I'm going be like what's going on I'm
not you know what I'm going to say
I'm not what you say but she could have
probably took it to go get clean she
could have probably took it to go get
six seven times yes because the insecure
man is gonna find things to be always
upset
with sit there she about she about to go
out she takes her off her wedding ring
puts it out ah I don't know multiple
times King I'm I'm I'm a fill away if
every time you leave this house your
wedding rings off your finger that's
that's the dudes that looking at the
cameras in
house that's those
dud dud checking DMS and email why is
that guy that's the dud that theone you
got you got the you got the CFO saying
completely different stuff so that's
equivalent to a dude sending or send you
a message yo your chicks hit me
up and if and if no and if she is then
she can go that part you can't miss
something that don't want to be there so
if blade needs to be over there then let
it be but the problem is until I walk in
and they doing it it's not happening
it's not but the the level of insecurity
is so high you're giving off this weird
energy I don't have that energy so my
energy is
different the Xbox front line Y
understand we will kill Kong we keep the
boot on the neck of the PlayStation
Nation and there will be no PlayStation
6 you need to realize King that as a
general as a leader of men sometimes you
have to be the one that has you have to
be the one that has the gung-ho The gung
hoess about what I'm doing here so
you're you're in shaming them you're
trying to build them back up and build
them to where you at disrespect them and
te them and bring them back you got to
break them down and we boot camp we boot
camp that's what it is that's what we
doing you know what thinking about I
should have got a blade poster back here
I don't know why don't do that cuz you
don't know the
exclusive there's a difference between
me saying I want the mar I want the the
the communication and I want just in
general talk with Microsoft to be better
than me not agreeing that exclusive I
literally came out on Twitter an hour
after that thing would put my my my name
on it
okay the street street so say this right
could you imagine they came out and say
only on Xbox they just said that
whatever legal action they got going on
we don't care about that like yo we
don't care that we just we will possibly
lose this all right this this is for you
jelly back dudes listen to
here your insecurities is risking the
bag all right you got to understand how
many times do your girl got a haar are
you cheating and she's not before she
does so you got to get it together bro
going to something right now cooking
this is the time when you supposed to be
secure within yourself and understand
it's coming to us period until it's
not yo and if it's not then let it be
okay F but but you as a man you got to
stand on your toes stand on your Square
I saw a show I
yo I literally no okay thank you cuz you
know sometimes say Nam stop it I saw the
show and I was elated with what I
seen and at no and everybody with a
spine saw that Microsoft walked away the
big winner of the show fact not I know
what you're talking about not not not
putting Xbox only on
blade kept it in the
cycle keeping it spinning without
getting in
trouble putting question marks in the
FTC head oh reverse chess okay okay okay
you listen hasn't Phil been playing 4D
chess with these dudes for the long fact
hasn't he been like fainting them out of
position this whole time M hasn't he
isn't he the one that brought us back
from the Brink tell y that before isn't
he Phil Dominus Maximus really expensive
first of his name isn't he to rise a DOL
Phil who did that for us so let me tell
you something in the empire did you know
they was
there before it
happened you didn't that boy cold with
it so when they said Order
66 the Jedi couldn't
recover wait wait till it's there's no
left ain't getting out of this
one you got to understand they
got in everything is revolved around
PlayStation I have everything has to be
PlayStation Des so invested in hit the
like but where the likes at let me see
the likes I'm my boy is cooking it's
only 700 likes we got to get these likes
up you got to understand he cooking line
is
Master if if you guys stand your ground
now get L you saw them hey on Starfield
yeah why cuz they don't got it oh
remember when they was capping for
Boulders gate yeah oh yeah that a c no
more that's true that's true yo I
see yo I see people say I can't believe
people like this style of game play cuz
one Spider-Man they went now all sudden
cuz they was acting like it was an
exclusive before when they a know that
is true that remember that month that
came out listen I understand why it's
not in Game Pass too I understand that
part too okay okay I would have wanted
it in there to put the boot on their
neck right right right but I understand
why it's not in there why it's not in
there K it's not in there because
Starfield need to do what Starfield does
if you want to play the game is on our
platform go buy it got you got that's
RPG from from we have RPG can we get it
can we get it later though can we get it
later baby when it dies down okay so
then go out to
Z spin the block then get the spin the
block on them you know cuz right now
they acting crazy enough they just one
game of the year so you know they was
like to your
to your point you said they going to do
something crazy and they had like they
had a plan to win the award and say
now and he messed up the bag he messed
up the bag okay that's why that's why he
didn't get the cookies he didn't get the
cook the check had get sent back he
messed give those back send those back
okay it's like I said man like I'm
thrilled they got a blade and the I I I
went more towards like like spawning
them or Batman because I was convinced
people like blade was off the table no
doubt I'm going get my ball to to me
they got one of the most unique people
like it's like I told they got someone I
didn't even know it a comic book here
but I love the movies yeah that that's
the importance of Blade prcu premc let
me get in look come on blade means so
much like adct just said you know Prem
MCU to show Comics comic book movies a
character can be relevant I still
remember sa to this day the club scene
Wesley Snipes Walking In The Joint you
know what I'm saying you I bought techno
music for the first time because of that
damn movie what was that that
confusion that J was crazy the blood
came down from Bill he that wasn't the
club he wanted to be in at that moment
you know what I'm saying I said this
character is amazing the reason why it's
grounded the reason why blade is perfect
for video game character adaptation is
because he's grounded then you get the
dark gritty tone right and let's be
clear shout out to you know a lot of
people on Xbox is that sometimes we feel
like we haven't had since since Peter
has been gone we we missed some of the
gritty darker XBox exclusive but gears
came out original gears we had Cliffy on
in the realm right darker tall gritty
the fear that energy like blade
represents that with the vampiress and
then what I like with Arcane set is
whatever type of Blade you choose to be
so that to me gives me like maybe
there's a morality Choice with how he
handles things and maybe the skill trees
and all of that you know for me I set it
off rip yall know I'm hashtag just one
but once the rumors started picking up
I'm like in my mind I conceded I was
like this was going to be third person I
mean this is going to be first person
because want to believe it existed me
yeah I it was too good to be true when
we heard how long have you had we been
we've been sit we've been sitting on it
before came I didn't want to get my
hopes up too hard because I'm like you
know what Cog you always want a hasht
just one and even if it's not I don't
know because we got to see it right we
got to see we know third we got most of
the categories filed I just need to see
it in action and then we can finalize
that decision but more important forget
all that it's what me and AD would talk
about I've been on the superhero Square
I've been on Xbox where is your game
that is pop culture that is relevant and
I don't care what nobody say you see
what the the the viewership is doing
right now with the announcement of this
game I knew this was going to happen
that's why I've been consistently on
Xbox's neck you need one of those I
don't care what these Fanboys talk about
you be emotional all you want I know
what moves the needle that moves the
needle do you see how people are jumping
out their seats right now you got people
Port begging you got people excited you
got people that don't even care about
video games but they care about blade
and they're like yo I want that so to me
the reason why blade is perfect got the
Game Pass thing up here's the thing King
you gonna you gonna appreciate the
reason the reason oh my fault thank you
um the reason why no no not even that
the reason why you're going to
appreciate it is because let's be real
bra is perfect in this respect like a
like a daredevil or grounded street
level character because let's be honest
doing a Superman who's kind of
indomitable doing a Hulk who's kind of
you know what I mean those guys are you
can make characters that are actually
put his life in Peril exactly which
translates better to video gamess right
the fact that he can be killed he is
still human mostly right so that
translate then the SCE point it's so
perfect because Arcane could take it in
many different directions they can do
action but they can also do have stealth
components to it I wonder if they get
Dracula in this
game speaking of which if you play
midnight Suns and you play with blade
and all the DLC there's a strong vampire
sub boss whole thing going on with that
they could could take from that the
other I'm sorry who's going to jump he
has a huge lore oh huge I actually I
truly believe as much as I I actually
did enjoy Spider-Man 2 I think if Arcane
gets the Aesthetics right the TR uh you
know with Insomniac I'm completely on
okay they're going to know how to move
around the map they're going to make it
look nice right uh but I'm always are
they goingon to have the game play fun
right is it going to be okay but Arcane
it's like reverse yes can they get the
trans versal right I'm I don't know but
I know that game will play nice that
game listen that is the perfect Studio
do traversal in the sense of how people
would think like of a Spider-Man so that
this game could he is super fat like he
does have superhuman abilities so there
is some form of transversal that will be
in it to an extent adct and and when I
was talking about the midnight Suns he
comes from the comic books of the
midnight Suns that rebranded him right
first he came in uh and tales of
suspense or whatever and I think of the
book of Dracula something like that and
um no he came through werewolf by night
I got that book anyway um the fact of
the matter is he has a lineage to
characters like moonight yes right there
to um Iron all right um well morbius not
so much not so much oh because in
Midnight Suns when I played it unless
that you correct me if I'm wrong when I
play they that's an Adder on or later on
story where he doesn't respect morbius
cuz he gives into the flesh he's a he's
yeah he's a living vampire not a real
vampire and he doesn't ever respect
morbius yeah and I liked it that Dynamic
when I was playing Midnight Suns I was
like oh I never knew this okay continue
so so if this game
hits and you'll see how Wolverine really
doesn't have no connection to
Spider-Man right that is what Sony did
was what is the most uh notable
characters in the Marvel
Universe and they went for those
characters Spiderman Wolverine right so
okay what we do is tie them in the
universe right the only time that they
was tied in the universe is what if
Wolverine killed Spider-Man that was a
side thing pie they're not really tied
together he's really tied to the Hulk
right um yes blade talk to me that game
hits you can get Ghost Rider oh yes you
can get moonight you can get the
Punisher let's go there so Coalition
making the Punisher tell me that a give
me a curb give me a curb stomp damn it
this is this is the stuff that is is
available to you but a lot of you guys
don't
celebrate getting an entry drug like
this is this is it right here you
secured the bag y'all all said it I'm
the only one that was standing it by
myself saying that n y'all don't need
that well apparently y'all was right and
I was wrong I appreciate you brother so
the fact of the matter is until further
notice it's yours facts oh no listen and
now let me get to the controvers since I
talked about the thing yeah like to me
it's it's no doubt you know unless
something wild happens and I get proven
wrong I don't and I'm not even thinking
about it to me it's a combination of
things one I actually think it's more so
Xbox is in the position whether right or
wrong M when you acquire a publisher
part of doing that acquisition is still
allowing them car blunch in the way they
present then to your point King I do
think there is a factor here with the
FTC and that let's be honest this game
is still a ways away so there's still
time there but I personally look when if
this was blade live service MMO maybe
you know what I'm saying something
totally different yeah maybe then we
could talk like that's the only scenario
I could see or in the rare case of a
call Duty a Minecraft or let's say for
example Xbox acquired epic you know
fortnite you know fortnite you can't
really lock down to one platform that's
what they did to Minecraft right so it's
like you got to then so this ain't that
so to me this follows based on the
playbook play this follows what happened
to Starfield what happened redfall
remember when we saw the information the
tapes came out we got the dirp they said
yeah erase day eras day console version
remember they like take you was working
on that you're not working he came in
the house he said who bag is that
correct oh that's that's Jim's bag throw
that in the garbage ex we know the dirt
is out that is a fact they they they
cancelled the PlayStation versions on
site we wasn't supposed to know that we
wasn't supposed to you know how dope
that is Phil came in they was
like that's a death kit for the
PlayStation th trash I
can't got that music you stupid you will
not get it thought y was slick guess
what happened and Y still P begging for
Starfield it's whack I don't like it
yeah you're messy you're messy but to
your point also we do know based on the
dirt that was revealed this was a
struggle for Bethesda culture-wise
pre-acquisition they used to everywhere
oh we said it everywhere that was a
struggle for one person well we're not
going to do that but I know where you
going that's my man that's my man though
that's my man that's I love love
struggle for one person name that's my
man listen he stood on his Square he
stood on business yeah we going to put
that square down the
block have a nice day mat yo Matt you
want to you want to spend them out of
business you in charge let's go at shut
up at the end of the day it's just this
is part of the growing pains through
acquisition especially of a publisher
this is not a man no your girl don't get
to go out date the same old
ex-boyfriends we exclusive now that's it
so all right Big Pimpin you are allowing
her to say go out do what you want but
you to your point King like standing on
Square advancing the line you know she
comes home to you no that's inure that's
insecure so I get it I get it that's not
insecure what the hell you talking about
anyway secure you got to let her rock no
you don't okay first of all contact your
ex-boyfriend and going to ex-boyfriends
and doing stuff like that is not
insecure that's that's foolish bro
that's that's a recipe for disaster so
listen you said that's it no more yeah
facts we we know they're in a
relationship that's they got have kids
together see the game of service is the
kids together yeah okay fair enough fa
that's pre relationship the kids still
get to go over there okay fair enough
fair enough so all I was saying in
completion so that was that with the
blade that's where I'm at with I did
want to get this ball for for soft cuz I
didn't get a chance to talk to
with the game was is did we talk enough
about the Sega Jo for for you did we did
we saate that because for me the grown
man tears again seeing
shobi bro you you want to have him talk
about Sega and he's talking about Sega
for a whole different reason yeah oh
yeah this this is where we all are
together yes see everybody on this
podcast has a Ste
spine until proven otherwise yes so I
can't wait for Salman to go into his I
waited for this I wait for it like f
like the reason why it's so emotional
because again y'all know my history
addict knows the history you know as a
kid growing up in the South Bronx 167
Street Webster Avenue there was only the
one arcade I was a laundry mat that had
Shinobi you know I used to go to there
play this religiously drag off on
occasion and basically you know I wanted
that was the Dark Souls in the Ninja
craze era one hit one kill welcome to
bonus stage you know what I'm saying
ninja magic the whole thing my whole
namesake is for this this damn game my
whole love of Sega is for this whole
game game so to see the arcade Marquee
in the back already took me to 87 I'm in
my I'm in my old man that's the joint
then to see okay not only doing that
we're standing on all the classics from
the Genesis era everything that we
bought I literally I never forget get
this day sof come to me young soft comes
to me Co about I got money for the
console what should I get what should I
get and I literally Fanboy this man down
the Sega path I said look man I know
Nintendo's outside and all that but that
double drag is two players over here
and saying the Sega mask system is the
more powerful console you know what I'm
saying and I was like yo they got shovi
and hang on and out run son the joints
he all Co I'm I'm going listen to you I
heard they doing a deal they getting to
I remember it like yesterday he was like
I could get I said you get a free double
dragon packet game with your I said get
out of here and he came
over was like why are we still talking
why don't you already have bro he came
over he brought his his Mass system with
the Double J we played it all night son
we rocked that joint y man when they
said that remember cuz the Double Dragon
it wasn't out yet that was that was a
kick yeah so I didn't have I got the
console and I was rocking you know alra
be beast and I hang on Safari hunt cuz I
had the gun right and then they were
like yo but you going to get in the mail
you going to get double dragon and this
was some serious and I didn't believe I
was like you know and when that thing
arrived it arrived like on a Wednesday
right and I'm not allowed to play games
during the week I
remember used to come through my CRI
just and I asked Mom Mom please like
it's double drag she was like you have
one hour to play that one hour me and to
rock it out like rock it out rock it out
so I'm telling Cog I had called Cog and
I was like Cog yo like I got double
drink I believe you I didn't believe you
at first believe you so I go I said yo
I'mma bring I was I was like I'mma bring
the book tomorrow
y yeah I'mma bring the manuals I brought
the manual it was like oh my God it
flipp it through you cooba like my God
we was in home classes Mr IR girl was
our home room remember was younger than
than could have been Mr angry yeah
that's right or maybe before that's J
anyway continue yeah so we go and I'm
like so cock's like yo I gotta come home
with you today so you can check it out
right so I was like that's the way he
was going with this cuz could play her
any day it didn't matter right I was
loose so only he comes over he comes
over we got a little Blaze on we rock
out and then um your mom was like all
right that's it I already told you I
told you an hour yesterday and you
brought Barry over the time like come on
like cool and so he he doesn't ask me he
asked my B he's like yo Mr sand can I
can I borrow
this yo I was negotiating early son she
was like she was like of course you
can son of a I was thirsty son I was
thirsty he had the exclusive know so but
again that's my B I was like let rock
out I I never knew this story he let
Meck I knew he was going to blaze it I
was he like I'll bring it back Friday to
for school you have it for the weekend
that was so much love did you end this
joint of course he did many time because
immediately that's why you got that back
that's why I did that too but we ended
it we ended it in my house too cuz we
found out immediately but he ended it
first don't matter the ultimate lives
yeah we as long as I beat it first I was
happy you know what say I like K who
beat your new Strider 8 big Mega bit
cartridge in your face when we came home
from you paid 89 right for that yeah it
was $80 6 mega bit cartridge I CAU bad
expensive and you beat it in my face you
brought it from crazy sound
was Crazy Eddie I thought maybe Crazy
Eddie he said beat it in my face pa
pause that was wild
pause crazyit the music the
music we we beat the game the I think it
was crazy Eddie Crazy Eddie back there
back then kind of he was kind of like
yeah he was kind of like your Mr lead
your Mr Le you you'd go across the
street to the whz and the whz wouldn't
have the game yet because they had that
regular you know release Cadence Crazy
Eddie across the street and we knew he
was doing some very funky stuff um he
would get things early he was the Mr Lee
of that time so yes cuz I got Fantasy
Star there early I got everything there
but he had the $10 tax on his oh yeah oh
he he rocked rocked
hecked the so the crazy thing right like
he rocks out he brings it back Friday
right so Friday he comes home with me
anyway we rocking out and then Saturday
I go to his house and we rock
that's how much we love Double Dragon
that's how much I remember when we
played it cuz that was when remember
before I moved up to the fourth floor
right of the of the house I was still
down the first floor I was back in the
first floor days and we brought the
masses St we had the two player Rock oh
man I love that so yes this just hit
come continue continue this was what it
for you I mean I'm I'm when I saw it and
I saw the type of games they were making
I would have been excited to see more
like straight up just 2D stuff but to
see them taking their properties and
rethinking what they could be in a
modern context and seeing streets of
rays in 3D seeing uh golden ax in 3D
seeing Crazy Taxi looking even wilder
than before seeing looking at Jet Set
Radio and and and looking at and looking
you know that is not a rem that is a
remake of that
game and you know to see Shinobi and
immediately I saw Shinobi and I'm like
oh they're doing Metroid Vania slash
you're going to have the combat you're
going to have the platform and you're
going to have you know the the Metroid
Vania esque thing you know Metro Vania
of it where it's like maybe you're going
to have multiple paths and things of
that nature in addition to you give me
the difficult bosses you maybe give me
some stealth right that's when I looked
at it I was like Mark of the Ninja Vibes
with the art style maybe maybe but shobi
has never
been he been action platforming hard
bosses that kind of thing thinking of
these classic franchises and not just
give oh here's the arcade game or
whatever that's cool but and the fact
that they came out and said we want to
go back to our edginess and rebellious
mindset
mindset shout out to Jean for going in
there and getting all the information
that we wanted we need it fact shout out
to Peter Mo kind of for shadow in the OG
where is he from where is Jean from J uh
Washington Post Washington Post okay no
doubt okay got that get him name oh oh
you know Jean the homie I know Jee Park
I know so uh the fact that you know even
before this we saw no what happened was
really I thought you was talking about
Jean oh you thought
G I jumped out the window crazy okay out
the window oh yeah yeah for sure for
sure but um the fact that even a few
weeks prior we're we're getting Virtual
Fighter 3 a new version of virtual
fighter I was like yo sega's is going
back
PE off it said those tent and it said
and more more so they got more they
could dig in the crat with that's crazy
they have so much like when we think
about all the things and shout out to
everborn because everborn literally
wrote down on Twitter everything that
I've been thinking for years right so we
Sega kids are all the same we want a
true Fantasy Star I want my I want that
in House of the Dead I want House of the
Dead back for PlayStation VR too oh my
God House of the Dead go like yo there's
so many so many of their old IP because
they come from a simpler time you can
take them and recontextualize them in a
modern context that that it will still
be fun to play you don't have to make
them Triple A games or you can depending
on what the IP is right all of these
things are viable in a modern setting
and I'm glad that whatever happened in
Sega has happened and people are
recognizing this and putting respect on
the name of these old classic IPS that
absolutely should be coming back
sometimes there's certain things that
happen that come out you like you know
what it had his time let it die whatever
the case may be these IP are not that
they should be coming back I love the
direction that it seems like they're
taking all of them um it shows that
there is love and reverence and and and
the willingness to to maybe get called
out a little bit and say
hey you're taking this a little far
you're going a little in in a direction
I wasn't expecting with this I don't
don't care yes take the risk bring it
back you're never going to know unless
you try and then if you stumble we're
going to tell you you stumble and then
move forward from that but just be
willing to bring them back don't Focus
just on Sonic Yakuza and and Atlas games
like facts I mean in the in in Def fense
that like that's what kept them alive
right if it wasn't for Sonic the
Resurgence it wasn't for Yakuza games it
wasn't for Persona you know addict
generation kind of kept us afloat right
and then
us now just of theth this super these
individual how going do it but it's it
was such a move and I was excited it was
I I couldn't have imagined anything as
better as that and to be lowkey crazy
tax me had be excited I I like the way
this new look of it it looks because it
looks Bonkers it almost looks like they
could drive up buildings something like
that look crazy almost like a Need for
Speed with the we going along cuz we got
mad topics but I did I definitely wanted
to shout that out and then the remaining
games I mention
I I like the game from what is it um
private sector or private um private
division private division yeah they had
um oh the dudes that did
ay no you talk yeah oh eeko are the
falling no not that what you talking
about no no Echo something um it was it
was a space game and and not the space
game where you flying a [__] exus yeah
ex I think it's Exodus and and the girl
came through and she had the helmet on
right like Mass Effect like Mass Effect
those are the dudes that the X the X
yeah BioWare guys all right
so that that game has been in
development since 2014 yes let me do is
put that I thought it was Vapor I
thought it was never coming I saw I kept
seeing trailers I kept seeing um demos
like for new uh video cards yeah and
that they showed it there we got a lot
of games at this game awards and I don't
think you know Jeff is getting enough
credit for the amount of trailers that
he did show new stuff for promo listen
we we know what the priorities are when
it comes to uh promo game trailers
theatrics it's on like that you could
make the argument it was their best one
on that level that was the best that
there's no you can't we can't deny that
I just want to give a couple other games
they shot that we didn't say um
Warhammer Space Marine 2 um that look
crazy um Asar r or to VR that looks
crazy go get your you like the um those
little um bird things which one which
one what what was it called walk out or
something like that and they was like
they was you all right remember back in
the days your moms used to have like
this little drinking bird yeah the I
know you talking about yeah them dud I
they turn those into little walking guys
walking guys the characters yeah and
that G look interesting to me interesed
we got that before um yeah I I mean we
got talk about OD we going to talk about
yeah that's say we talk about o um light
light no fire we said the um um the guys
from Hello games that did um remember
he's down doing um the no man Sky guys
down doing open world Planet game just
be careful with all the stuff you were
saying cuz see like overom overom that's
not over promis we got you for the first
time so relax Final Fantasy 16 adct the
DLC um Echoes are the Fallen how we
feeling about that you saw that huh the
Final Fantasy 16 DLC he said huh
oh no no I'm saying huh like I I don't
know I don't even know what you're I
can't hear you I'm muted or something no
like you're talking Final Fantasy 16 I
can't hear you like I don't care I don't
care oh oh you can't hear me cuz you're
like all right you be messy got you got
the finals was last launched that day
and then Monster Hunter Wilds they had
the final spot now sof yeah OD we didn't
talk about that kima's joint where you
at with that then we can wrap up I gotta
ask dip Down's uh patreon question on G
the the idea that it could be some sort
of spiritual successor in the cloud to
um to PT is exciting for me because PT I
I didn't made the dumb decision of
trading in my PlayStation 4 that had PT
installed on it
I bread for that yeah so um so yeah I
traded it in and I forgot that it was on
there um that to this day is probably
one of the scariest things in yeah that
thing is interactivity is Bonkers uh
that things like that you know again
kajima be up his own butt some a lot of
the time but there's certain things that
he does super well that he thinks about
things in a different way than other
people does do um so I I I I'm excited
for this being a horror thing and this
idea of bringing in you know horror
directors like a Jordan Peele and maybe
other you know sort of Masters of of
horror and kind of having it be this
whatever interconnected cloud-based
thing um I just and I and I recognize
that it's a moment for Xbox to have
coima this is a Xbox game I'm out there
you know that that I enjoyed that aspect
of it but the fact that he came out and
you were out there 10 minutes and didn't
show you didn't show anything really um
he show faces yeah he show faces and and
you know this long- winded sort of
literal conversation up on stage about
an interview with coima on stage during
the game awards no no no music wrap up
to speed it up yeah was better wrap it
up he put you in that game yeah it was
very very weird I didn't like that
energy it was no need for that you could
have just that wasn't weird for them too
it was not weird it was not weird for KY
but then it was a weird thing in
generally cuz key just ke look like he
was about to cry when the man it wased
that's his homeboy out xox I feel you I
feel you but that's you know that energy
when like you you really in love with
somebody and you think everyone else is
and that's not
let me let me ask you this question how
come the same rhetoric ain't around this
title around which title o what you mean
is it going to be on Playstation oh cuz
they came out and said it they said that
he said it he said Xbox but but part for
the course is you know Xbox is
wishy-washy know kajima knows with his
butter is Brad and he needs to get our
money overhead ain't that what they say
yeah this is a teaching moment General
King you got to teach the masses the
troops about you know how to be how to
be
confident that's right this is it but
yeah I don't know what what what kind of
game this is going to be what kind of
experience this is going to be I know
this is big for Xbox I hope it it turns
out to be cool because I know a lot of
people were I have I played five hours
of death stranding and one day I will go
back and try to really give it the time
to see if whatever it comes on Xbox it's
PC you play right
now so I one day I'll sit down with that
game when I have time but um I gave it
five hours initially and it it didn't
hit for me um so again I understand the
importance I just don't think that it
required that much time on stage when
you're cutting people off that won
awards that really yeah Xbox did I I
Xbox certainly did Jeff certainly did we
paid for a large amount of time to be
SED out like that
right there we paid for key we paid for
the door we PA green light we PA for all
that we paid for the fake tar for the
crying kid in the I'm going keep it a
buck I thought the last person to come
through the door was going to be filled
I through the door yeah no I thought he
was coming out flarent though messy so
yeah no I feel yeah I mean can't get any
thoughts on an OD other than yeah the
fact that the PlayStation uh fan base is
OD d off for
copium yo you see I did right there you
see what I did right there this title is
going to be the Bane like how you had
her and y'all really couldn't do nothing
with her so she had to go to the
opposition and and when he's up there he
said he said this is can only be
possible this why his hands like that
his hands was
together this can only be possible
through the Microsoft infrastructure and
Cloud remember when y said CL was
F remember when y said Cloud was fake
well kajima knows it's
real and guess what's guess what's fake
you guys are cuz he left y'all and y'all
don't get OD so you know you know what
Jordan pill knows that PlayStation don't
get
OD yo when they was doing the face you
know at the end that last face where the
girl said that face right there that
face that was the PlayStation fan base
screaming when kajima came out that door
and he was like Xbox and he
said that was you it cut your mic off
bro too much for all of you dudes I am
so happy that's the horror game it's
it's not coming to their platform this
is how the game starts you see a
PlayStation in the room the guy comes
inside you see a Xbox and he walks over
with OD and he puts it inside the Xbox
and game over PlayStation cries and dies
sh your M you are way too messy you are
way too messy today anyway thought it
was cool last last last day of year I
know you get all your messers out look
um Power move by Xbox I this to me this
is a bigger picture thing of yes this is
they know I got hey I Gotta Give King
this King says something that's very
prophetic I'm G give him flowers thank
you last
year Phil had to go to that show
CMA block fresh off a Redfield they MD
his face they they they they did him you
know kind of dirty mhm King said Mark of
a Warriors to still show up and go there
anyway and he going to absorb this this
is what king said and he's going to use
this he's never going to have that
situation never going to happen again
under his rent he going to use this for
motivation so we laughed we like okay
kinging full of
it I personally feel that cuz to me
let's be real we didn't even talk about
hellblade right hellblade didn't even
need to be there I'm sitting there like
yo you don't even need to be there cuz
we
know word y y'all think it ain't no
combat you don't think this is photo
realistic you don't think this is what
we do come out there not only did they
come out there off why they had a live B
with the full outfits every body in
there I said oh this they going to show
something you don't bring a live if
you're not there then they come outting
B there bro there was times when I had
to look at that reveal and I'm like yo
that looks so photo realistic it looks
like a movie there's a part where
she yeah it was it was it was outside it
was outside the thing for me with the
combat is some enemy had a flamethrower
thing
yeah she did the came through with the
combat then the visceral through the
skull chopping the leg they were like oh
you don't think so we're going to show
you and by the way yeah we I would have
loved the date we know
2024 but man did that show out then you
come through with OD exclusive kajima
regardless of how I feel about my
feelings with him I will say
he will the way of his quirky nature he
will find a way to uniquely use cloud in
a video game better or uniquely than
anyone else I I firmly believe that cuz
just he's just so out of the box right
and then I've played death Strand and
now and I know like he he's been
flirting if you notice the strands and
the connectivity between the world and
everybody he's flirting with Concepts so
he's probably got an idea shout out to
Jordan Peele who said oh no this is a
video game
trust me and the other thing you can say
what you want about Kim I clown him all
the time but when it comes to graphical
Fidelity when it comes to things looking
amazing since every day he's put put out
from the jump from the Metal Gear Solid
to one when we saw the boat he has
pushed Graphics forward we can never
take that away from K remember we played
that demo we play we dealt with what was
it Z of the Enders or what some game we
didn't care about cuz we wanted the demo
so I'm like all right so now you with
the hellblade you come with the OD Xbox
then you come with the Cog shut up C
like you going to get the combat you
been talking crazy you going to get the
kaj exclusiv you been talking crazy and
we G to smack you said you ain't goingon
to get no superhero game and potential
just one we G to smack you in the head
too I said all right Xbox yeah y'all got
that y got this was a dominant
performance by Xbox This was oh we have
so much content we can give Jeff and
there's more stuff you you don't even
know about we know there's a wuang game
coming out y wasn't even there it wasn't
even there we know gar we know there's
more stuff so what it shows me is that
remember the thing I always said I said
they had a fantastic
2024 feels like the Avalanche year where
you're going to have to space out
content we didn't even talk about
ABK and and the infusion of how they
going to have to do that right so it's
to the point to King we don't got game
this is this is a
celebration of what's about to happen
now just about the execution and the
games need to be good of course right so
but man they on fire right now and this
this was a dominant statement after last
year and I have to salute the teams
because they were they were popping off
man they and and they they laran fumbled
the bag for another moment to say that
balest gate the game of the year is on
our platform right now go get that go
ahead K that that was another one but
you know what I noticed too what they
show Todd Howard yes with the movie with
the Fallout and the they got the movie
they going all over the place go ahead
but no it was um Todd didn't look happy
you think
so okay he didn't okay and and Microsoft
as U um as a solidarity to
Todd put up accolades for Starfield oh I
saw that I I thought that was a shot
they ran yeah it was I thought that was
they ran um a promo yes I saw that
Starfield mm and that was that was a tip
of the hat to Todd yeah respect to him
because he's there and he's soaking it
up knowing that his game should be up
there and some people say dunk whatever
it doesn't matter that's fine the same
way
Phil felt that that'll never happen
again right Todd is made from that same
ilk okay and I honestly believe when
that Skyrim remake comes out and these
games Oblivion remakes comes out and
these games come out they're going for
the juggler you're not going to deny him
game of the year but here's the funny
thing I I feel you but the thing they
can't no one can't deny is the
commercial success of Starfield that's
true no one can that moved the needle
you can say whatever you want it won MPD
it had to get what you say 12 million
players you can say whatever you want
about steam it's a whole pie of
Engagement so that's thing but I only
say this to say let's go don't you think
that and I care about how my peers view
me of course of course of course and and
I guess he's looking at these guys as
form of PE yall in the same industry and
for certain things not to be done and
you feel like it's an Xbox tax you're
going to feel away no you're going to
feel away and the teams are going to
feel away because we know they want the
commercial thing but at the end of the
day even though it didn't get the
critical Acclaim that they were hoping
for right the the the reality is we know
what Bethesda games Modern community and
and just the expansion the long tail of
is so we have not seen the end of it
they in my opinion the same way cyberp
punk I had this argument with MADD like
cyberp Punk he's like and what you go
these games afforded to come out in you
know broken state or one with a you know
kickstar or whatever let's see what
happens let's see what happens if if
this is a failure that some a small
vocal minority is saying that it is is
is not it's what it is is certain people
that it bothers them that it is a
commercial success and they want it to
be a failure but we I've already talked
to everyone internally in there it is
exceeded surpass exceeded every internal
metric they even hoped for so don't let
people fool you into thinking cuz they
don't like Starfield that it is some
flop oh no oh no that's not the case so
that I feel what you're saying they're
going to go there they're going to do
what they got to do but that's it look
game awards I just I have to get this
out it was dope it was dope um soft and
adct I got it cuz this is something for
all of us with Di down I got to get this
one but I'll wait until they'll both
come in they probably doing a little
bathro break but I'll talk to you last
thing um Monster Hunter Wilds I thought
that was interesting in the last spot I
didn't think that that earned the last
spot but I understand why last St C call
and and if anybody seeing anything in
there having a problem with whatever
Jeff is doing a lot of that stuff cost
money security cost money the renting of
this uh this the place cost money the
the lighting every all that stuff cost
money this was his best production yeah
like I and I thought he brought
everything together okay now everybody
can say the Cadence is a little bit off
when it comes to um him giving awards to
people we've that has been a huge
criticism for him every year right well
not really every year the first couple
of years it was he was really good at it
and then he regressed as the the mark
and dollar came in right and you don't
want it to go all the over three hours
because he gets he has to pay for the
space right so
I honestly think that he's going to
figure out a way and I'm pretty sure he
has his team on it to give these guys
their moments right he got to fix that
he has to fix he has to fix it because
when everybody's saying that it's the
marketing show and it's not the award
show correct and awards are secondary to
everything else that's a problem so I I
think he saw this he's going to
internalize it he's going to fix it
because last year
uh this year was better than last year
and I think next year will be better
than this year and that's that's a good
thing for him yeah no I agree I think we
we just got to get back to what we here
for the game ons and and to celebrate
these creators shout out to fun specul
shout out to MAV yeah presenters should
not get more time than winners that that
I and I don't want shotgun blast this is
the game that won this boom boom boom me
and AD couldn't even get to write down
and see if Sol won what cuz he was going
through so fast and we're just like yo
what is going on too much off screen
again we get it I like the oscar style
presentation and reverence and the
production and I I don't mind Hollywood
being a part of it but my thing is don't
forget why you're here the reason this
is exist is to to celebrate our heroes
that made these game and don't wrap it
up beat them on the stage when you
letting the Muppets Rock when you
letting kajima Rock it's really it was
really Matthew MCC and um this that
other guy that played Captain America
that's
black Captain America and and
simu broke a leg and all that and I know
like a lot of these guys are game I
don't want to be disrespectful but is
the thing that people have a problem is
that King it's like remember we for all
of us are from that era when it was not
cool to be a gamer why are you gaming
this is not this is not going to go
anywhere we are now bigger than them we
are it's like we're appeasing them like
you want to be a cool kid and I get it
but we're the bigger entity now we our
revenue and entertainment and our spot
is where we are now so just remember
just give it back to the people give it
back to the devs who actually say they
have jelly well adding back I need I
need him back for this um this dip down
cuz we damn still ain't back we going to
do the other um we did spot or something
like that we did we did all the spots we
did we did all the spot we did all the
no don't actually we have we have some
more Super chats and then we have more
spot all right so let's do the super
chats and then try to get adct some time
for that okay hold on a second yeah cuz
almost 500 yeah we a even going first
time okay this is ridiculous y can drop
my
topic I'm just G to say what I'm going
say and that's get your balls all right
all right uh we got bean dip nip slip
$20 Super Chat shout out to the king and
them pause cast that make me laugh and I
look forward to Sunday every week can't
wait to catch it live but I always catch
up when I have time Merry Christmas and
have a happy New Year you as well thank
little blessing happy holidays then we
have Skywalker the Jedi $2 chat any of
the Lords know who has ready to rumble
IP no that's Midway if I'm correct
Midway is a rap so I don't know I mean
it could it's kind of been limbo unless
they just mid somebody whoever whoever
is messing with Midway and has that sort
you can liter make that game with other
characters yeah you can 100% cuz none of
these characters are really apart from
like Michael Buffer being in there it's
that's all made up characters yeah so
let me see for is a legend $2 Super Chat
hellblade looks good god tier No Cap
here day one yes it does yeah d w and
Game Pass yeah I was a little I'll be
honest though the combat looked great
visceral you know you know we say
visceral you know the floody it just
kind of looked like it was kind of the
same same from the first hellblade oh
okay okay I got you oh you wasn't really
that impressed in terms of like the
sword obviously the time period means
that the swords are heavy you're not
going to have have you know back and
forth parrying and crazy stuff like that
it's going to be heavy swings and stuff
like that but I don't know it just felt
like it was you didn't see much enough
you want to see even more of a Devi uh
deviation sh from okay that's fair like
show us what the actual moment to moment
game play is and it still wasn't that oh
no I get you you this is where I'll give
you that with only thing I was annoyed
is just when they started give you the
the combat they switched to cinematic
and something El like they kept going
all over the place so to me that's how I
internalize it yeah it's like shut up
Cog we got it but we're getting close to
release we probably going to do a direct
with some point really give us what like
the Starfield level of complete
immersion where we have no doubt what
hellblade is the say we do yeah yeah I
think a director is coming yeah but that
game looks aers um put the crest in the
chat for Lord bronze Royal boil 78
that's the homie that's the homie right
there
salute put the CR in the chat for Lord
silver wavy kosher shout out to you
appreciate you man then we have Alvin $5
Super Chat most of the blade talk isn't
about exclusivity movie Twitter accounts
are getting tens of thousands of likes
announcing it the people are hype yeah
we we are in an echo chamber that is for
sure then we have D DCd DCd DCd $20 $2
Super Chat Microsoft is like Sideshow
Bob stepping on
rakes sometimes yeah yes I don't know
what rate they stood stepped on then we
have sjsu Sage $ five Super Chat
Microsoft didn't need blade they're
simply putting the boot on the neck by
flexing what their game development Army
is cooking about sending a message yes
they do nah you can't play bro you say
you don't need it you can't play I went
at it I'm just no soup for you no suit
for you you stay stand on your Square
stay on business don't
play Sage I love you I'm messing with
you I'm messing with you bro I'll be a p
Petty Danny passion official $5 Super
Chat blade is the conversation of the
town and I love it let's not forget that
Starfield went through the same
situation for months and Starfield was a
w we have Sage once again $5 Super Chat
at 100% matters that blade is exclusive
even Day One on Game Pass nothing grows
Game Pass more than exclusives Starfield
on Microsoft Store outperforms
steam yeah you know some people try to
act like didn't win MPD and all of a
sudden it's some we gonna move on we
gonna move on there we got the everborn
Saga $5 Super Chat in their latest
financial report Sega confirmed that
Sonic has been downloaded SLP purchased
over 1.66 billion with a B times where
did most of that come from I'm assuming
that was you ever who bought that shout
out to everyone flexing the numbers
flexing the numbers where did he get
these numbers from shout out to everyone
letting people know Sonic I kind of do
not believe I think that plumber got you
crazy continue then we have fantis
Archer $ five Super Chat in my mind
isn't some of the stigma against
Microsoft is that folks might think that
Bill Gates still runs it and can't see
Microsoft trying to change their
narratives who knows what people think
that's good yeah the sound like that
Steve bomber guy
you never know then we got Mich skew Jr
$5 Super Chat King is right I want only
only fans to feel like the Cowboys fan
on every year at uh uh I want them to
feel like Cowboys fans every year they
sniff the playoffs and then get sniped
in the Wild
Card messy I'm a Cowboy fan this weekend
then go Cowboys beat them eag I need
that first place seed continue no first
place I'm not going to say seed moving
on there we go stupid we going to move
on hear there we have the rubber knob
with the $10 Super Chat morning Lords on
a different note I have been loyal I
have been a loyal fan for some time now
but of late there have been some shady
actions your on your show and this needs
to be brought to the realm's attention
what do we do R once again $10 Super
Chat King I love you brother but I need
to pull I need to pull up this constant
blasphemy of my man's name has to
stop I know what he's talking about man
who's Blas I don't know I let's see if
Hees what king said I know I don't know
he's BL Jim Ryan I don't
know me it's me it's me okay he doesn't
like that me and King disagrees and that
that that's my side of the story okay
that's your side King oh hold on oh no I
it's coming up I see it I see it right
now it's me no it's me you don't have to
read it let's read it we have uh gamer
by choice $2 Super Chat Microsoft cannot
finish Kong with the feds looking with
the no Cuda gr why the F do that why the
F the best part of killing somebody off
pause is let them do it to themselves we
G get FBI us and and you don't you're
not even there you're not even in in in
the in in the country you gone and they
passed away and you just like that's a
shame me me and them was just talking
the other day we were good friends oh
well
mess continue then we have the rubber no
once again $5 Super Chat Kong is going
to whoop that overgrown geek geckos
behind so bad he'll be forced to take an
ice bath and come out of the closet you
just died the last movie you died the
last movie we had to resuscitate you do
you know who you are you was on the ship
deck like God turn they said turn off
the engines everybody turn off C and
hide that's a fact that's the only way
we going to save cuz this this lizard's
crazy and Godzilla looked at y'all and
smirked and said I thought y'all turn
that
off get out of here manov it on let's
put the crest in the chat for Lord
bronze Juan shout out to
Juan thank you thank you sir thank you
bless you there we got gamer by choice
$2 super chat if if ring is Major bling
don't wear it everywhere if the ring is
Major bling don't wear it everywhere I
think barri yeah I
know there we got Dany passion official
$2 Super Chat blade announcement is
playing the Xbox tax yo crazy could be
could be then we have Arthur Harris $5
Super Chat I think it's a simple
explanation the game is just under the
Bethesda brand those games probably
won't have an Xbox game Studio splash
screen I don't know does I
mean does redall have classic P the
first topic four hours long yeah there
we go what it's two topics it was two
topics technically that's what we excuse
then we have hold on I gota jump the
bougie coin $5 Super Chat Philly Maximus
be like Alexa play Forever straightened
I don't know what that means can't wait
to watch my man play blade Xbox gamer
girlfriends out here cooking and holding
the line shout out to the bougie coin
and we got [__] J $2 super CH Bill
Spencer stand on business right then we
have Mike Untitled $5 Super Chat so it's
Xbox's fault that podcast and social
media can't stop talking about the
platform how about people choose to talk
about the game not the platform it's
it's Xbox F definitely how they handle
messaging on their
platform that is on them that is for
sure then we have god the blessed one
$10 Super Chat
I got you King dudes want a console war
more than they want to win the war and
Kong how it's done don't matter to me
advance the line that
part then we got gamer by choice $2
Super Chat blade could introduce Mighty
Avengers
game yeah that's that's highly possible
but I think they're going to go to
midnight Suns I think you get a doctor
strange game um blade is in the ult so
they're going to go to darker they could
go really dark with blad early on blades
was really
dark then we got 876 Patriot $5 Super
Chat blade first appeared in the Tomb of
Dracula number 10 blade got his ability
to be a day Walker when morbius bit him
so Mobius or morbius is it mobus or
morbius that's not true but
okay and we have yeah that's a redon
that's not true okay then we have Don
Sega theotaku $5 Super Chat double
dragging his eye but River City Ransom
on NES bodies it easily and is to this
day still one of the best beat him UPS
of all time Ransom is great it's great
but uh you may be talking about that
whack Double Dragon Dragon one player
that had cuz your sister wasn't powerful
enough to do two plays like the I never
got a chance to tell that
story my my cousin had the Master System
and he's down the hallway and um no my
god brother my God brother's down the
hallway and he has the Master System he
has Double Dragon I get Double Dragon
for the
NES he's playing with his brother
Leon and said and this is this was this
is when the stab hurt what he said who's
playing with you
y yo this this is when console war was
happening in your face in your face I
just had to hold that L but I was like I
was look a little bit better
though the saying Nintendo was was hard
body karate it was it was close to RK
perfect
too such a good P loved it oh my God U
then we got Raheem Linkhorn $5 I feel
like it's full government in
there I love to hear fellow brothers
from NY doing good I'm from Harlem keep
up the good work NY stand up Harlem rise
we don't want to follow with them guys
no doubt right salute brother New York
in a building thank you and West
Virginia
there we got smoovie movie $2 Super Chat
people expected the Oscars at at the VZ
is I mean I think that's what Jeff wants
it to be I don't know people I think
that's exactly what we got yeah that's
what Jeff really wants it to be then we
got JD gamer $5 Super Chat the three PS
of copium pathetic Port begging Pony
stay oh my God stay in your lane you get
nothing no pork no soup no ice cream no
games for you five
biscuits objective is always always J
objective gamer love you there we have
Homeless
Bird Lord silver love you Homeless Bird
health and happiness to the Lords and
the realm thank you for making a busy
and difficult year a little brighter
happy holidays to all that's what we
could
do hit you with a health his wealth too
brother
salute then we got JD gabber $2 Super
Chat SE it's either Sega or Sega one of
those two but or both it could be both
then we got the rubber knob $5 Super
Chat Kong was sedated and chained up
King Kong will
rise he was sedated and chained up
because he's a danger to
himself y I'm telling you I can do this
for days I can do this all day I'm
Captain America this I can do all messy
then we got sagging nut sack with the 5B
super
all these exclusivity talks about blade
let's be honest if this was a Sony if
this was Sony wouldn't be talking about
it we all know it will be exclusive as
correct Sun T to be on Front Street with
that I I I I'm not answering that
anymore clearly you guys have your own
personal opinion on it it's like look
the reason we wouldn't have any thought
process if it was Sony is because Sony
wouldn't have this messaging in the
first place oh shots moving on that's
true then we got JD gamer once again5
another two hours I ain't got nothing to
say this Sega kid had a Sega s that's
right baby I want my paner Dragon Saga
remake let's go and the sequel let's go
I want a real final I want a real
Fantasy Star game let's go and I want a
Shining Force 3 REM oh let's go this is
Sega and it might be on Apple watch him
out might have to go get a damn Ione
there we have we have Don Sega the
otaku Double Dragon had no physics no
picking people up and throwing them no
RPG elements no learning new moves no
shops no open world whack he he those
Dragon was a arade
sensation like bro that moved the needle
and two player beat them up where do you
think River City rans love where they
got it from like they had to you had to
bite the style and then evolve on it
then improve upon I mean streets raage
kicks Double Dragon in the mouth yeah
but you know but it learned from it like
Double Dragon one of the OG's bro salute
got to got to respect the Legends out
there ah we are caught up all right now
this was the dip down games and Anime
okay let's do that Rel related patreon
the Eternal emu has arrived on Earth he
is upset that he missed the game awards
it's up to you to agree on the three
best moments of the game awards so the
Eternal evu can know what's really good
in gaming otherwise kog will be turned
into a Lego character entrapped in
fortnite with no Halo or any crazy ninja
games rise of the man in kog or whatever
y you messing so we have to agree that's
why I need the adct back three I feel
like we just moment what was what what
what were the three best moments for us
to see if we can agree on three best
moments in the game awards hey hey hey
guys Kings s let's just disagree so he's
stuck in
in that's evil I feel like that's a
win-win let's start with since you are
the most
disagreeable let's start with you
addict what are the three
moments blade
yes uh the fact that there's a Mana game
coming to Xbox that's a pretty big
moment
okay and I would say the super massive
game we're going to die we going to die
so super master which one they did oh
the um the horror joint with the joint s
what are your
three
blade so we got one Sega okay SEGA All
Right blade
Sega that last
one for me for for biggest moment
[Music]
damn it one bad mother I'm with you
it who oh damn it this last one is
killing me I know cuz it's
personal let me see H let's give it
to just scrolling okay you know what
what what black myth really
just game is real yeah all right so we
only have one so far that all of us
agree with
King three biggest moments of the game
awards for you I'm sorry you're about to
be trapped but um oh man what you doing
I'm gonna go with uh Sega I'm going to
go with um kajima oh you going with
O
and see I knew about blade oh you ain't
going put blade in there for all of us I
I yeah I knew about blade you rebellious
I'm not I'm not being rebellious about
but I know about blade my question was
was uh hellblade 2 The Show gameplay so
and I got to say hellblade 2 was
probably the most incredible looking
game yeah next to that and I would say
Wukong were the best looking games in
the show right so I I gotta go with um
hellblade and
Sega so all right
damn yeah all right so we all in
agreement with blade minus minus King
and we mostly in with Sega minus well I
mean save you I will go with blade and
drop OD okay cool cool um adct I don't
think a ain't picking Sega no way no how
well nothing that means nothing to him
he does nothing for
him we're dead I would I would have
conceited with addict on Mana just to
keep me out of the damn fortnite but I'm
trapped in there I'm trapped cuz for me
yeah it's it's it's
blade it's oh Sega number one blade
oh man and it's probably time between h
no I'm actually say something hell blade
was fire though come
on if any of y'all would have said
Exodus I would have conceded but then
I'll put hell blade so I'm closer to
King than anybody but we are I am
trapped we dead or whatever um there was
too many good moments too many good
moments dip down I I yeah so I'm trapped
in fortnite forever it is what it is I
noce dip down you trying to tear us up
from within yeah yeah he tried to create
separation between the 12
get the picking so that's it fortnite it
is so uh we are done um s this is you
yeah well actually we got let's let's
pay this last bill pay one bill one bill
one bill we'll pay this last bill and
we yeah we'll move on all right so yeah
definitely mute the mics mute the mics
mute the
mics all
right this episode of The Iron Lords
podcast is brought to you by
hellofresh what is hellofresh with
hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hello fresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable that's
why it's America's number one meal kit
say hello to a Stressless holiday season
with the help of hellofresh skip the
grocery store and save time with easy
Tasty Recipes delivered to your door it
is the season for giving and Gathering
and with hellofresh it can also be the
season of Sav saving actually save money
this month with fresh recipes delivered
cheaper than takeout and with
pre-portioned ingredients you never
waste money on excess food after a full
day of work there's still so much to do
some days it feels like eating a
wholesome dinner is next to Impossible
but with hellofresh you can turn busy
week nights into memorable meal times
with delicious practical options
designed to save you time like their
15minute meals spend your time this
month shopping for gifts and sipping
cocoa not stuck in the checkout line
sign up for hellofresh and get
everything you need to whip up a fresh
tasty meal delivered to your door just
choose your recipes select the delivery
date and relax knowing dinner is on the
way make hosting this holiday a joy
rather than a hassle with help with the
help of hellofresh Market from
crowd-pleasing charer boards to photow
worthy desserts it's easy to add these
party Pleasers to your weekly order
saving you so much time did you know
know hellofresh does more than just
dinners from easy breakfast to start
your morning off right to 10minute
lunches or satisfying snacks both adults
and kids will love hellofresh has tasty
choices for every meal time occasion and
the best part no grocery trip is
required hellofresh has over 45 recipes
and more than 100 seasonal add-on items
to choose from every week so it's easier
than ever to find something everyone
will
enjoy at the end of the day I'm going to
tell you this for me when it comes to my
use of hellofresh I usually am the type
of guy where I come in it's 11 o'clock
at night and don't have time to cook now
the good thing about it being the end of
the year is that I probably have some
time off so what I can do is stay home
and cook with my beautiful wife and
actually make healthy meals in between
all of the non-healthy stuff that us
Puerto Ricans like to eat during the
holiday
all of that penil the pasteles the coito
all of that's going down but in between
then we are cooking some amazing
hellofresh dinners some of our favorites
are the Hardy steak and potatoes with
balsamic cranberry pan sauce the
mozzarella crusted chicken with
blistered tomatoes and potato wedges um
the chicken in Greek salad lettuce wraps
to with f feta cheese so for us the end
of the year is cool because we get to
spend time with each other and actually
share time in the kitchen and there's no
better way to do that than with
hellofresh because again we don't have
to go buy all of these crazy ingredients
that we end up losing half of them in
the fridge if we don't use so the great
thing about hellofresh is that the
portions are just what you need for for
two to three people and it it's great
because for us it's a unifier in my
household so that is definitely when it
comes to to to hellofresh and and what
it brings to the table for my family
it's I can't really match it I can't
really match it because apart from the
delicious food it's just brings us
together in a way that you know nine
times out of 10 during three quarters of
the Year we're not able to do so this is
an amazing time for me so with that said
go to hellofresh.com iron Lords free and
use code iron Lords free for free
breakfast for life that is one breakfast
item per box while subscription while
while your subscription is active so
that's free breakfast for life at
hellofresh.com
ironlord free with code iron Lords free
you can get all of this with hellofresh
America's number one meal
kit Salo salute yeah man got me hungry
man I'm on the site right now checking
things out got the meat the veggies oh
my God free breakfast for free breakfast
for life you know some people free
breakfast so you order that and you get
at least one breakfast meal per well
yeah it's one per day with each
subscription um okay they got they got
pescatarian
preferences they got all right quick and
easy we got veggie all right all right
I'm going tell you guys we we use
everything that we talk about here we
use and for me like I said I never have
time for anything so the holidays come
around I have a little bit of time off
wifey has a little bit of time off and
that way we like we never spend time in
the kitchen together this we can do and
it's it's fun most of the time she wants
to kick me out of the kitchen cuz I I
like to enjoy and like and she's like
you know she's so caught up but being
quick and finishing things and whatever
this is a time we can both sort of
settle down a little bit and just enjoy
our time in the kitchen cuz I like to
cook I learned you know my mom taught me
to cook very young or whatever I've been
out of the house since I was 14 years
old essentially so it's like I like
cooking so hell fresh simplifies that
and another thing that it helps with
immensely is that you're not wasting
food sometimes you buy go to the grocery
store Supermarket you buy excess right
now it's only two of us so we always
find that something thing like we cook
something and we'll eat what we're going
to eat that day forget about it and it
gets lost at the back of the fridge and
by the time you realize it's it's you
got to get rid of it so no doubt this is
good you just eat the whole thing and
you're good to go and you go on to the
next meal free breakfast for Life y'all
get on that use iron Lords freeh
hellofresh.com we already rocking any
other super chats then we get into this
topic now let me see if any super chats
jumped in yeah we got to oh my God
speculation say send me that bacon you
ridiculous B you hilarious salute to B
be a messy okay we
have JD gamer member for 44 months Lord
bronze flexing on you pathetic Port
begging ponies out here begging Phil for
game ports you get nothing don't look
for anything I might toss you a table
scrap oh my
God capitals in the streets yes then we
got Simple Jack $10 Super Chat 10 for
hat thought but do y'all think dark Phil
uh is using blade as leverage at the
negotiating table with Marvel get Spidey
on Xbox kind of how they sweet talked
MLB to force Kong's hand they they did
not sweet talk
MLB MLB came to Sony was like listen
y'all we need this game to be on
multiple platforms you can you can
choose to do it or not to get down stay
down lay down stay down lay down and and
Sony lay down stay down yeah lay down
lay down and Sony made the choice to to
lay to lay
down welcome to Game Pass ml be the show
um so it this it's a different situation
yeah that was ganga yeah that's that's a
gangsta move a Ganga move gang Mo not
the same situation but what else you got
we'll see JD gaming was again $5 Super
Chat pathetic Port begging ponies you're
down bad Kong is on his last legs you
can't save Kong Sega I need hold on I
need The House of the Dead with light
gun damn okay you want to go all the way
back there why not busing his console
Warrior guns in the streets he is not
playing no Kings out here wow we outside
then we have neopet God shout $10 Super
Chat shout out to Cog following on your
health is wealth messages and took care
of mine ended up finding early cancer
but was able to get it removed thanks
for positivity and your reach is more
than you think absolutely wow brother
man that's why bro is so humbling and at
the same time I'm glad you are taking
care of what you need to take care of
cuz as men I love that you said with the
early detection right finding out yo
it's 40 somethings also it's time to
colonoscopies you know what time it is
stop playing because we got to find out
we wait too long check that butt check
that butt all right you a doing the must
doing the most doing the most make sure
you check back there not check it back
then Che anything get your blood work
done gentlemen that's another thing
blood work is very key key to find out
what's going on your body and again stay
fit we're staying in front of these
screens all day like we are right now
podcast after all this get up get out on
so I don't damage my eyes facts all it's
about health is wealth y'all support
health is wealth t-shirts is out there
you're going to see me rocking get with
the movement y'all I want you we need to
be around you see all these games coming
we got to be around we need to be alive
for this we need to be alive for this
for real
salute y wor about Wolverine but eating
Cheetos so we got uh Riser $10 Super
Chat originally in Blade uh vampire
number vampire Hunter number one it was
uh believed that the bite that happened
in Peter Parker it was believed that it
was the same bite that happened in Peter
Parker um Spider-Man number eight
mutated him but Marvel later on changed
it to him getting powers from Deacon
Frost yeah interesting so I guess they
changed it a couple of times okay he's
he's he's one of the the most changed Up
characters characters yeah he mm
good that's it we are caught up all
right s this is I'm sorry let me mute
for a moment just let my wife know
something real quick I'll set you up
I'll set you up so um yeah this is s
topic I set a up why he takes care
business um GTA 6 dropped this y'all
dropped this week man
absolutely insane trailer right that
broke the internet the views I can't
even keep up with at this point as far
as 18 million views that's crazy on
YouTube Channel um biggest YouTube debut
ever you know 93 million views over its
first 24 hours oh man over 123 at press
time insane a lot of commentary here and
uh yeah I mean you know where can we
stop besides the the the the breaking of
every record Shadow you know we got to
talk about the game itself and this is I
believe s's beloved rock star so you're
back um your thoughts this is your topic
where you at with it yeah man I mean GTA
5 launched in 2012 wow the tail end of
the Xbox 360 PS3 generation the start of
the the wiii U generation if you want to
call it that the Generation Um that's
how far back this game goes
and the fact that you know I've always
felt that things nobody one UPS Rockstar
Rockstar nobody can nobody put puts in
the time the resources to make a game
and have them talk about it release it
when they think it's ready and there
there's no other metric other than when
it's ready you'll get it yep and however
long it takes for that game to be ready
if this game comes out in
2025 we are looking at a game that is 13
years in the
Mak that's insane like
um I I was super impressed the thing
about Rockstar also is that when you
have these these trailers and they break
them down afterwards you realize oh this
is not they're not showing you the
vertical slice they're not showing you
what the you know what they hope the
game will be it's showing you the game
they showing you the game whether it be
in cinematics which are usually in the
real-time engine which is the rage
engine right at engine that they created
and have been refining over years and
multiple games including the the Red
Dead franchise
um when you look at this game there's
pretty much nothing that I've seen to
this point since GTA 5 compares to what
they're looking to do with GTA 6 and
going back to Vice City um or not VI
City we're going back to the to
essentially Florida right with the state
of leonida is what they're calling
Florida leonida and obviously Vice City
will be included within the state of
Leonid um the level of detail that I saw
in this trailer is just mindboggling to
me really when you think about you know
these consoles are powerful but when you
think about what they're trying to do
here in terms of what I think they're
trying to do is terms of
density right yeah density and scale
they're doing both I feel um when you
you know look at the flamingos flying
out and you see like a thousand
flamingos and and then in Red Dead you
saw like you know whatever 50 of them
whatever the case may be you see the
leaps in technology you see what they're
trying to do um and again it's one of
those things where you can't help but
you know be Gob smacked because you know
that's the game right you know that
they're not trying to fool you you know
that this is this is the game um so
again I was super impressed I was you
know again I was sad for the team that
they didn't have their moment the way
they should have had it yeah but at the
end of the day the end result is still
the same the internet went crazy for it
the world went crazy for it um and guys
you know we next year well not next year
the year after next yeah we will have at
some point people breathe a s of relief
that day yeah exactly
2024 because this is a game that
everybody gets out of the way of you you
just don't you don't play with this you
don't play with GTA um what did you guys
think cuz again I'm I'm a big I'm a
Rockstar fan Red Dead you say that [__]
number one Studio who who would be your
top three Studios man never asked you I
got it it's
Rockstar
Arcane and I love baseball so it's got
to be Sony San
dieg yeah but like um yeah Rockstar
really is again because I there's no I
remember playing the original GTA's the
top down W top down wow PlayStation one
right cuz again PlayStation one you guys
know everything under the sun came out
in that game there was so many wacky
Porky games and you see this you're like
oh wow they really trying to do this
this this murder simulation or whatever
and you know obviously it's it's it's
it's top down it's cartoonish but you
see what they're getting at and then you
make the jump to the PlayStation 2 and
three when three came out I was like oh
they just they realizing the the same
vision in 3D um and they got it right
and I remember playing this and I like
is this really as good as I think it is
and again you go back to it now and it's
a time and it doesn't hold up as well
but the essence of what they were trying
to do and how important that game that
that game is to the history of game you
cannot deny that so um yeah they really
to me Rockstar signifies just that
they're rock stars and they really they
G their their goal and their aim every
time they come out is to raise the bar
in a way that no one else can touch
people can look up at it be like wow
this is amazing how you know what what
can we glean from this to add to our
open world but no one's going to have
the budget no one is going to put the
time the effort um to really do the
things that Rockstar does in their game
so again it's that's why every time a
rockstar game releases it's a moment
right it it really is a special moment
and at this rate they don't release a
whole lot of games so you know you get
one every decade like you know it's
funny because in the I don't know if you
guys noticed that in the the comments
section of the of the the video up on
Rockstar site there were people
literally said talk about shout out to
the homies that didn't make it to the to
to the trailer the homies that you know
here 10 years ago yeah it was one of
those things where they're paying homage
to their friends that weren't here to
witness the
GTA because it's a decade in the
making it's kind of Bonkers that this is
uh but this is what they do I mean this
and this is this is the core game we're
talking about yes we're not even talking
about GTA all online is a whole another
thing we don't know how they're going to
handle that are they is this GTA online
going to be attached to this or is this
the single player game and we'll get GTA
online later right and just attaching it
to to present GTA
onl because they they upgraded right
they upgraded GTA online to to be more
inline I guess they up the upgrade was
technically on the Xbox One PS4
generation the upgrade and that's what
they've been using moving forward now if
I'm not mistaken maybe I'm wrong about
that I don't play GTA online
um so maybe that is the case and they
add to that or is it going to be its own
thing or are they goingon to do the
crazy thing which I don't know I don't
think they'll do is is rebuild the whole
thing for the gr for GTA 6 who knows I
have no idea but um we're going to see
at least this game is they're going to
sell us this version of the game and
they're going to sell us a PC version of
the game at some point PC no no
announcement on PC at Lun no
announcement on PC if if that next
Nintendo console could run it in any way
shape that's reasonable it will be on
that platform and then of course we'll
get a next gen upgrade or or whatever
re-release of this game they're going to
sell us this game multiple times they're
going to make billions upon billions of
dollars and people will be happy giving
it to them because they know that it's
GTA 6 yeah so um and you know capping
for a game before is is one of those
things but I'm like they don't they
don't really miss in my book I know you
guys aren't red dead guys but in my book
they don't miss no Red Dead fine we
can't just not for everybody but
graphical Master can't understand
dispute the quality horse blls yeah when
you know what they paying attention to
that is real shut you stupid adct man
GTA 6 your thoughts the trailer what
what was you thinking when you saw this
thing I mean it it definitely uh I'm
looking forward to playing it like as
far as like everyone else like I've
always saw like up until five I saw GTA
as like a really fun game that I really
enjoy playing uh because of you know you
all the support they've done from like
the GTA 4 franchise but I I ain't gonna
lie like after I played GTA 5 and I
expected like more support when it comes
to like the single player narrative and
they never done it and they just focused
on the online infrastructure it's just
like it's I I'm not as hyped for it
anymore look I'm going to play it and I
think it's going to definitely be the
biggest game that's came out in a long
long long time for the foreseeable
future but it's just like it's something
I'm going to play one time and probably
never touch again because it's like I
don't like that multiplayer stuff I
don't like my brother he gonna probably
put like a thousand plus hours into it
but it's just like I'm gonna play that
campaign one time oh the campaign you
play yeah yeah maybe twice depending if
they do some things you know where it's
like some form of repay ability but I
ain't going to lie like at GTA on online
kind of killed my hype for GTA franchise
going forward because I know out the
gate they're going to put a lot of that
there's a lot of budgeting going into
that single player but I know after that
initial single player is out that's it
unless you like the multiplayer it's a
rat yeah and I'm going to enjoy playing
the single player don't get me wrong but
it's just as far as like being really
really excited for it you it'll come out
and I'll play definitely it'll be
probably you know I'd be really hyped to
play it but I know that they're not
going to most likely do anything with
that single player after the actual game
comes out so were you impressed did you
at least like what youself this is what
my question it look cool I I I feel like
I need I miss happy addict I don't feel
like a happy addict lately just I'm just
I don't it just it doesn't I I get it
you guys are are are excited and that
that's cool you
guys he said I get it that you dudes
like that but this is no it's it's not
about not liking like I play I I beat
GTA 5 I enjoy playing GTA wa say that
again say that word you enjoyed I I
played that day one you know I sat in
the the the long giant line that was
there and what's funny it's just
like I expected more from that campaign
I expected to build off for Franklin
Michael and Trevor and I never got it so
it was just like so you want me to put
more time investment into another game
with more characters knowing that
nothing after that happens cuz to me but
you did enjoy what you first played you
did enjoy no I I enjoyed it and I enjoy
doing I like when you enjoy but I I just
don't to me if if you in order to really
truly enjoy the the the experience of of
GTA 5 you got to get on that multiplayer
and it's just I did not true how how
many people here can how many people
here can also say they did you guys play
GTA 5 when it came back to the Xbox one
did you rebeat it no hell no because it
had no value outside of that single
player experience like yeah the
multiplayer is where they at they are
they outside that joint I definitely
agree with you there that's for sure no
doubt no doubt um that was I'm sorry cut
you off yeah yeah yeah I'm good no doubt
no doubt I mean I want people I see
people look I'm going to play the game
like hear my thing like I'm not sitting
here doing jumping jack slapping my
thigh di down hit with the line said I'm
happy that you're happy you hit us with
that I'm happy that you're happy I'm
excited you guys are happy and I'm going
to be right there with you but I know in
my
soul that that excitement's gonna last
for like two three days because that
multiplayer and who knows maybe they'll
hit me with the multiplayer I don't know
but my my brother's is obsessed took
over his life yeah outside see and I'm
excited for people like him that love
that there you go you
it's just like as far as me I'm excited
to get my hands on that campaign because
I know Rockstar does crazy stuff with
their games and they're G to evolve that
you know that type of game like like
immersively but like to me too I don't
want I played uh when I played GTA 5 I
played Red Dead 2 I am not feeling the
the clunkiness of the of the player and
I feel like they're not going to fix
that you know I get people are like it's
realistic you can't stop on a d that's
cool it's a game though if I wanted to
do that i' go out there and jog with the
control I got you I got you you need to
see true gameplay system improvements
from y'all remember the argument I had
with adct with red dead yes I remember
oh my God years ago now at this point
yes he was not about that he not about
I'm not saying that you guys don't have
the right to enjoy it but it's just like
I'm not there that's like oh my God it's
a 2025 I can't wait you know poing
bottles you po bottles like yo that
looks cool you know what's funny is it
was when it dropped I didn't even watch
it I went there and got my brother and
me and him both watched it so it's just
like it's cool I'm gonna enjoy playing
it I just like when you enjoy stuff
there is way more games that I'm looking
forward to over GTA 6 for instance Final
Fantasy rebirth I'm looking more forward
to that you excited because that's
coming out sooner or because mainly
coming out sooner here's the thing like
a lot it's mainly just I know I'm not
going to enjoy the entire the entirety
package of GTA 6 and it's just the
campaign I'm going to enjoy you know I I
I have bought that game
twice and I and I only really played it
once like and I enjoy playing it I do
but I think like the GTA thing with me
went out the floor the old days where
you know you could just SP jets in front
of you and stuff like it's just like
after that it's still a phenomenal game
in Rockstar is definitely top five
developers in the industry but it's I'm
not going out and saying that it's like
the most hype game that's ever coming
out I hope you guys enjoy it I'm enjoy
it with you but I'm not I'm not going to
trick myself and hyping myself up for
for a year and a half to two to play
something for two days and just drop it
because I know that's what's GNA happen
that's fair that's you know where you at
with it you know where you at with it I
just like bothering you
continue King look King you your
thoughts uh GTA Florida in the building
where we at um the one game that
can uh Dodge the criticism and the
softness of what's going on that we have
with uh the individuals that are vocal
nowadays you know sensitive dudes softb
jelly back dudes back okay a for that
that's ain't for that Grand Theft Auto
didn't care about y'all like grand Grand
Theft Auto went out there to to offend
you to put um culture in your face and
it's always been topical like Grand
Theft Auto has always been like an
encapsulation of whatever time is going
on I um San Andreas for me was a peak
because I'm not from that was the peak
for me too San Andreas that was a peak
for me too no I didn't say it was the
peak I said it was a peak for me into um
La culture oh like look yeah because
what I saw was I learned from I I
learned La culture from Colors the movie
um boys in the hood you know stuff like
that and it was always like the negative
stuff not saying that the Grand Theft
Auto didn't have like some negative
connotation to it but it it was still
you know CJ was dope going around the
neighborhood when I got to Cali the
first thing I thought was wow Grand
Theft Auto San Andreas prepared me for
this like all the like look like in the
game like and I was like yo I said this
is really dope
um I know it's going to be a a year from
now so it's so many games that's coming
out ahead of time I can't really say
that my um excitement for it is super
high right because I have to wait and
there's a lot of stuff that's coming out
before then but I know the day that it
comes out day and date I'm going to be
playing it I'm going to finish the story
I never got into the online aspect of of
it and the online aspect of it is as
robust as fortnite yeah like they they
make their money off I forgot what their
currency is called
sharkar is the Shark cards I don't know
what the actual currency is maybe it's
just called Shark currency I don't know
right but like what adct was saying I
understand they was not dropping any um
story driven stuff right the stuff that
we got for uh Vice City like the ballet
the Gay Tony and stuff like that that
stuff was cool they didn't do that with
five yeah good and and what they did do
though I saw them dropping story content
for the
online remember they had like this Heist
thing and all all types of stuff was
around the online and I'm like how how
robust is this so I think now they
learned a lesson from five that the
online was separate from the story mhm
and I think they're going to do it in a
fashion that the online because now
we're online always
right now I think they're going to do
the online and a story in a way that is
together and adct is going to get that
story content that's going to be driven
towards the online I think Grand Theft
Auto 6 is always online the story is
built and wrapped around the online and
it's one big giant package in instead of
two separate packages oh don't say that
people going to be really upset if it's
that they they they shouldn't be because
it should be a way for you to play it in
a way that you don't have to worry about
you know somebody putting a bounty on
your head and stuff like that but I
think the game is going to be dope I I
definitely
sort
graphically out of this world wow and
the first thing you heard these monkey
mouth dudes saying monkey mouth was the
first hurdle for a Grand Theft
406 is little man oh wow I didn't even
know about when Boulders gate showed
you Boulders gate three showed you
little man is leading the
charge stop with the rhetoric bro your
unstable
box is the problem that's why yall need
a pro so hopefully that Pro come out
right before that joint come out to get
your frames up because your frames is
looking a little weak right now but yeah
yeah I will always stay on the head
pause you know you mentioned that and
it's funny because most people are
speculating this game is a 30 FPS game
right yeah y yeah well because what
happens is this is what always happens
right you start getting to a point in
generation you start getting the things
that you want out of the generation
especially the hardcore right one we
we're obviously the bells and whistles
the prettiness the resolution that's
great but we want performance
everybody's used to that 60 FPS we want
that now then in comes a game like this
that pushes the boundaries right
bro 30 right I see that's 30 so if it is
true that we aren't we just getting a
refresh of the Xbox uh consoles right
potential the pro could be the 60 frames
definitive and this is the thing for on
the PlayStation side right if if like
King said if that coincides it could
have a little bit of a cool there
because there's no PC version right so
at least they haven't talked about it
yet and and they knowing Rockstar they
know they can sell you this game again
they're going to wait they're going to
wait going to be at least a year after
whatever this game releases that they're
going to give PC version uh it could be
like if that if that coincides all of a
sudden this looks more you know
PlayStation Centric if you want to say
that I'm going tell you this right now
only console that could run 60 at the
highest Fidelity I will be playing it on
that console that is the case a lot of
I'mma say
this whoever gets the market and wins I
don't care what it runs like on your
machine yeah if XBox gets that marketing
and you can put Call of Duty on the
sticker on the box with uh Grand Theft
Auto and Starfield oh wow and boulders
gate and Game Pass at that same time you
might as well take that PlayStation up
wrap it up with a doobie and Chuck it in
the
bushes y your death will be in
2025 that will be it so you better hope
Jim put some stimulus package away to
get that grand theft 406 because if
y'all don't get that
marketing I mean GTA is at a point I
don't think they could just be like F
both of y'all yeah they don't even need
they're like we're free money it's free
money bro true but who who got enough
bag for that for that Microsoft dude
they just spent 70 true all right you
know who got enough money for it all
right fair enough but we do what does
marketing entail entail right when we
talk about it like you see how these
dudes said blade and his um on Xbox
right and dudes is like did they say it
on Xbox I don't know well now when they
say Grand Theft aut0 6 is on Xbox oh you
guys going to be like oh snap he said it
they putting the foot on they
neck yo here that's what we want to
marketer for just to use S Jelly back
dud in this unlikely
[Music]
scenario okay okay we'll see we'll see I
don't know what's going happen I've been
right yeah yeah he has been he has been
I mean look I'll jump in if you finish
what I'm done yeah now look um Gotta
Give Sol his props man Rockstar man
crazy levels to this there is levels to
this like it is stunning how it looks it
is the the sh you know why he got that
face why he got that fa cuz he know that
Tech is going to be put in that Red Dead
Redemption for
sure the Remake the Remake yeah you know
what it is you know what it is the
confidence in them it's because when
they show you this they don't have like
I said they don't have a need to show
you the vertical slice they're showing
you the game and then you let the
digital Foundry go in and break it down
it's like oh this this much of this much
of it is like real time like this could
be gameplay this could be a cut scene
where they smooth it out a little bit
but all it's all ingame engine and some
of it is straight up gameplay they never
lie to you they never lie to you
anything that you like I saw that beach
scene you know oh my God all the density
of the people the detail you saw the
chunky the thick girls with the tattoos
TW that I'm looking in the back oh shout
out to the twerk God bless them they out
here doing the Lord's work
Rockstar twerk physics you out here
doing the Lord's work that each and
every de developer who worked hard who
worked hard on this clearly shout out to
a clearly very clearly they work very
hard got the hor balls team on the man
they out here doing the Lord's work and
look you know what's funny is like the
people attacking them for doing it it's
like in case you ain't noticed GTA is
supposed to be a parity of
America and that's what it's it's common
for them it's like look like I don't and
then you got like an adjacent people
saying like they they've gone woke too
and it's like what do you mean a female
protagonist people are just throwing
that everywhere it's like look Bon andde
i b I don't think Lucia oh Lucia yes yes
yes put that mask on let's go get that
work here's the thing the adct said it
perfectly the reason why I love Rockstar
when it comes to G even though I am not
a GTA dude like they like adct I was
teasing them because I'm the same way
what it is their world are so immersive
off I end up not doing the main story
and just getting
distracted I I'm I'm so overwhelmed with
all the systems and the beauty that's
going on you can literally do side games
and be immersed in these things forever
but the beauty of how CJ was de he was
bring he definitely
get facts I remember that so the thing
is where addict is right is I
love he King what you're saying their
creative expression to say you can't
tell us how to make our games we are
going to take the creative expression
and the freedom to give a snapshot of
what we feel the world is right now and
what I love about them is they take from
real media kind of events that has
happened this is the most Florida game y
I have ever seen and what's funny is is
a lot of King all all the Lords know you
know I got a lot of synergy to Florida
recently so it's like seeing it I'm like
yep that's it and every group gets to
smoke every group gets to smoke it don't
matter what's your ethnicity your
background where y from everybody gets
to smoke in the most You Know parody way
but it's accurate cuz you like yo
someone had a a a a news shot of every
thing that they took from real even from
the guy pulling the crocodile out know
somebody had the city girls F what was
they made record they had that record I
forgot what that record was hot girl
summer yeah hot girl whatever they had
like everybody's getting in then you
know shout out my Backwoods my you know
like y everyone's getting it so I like I
love the fact that they are consistent
on their message every GTA and this is
why people love it this is why the
millions the billions go for this game
is one of the most controversial games
from the violence and from the depiction
standpoint but this is why I love devs
allowed to do their Vision how they do
it and the people speak cuz this to
King's Point about like how maybe he not
be satisfied with MCU or certain things
with messages agenda they are going to
make this the way they want to make it
and they're getting rewarded because the
people agree this is what's up but I'll
let y jump I want to
jump I just wanted to say that it's so
dope that they said you gonna buy this
anyway yes oh yeah it don't matter this
that's the thing and like you said it's
immune to all of this there some of this
conversation has been going on online
about to addex point the wokeness or
whatever right some people saying like
oh you know all of that Florida man
stuff all that stuff is like oh that's
not what Flor Florida is right now and
people started talking about the
politics of stuff of like oh you know
Florida really is like in a in a crazy
state right now where you know they're
blocking immigrants and trying to kick
out things of that nature have you why
don't you have what when did people stop
having fun and stop like I've I've
always been of the mind that stereotypes
exist because they're they're this close
to reality right it could be an
exaggeration but it's they this close to
reality and to me GTA games always
remind me that we need to laugh at
ourselves and look in the mirror and
laugh at ourselves sometimes and not
take ourselves so Ser it's a Time piece
of what's going on really it always it's
a snapshot snapshot and and it's their
exaggeration of that snapshot that time
right and at the same time you will
always find within that something with
cultural relevance today they're NE
these guys are very smart they spend
years and years and years building this
out to give you something that is a sar
itic yes twerking on a car was crazy ex
exactly take on what and the funny thing
about it is that the heads of the the
heads of this are are British guys right
so it's it's like it's the Bri on what
how they look at America on some levels
right that's what is it would be like
silver server coming to Earth oh this is
what y'all be doing oh this what do
exactly n like let's let's let's have
fun let's stop and not be so serious and
that I interrupt I was going to jump in
real quick have you guys seen the um the
Bingo cars things people have been doing
recently like at an event they'll have
like a bingo C they'll have like guesses
what they think is going to be at the
event and the and the goal is to like do
it like you would actually try to win
Bingo where it's like straight line or
straight down I bet you Rockstar has a
bingo card on
woke not not Florida like just they got
like they're all in this this giant
Bingo on the wall it's like no I've seen
that I've seen that bring it up then
prove it
I guarantee you all of that stuff you're
going to find some missions in there to
address all that stuff in a funny way
that you should look at and laugh at to
see how stupid human beings I saw
Rockstar is the type of person to make a
mission about a a company trying to
control another company in its quote
unquote
wokeness what what what I saw in
Spider-Man it was a side mission where
Miles had to help a student uh talk to
somebody for homecoming yep I remember
all right and I
saw people refuse to do that mission wow
because they were either against a
certain uh
demographic I know what you're talking
or they had certain insecurities within
their self yep right and this is what I
said this is a video
game right I don't care I there's no
stance to have like this is not real
characters this is not real stuff
happening um how are you offended like
how are you offended and and then if you
don't do that mission because that's the
last mission you don't get the
suit it's a suit unlocked after that so
it's dudes is running around there with
half a game because in their head
they're offended yeah if you are
offended and you put up that woke crap
talking about oh Grand Theft is woke I
don't like twerking on cars I don't like
how they depicted the black people I
didn't like how they had the white girl
over there with the camera and stuff we
should not be laughing you need to go
away yeah don't don't don't be offended
for me please just I just my 70 gonna be
lit look it's just it's just not for you
that's how you know what's funny I I
think after hogw Worth's Legacy people
on the internet need to realize if you
push too much it's going to back going
to trip OPP and look at the views look
look at the reaction the gamers are
saying this is what we want we don't
want certain other things and it's a
direct reflection of that yeah they like
stop trying to do that in our medium and
it's it's a it's a it's a push back I
agree you know what's sad you know
what's sad the ballot of Gay Tony
couldn't be named that yes I remember
that you're right it couldn't be named
couldn't be named that now we didn't
think nothing of it back then of it
went and brought it yeah I love that DLC
hell yeah it was dope it was so the the
thought process with how far we have
fallen as as a people in a short period
of time yeah that's crazy I don't even
want to H yo listen my $70 is lit like
lit and if they ask me for 100 I still
stop stop stop that we going to do
that you and they going to clip your
USIC they but I will say like again you
know I'm always about creative
expression and and allowing the devs to
create the vision they want however they
want to want and the cops agree so we
move on
unless last thing shout out shout out to
Florida Joker trying to get his bag it a
happening crazy it a ask Lindsay Lohan
it ain't happening it ain't happening he
was like they RI me off man get out of
here out you done he doesn't have a big
he doesn't have a big enough bank
account to take them to court if you're
lucky they might give you a copy of the
game be happy with that be happy with
that they be like they give shark bucks
oh like they gonna be like okay you know
I think because of the Lindsay Lohan
situation this dude might take us to
court let's give him the game just so we
might avoid all that
nonsense ridiculous anything else H we
can move on no that's it all right let's
get Super Chat all right let's get these
Super Chat chat hold on a second uh let
me see we have so many JD Gamers calling
people boy We Got U we got spoony
love spoony
love old school ah you know what that's
from Twisted puppet Thea oh okay okay
sporty love with the 200 yen uh Super
Chat GTA 6 is a floor a man come to life
yes that is absolutely that
is there we got Gaber by choice Super
Chat GTA online is awesome I have
375 days beat Camp four times wow he has
more than a year worth of time in that
game that's crazy that's crazy jie gab
$5 Super Chat pathetic Port begging
ponies to end his night God save you if
Microsoft gets GTA 6 marketing rights
and exclusive content is over the King
has no
clothes what's funny is I'm out here
telling people about Port Beggars and it
just got
crazy got wild I love it yeah JD gamer
once again $2 Super Chat just so where
just so that we remember where we came
from Sega that's right baby talk to scar
it JD gamer $5 Super Chat pathetic Port
beg pathetic Infidel portel everything
is bad strong rhetoric scary
Wes pathetic I thought you all an Omega
Level PC no go buy an Xbox baby where
your games at ponies where your games at
man is out no road map console Waring
streets that's my gu that man is busting
his gun for the cap his cap lock is
going crazy today czy Soldier rank X bro
he's definitely Xbox front live that's
right that's my guy that's your guy
salute JD gamer by choice $2 Super Chat
imagine being uh lead Dev of the jiggle
physics in GTA yep that's right baby yo
what I like also what y'all probably
didn't see when they was on the
beach the
bodies how when you go to the beach yep
the diversity in the oh they killed it
bro that was dope the jle I don't
think I don't think I don't think it's
going to the NPCs is going to have that
level of Fidel
like that unless it's in cutcenes but
let's see
see I don't know what they doing and we
got JD gamer again $ five in the chat
but but but but what about the power of
the PS5 super SSD no games for you no
hellblade no OD no Blade no you pathetic
Porton pathetic oh my God
J he's out [__] wow um then we have
mdy $5 Super Chat as a native 35 Plus uh
Floridian they absolutely nailed the
down to the smallest detail and this
will be the first GTA that I get day one
Florida when they represent home man
it's remember when they did in New York
and they had was it ban and Dukes you
know what the funny thing is when GTA 5
came out I will never forget it um I
didn't at the time just had like pretty
much an Xbox I just bought off of off of
a friend or something it didn't have a
hard drive in it but I thought I would
be good just the disc but no you had to
you had to install install it more stuff
onto the disc so I had to drive to like
four different places to get uh
something to be able to put the
information on to play
it and I'm doing this at like one in the
morning that's should Saye wow that
that's dedication I remember I remember
playing that game and when I found Grove
Street from San Andreas I was like oh
they won man they have this whole game
this whole amazing game is encompasses
this little part of this freaking oh
manane we got JD Gaber $2 Super Chat hey
Pony stop Port begging go buy an Xbox
they have pathetic in the Super Chat
where's pathetic seem like he calmed
down he calm it down okay he might have
he might have stopped drinking the
coffee that's right n cool Aid on flee
flowing free flowing we're good we're
caught up oh let's go all right adct
this is You Avatar your thoughts um it's
out here looks like the uh better critic
kind of sitting 73 right now on PC
frontiers of Pandora I'm assuming you're
playing what's the what's the word about
this game man with two minutes on the
clock two minutes first off shout out to
Ubisoft for the you know I I did I
played probably about six seven hours of
it I enjoy it so first off it's probably
one of the best looking games not
generation no I'm not I'm still under
IND so what are the best looking games
well you're playing a game that's not
out this is true that is true so this is
one of the best looking games let's go
yes it's definitely one of the best
looking games uh at the beginning it
does feel very far cry but you're just
you're big people okay um you know yeah
most of the time it felt like the
biggest things that's going to really
fight me is you know any kind of mechs
or anything like that uh for the most
part like those are the things that's
really going to give you a lot of issues
I I like you know the way you can play
the game it's very far cry but once you
get through further and further in the
game you start coming across stuff that
makes it different from Far Cry I think
it's a it's a fun experience now
obviously I haven't beat it so you know
when we get back from the break I'll do
a more indepth on you know uh the ins
and outs of the game right now I don't
feel like I've played enough to like
really give a good example of how I feel
about the game but I do feel even though
that maybe this game's not doing the
greatest you know U review wise I do
feel like this game is a decent amount
of
a of a take on a franchise or an IP that
we see in the movies a lot of the times
I feel like they just they just try to
you know shoehorn these games in they
don't really think much into it but at
least they took someone in a formula
like Far Cry and they fine tuned it to
make sense to the Avatar brand and it
does feel good U you know I'm hoping
they take this this this ideal and they
build off of it I'm really U you know
looking forward to see what they do for
some reason I don't know how Ubisoft
keeps getting their hands on I uh on
licensing deals yeah they're very good
at doing it and you know I I would uh at
the moment I can't 100% recommend it
until I beat it I haven't played enough
to really say if I recommend playing it
at this time but that's about it how
does it R cry yeah it it runs good I
have no like big issues I'm playing on
the series X uh you know I I have come
some you know stutters every now and
then but besides that I haven't really
had no like huge issu but I said this
this game is
gorgeous that's nice to know what you
playing on series X or series series X
yeah the series X it's definitely the
of course one of the best looking games
I've played uh on the platforms thought
of gang singal with
his if you like Far Cry and that you
really enjoyed that
franchise you're the demographic I would
recommend blind buying it because I I do
think you know you're more inclined to
like this type of game than someone if
you did not like Far Cry I would
probably stay stay away from it is it
different than Far Cry yes J on they do
do things that's different than Far Cry
but I would say there's a lot of
similarities especially early in the
game JD got time
today he he said he said yo homeboy the
other day I ain't have time but today
got get all his bars today teach your
man how I got I got to respect JD though
because there's a lot of people that be
there'll be a lot of people in the chat
saying there a lot of stuff to The Ether
but he's he puts
he's standing on business facts he
letting him know he's saving money on
Game Pass stop Port begging he got money
to spend he's standing on business he's
like he's like you go out there and buy
an Xbox for their games like I had to
stop poor B begging yeah buy Series S
get that
that cop
that you have any questions with it yeah
no I think I'm going to pick up the PC
version and see how that
L but it is I I mean it kind of feels
like it has sale energy coming up
soon no a seven it's it's the fact that
it's it's very far cryes um is
intriguing to me and the fact that it's
a really pretty game open world I want
to see that running at 60 so I want to
see is is it running on at 60 how did it
feel did it feel I'm not a very
technical person um it felt good felt
good like I there's some games like I
felt like Starfield on on Xbox felt like
45 like it didn't feel 30 and it didn't
feel 60 was weird it was some weird
stuff it was some magical stuff man
Jason Ronald them magical yeah that that
that performance on the console at
launch was weird because normally I
could tell a 30 frame game when I see a
30 how how did it how did it play on the
PlayStation it didn't play on the
PlayStation
you know you know I I I feel King you
know I'm sitting there I'm waiting it's
never not popping up I searched for it
in the store feel like what's that song
by EV oh yeah it's like I done wrote you
you didn't call
me St the St yeah there I
go just it's just
dear dear Phil
y it be different it' be different it's
like it's like dear Phil or
Todd where is my star
Phil check the chat check boot it up the
car so it didn't it wasn't there messy
add check the chat when you get a chance
but yeah no I'm glad you uh talk spoke
about it obviously I'm a big Avatar fan
so I'm curious I was curious to see how
it was received obviously C is the man
got got lot love for but yeah got to
check it out got to see when I get my
hands on it see what's going on but uh
um everybody's good on the Avatar we can
move on with some chest well um I like
the movie Yes the fact that you said
that it was uh graphically intense um
I'm going to keep my eye out for it and
Game Pass whenever it
hit
funny off what you call it right I saw
no I saw yeah that's coming soon I saw
um acg's review on it it look it looked
really good and and and he was he was
going to ins and outs and stuff like
that and stuff that you do so it's
really good it look I'm I'mma be real
with you um Mike Untitled that tagged me
on Twitter with this long ass post I
ain't reading your stuff I'm just muting
you oh all right sh you got somebody
going at you going at you going at the
kid okay so I read it for the chat he
must he must have a jelly back he got a
jelly spine let's see what's going on he
don't got a spine Lord addict I so
people are report required to talk about
a platform in regards to Blade no they
are you could choose to not talk about
it personally I'm stoked we are getting
a blade game regardless a platform and
we love hearing more about the game and
less platform they didn't have Xbox
logo legally we need to talk about that
okay there you go man wow you really you
really went in on them
hey the guc it's just like sitting here
just coming at me it's like dude we talk
about first off we're influencers we're
podcasters we're streamers I guess less
streamers you streamers really want have
to talk about it that is literally what
we are here to do my dudes so maybe you
shouldn't talk about it how about that
you ain't a podcaster you know I'm
looking at your stuff you know you got
you got 426 followers you got a little
bit you got a little more followers than
the average
he could be a podcaster and this is his
sub account I'm done anywhere you are
you are following some people I would
expect someone like you we can agree toe
you know peace and blessings in the real
peace and blessings peace and blessings
G following some
people let's move on let's move on let's
get these super chats going
hey there go in there and like his tweet
like his tweet we got to show we
supporting the community go like his
tweet all about you know love and peace
in the community twe with our gaming
brothers and sisters we love them all
the fite when we agree we agre to
disagree I'm I'm giving him support I
roasted you now you get support you
don't get one without the other my dude
back to you s back to you so we got a
visual walk through with the two pound
Super Chat thanks for a great podcast
Lord thank you appreciate salute thank
you then we got JD gamer once again $5
Super Chat just to be clear I'm never
calm I'm always in these streets
watching lurking waiting and slaying
these pathetic P piing ponies Xbox baby
Xbox front line War salute killer salute
do your thing salute killer do your
thing out here you out here you busting
your G for
real we we're caught up I actually have
one more thing to give away oh oh we got
another giveaway yes give me a moment
while all right we out here for the
final day 2023 the final I giveway is on
the iron Lord's um Twitter um no we got
we got that we take care of Alex want to
take care of that yeah I'm GNA share
that before the podcast ends oh okay
okay so I was looking for it we got to
get that going you know what I'm saying
good friends what else we got going on
this is from our good friend akw you oh
shout out to AK another
giveaway I'mma read let me see I'm read
what he wrote yo this they said this is
IOP right now chill oh with the Lord
Metro versus
oh see that's messy put it back up they
said we oh wow we we on yard watching
that's crazy it was it it was wild out
these Nintendos Nintendo one Nintendo
crime yeah know man usually doesn't
happen usually does that's rare that's a
rare moment Nintendo on Nintendo K yes
it's crazy so this is Lord akw shout out
to you man I appreciate you hey Lords I
know that today is the last show of the
year and I would like to thank you Lords
for the amazing 2023 and wish the best
uh to you Lords in 2024 thank you to you
as well man I would also like to thank
the Lords for helping me share the
GoFundMe link to help my mom this year
exactly yeah absolutely and I am still
trying to help her but want to say have
a great Christmas and a happy New Year
he got a code for the uh for the crew
for everybody out in not for us for
everybody in the chat he said not for
you
co shut up Co it's not for you co said
oh
that's that's how that's how Sony fans
felt when they heard
BL oh not for you a that's my fault I
might not said that clear
yeah oh you did a Microsoft for the
community right I was a little
wishy-washy about it hold
on I am so bad so this is for Game Pass
ultimate I don't know uh what duration
but it's for Game Pass ultimate so shout
out to
AKs I'mma read this out like I read the
last
one we have
C2
gqr GW P3
y XR d f as in Frank
J
6km
X2 32
krz shout out to akw out to akw that's
love salute bless anybody who gets the
code well put that in the chat and give
a shout out to akw always appreciate
people doing stuff for the community
that is amazing thank you brother
appreciate yo adct only has nine Subs o
i mean 90 Subs over on his atct uh Subs
uh Arena yeah let's get that up there I
I want y'all to get over there ASAP and
and sub we have over 900 people here put
the link in the chat add put that link
in the chat we have over 900 people here
open up another bar on your um on your
browser and and just hit hit the sub
yeah cuz me and him going to be over
there acting a fool in this mhm we going
to try to get some fighting gam we going
to kill
Kong okay don't put l uh one more Super
Chat wavy kosher member for seven months
Lord silver 600 pm and the Lords are
still going that's a question it's a
great Sunday happy holidays Lord stay
beefy out
there I was trying to get out of here
things happened I was running my mouth I
knew it was going to happen Yeah final
yeah all right cool Final topic um
unless we got anything Bills play
anything like that um King's topic of
course uh shout out to The Verge um
after unexplained bans uh Playstation
had hundreds of reports of users locked
out of their um accounts and this is
without Waring on Monday um many uh
Playstation uh Network USS reported that
their accounts were unexpectedly uh
permanently suspended and um two as of
Tuesday Morning some of them receive
many of them that received the message
were restored but um yeah it was
definitely going on um earlier some one
a message to one user read that it said
this account is permanently suspended
from PlayStation Network due the
violations of the PlayStation Network
terms of service and agreement and yeah
this went there was a form on res reset
era that showed many people experiencing
problems and that multiple vers readers
also wrote into tips as far as you know
how to deal with it and how distru
people were that yeah it was not called
customer service yeah the customer
service issue and stuff like that now
since then um there have been added
reports that some of a lot of these
PlayStation accounts have been restored
overnight but yeah this was a big deal
earli in the week as far as the lockouts
of accounts and the systems without
warning on Monday so kayen this is your
topic about PlayStation bans and
accounts and
suspensions see y'all thought that um y
was going to put this news out it was
going to die before this weekend you had
the game awards and I wouldn't get a
chance to address this y'all worrying
about blade y'all should worry about
your server blades getting hacked y'all
should worry about what the hell is
going on y' have a real blade issue and
it ain't the one that y'all wanted now
I'm I'm I'm watching this and I don't
know why y'all guys are not screaming
and it wasn't hundreds it was thousands
all right and and and they actually
underplaying it and they saying most of
the people have been restored why not
all the people um I saw this should not
happen at all you should not get Shadow
banned as you go into your house and you
go to pick up you like yo I heard they
got the new DLC for God a war yeah man
I'm about to go play it right now some
Arena mode stuff they gave it out for
free oh say word let go throw that
controller on you have been
banned that is they essentially turned
your joint into a
brick for no fault of your own then you
call customer service and they like we
don't know what you did but um on our
end uh you need to go buy another
PlayStation d he say that yo I'm sick
and tired of you dudes worrying about
what's going on with us y'all need to
worry about y'all being banned now this
is
fearful and any other thing that you got
in your life like your refrigerator if
you open your refrigerator does it say
you banned you'll have a problem right
you go to your car you go to get in your
car you turn your key in or you hit the
the start button and it says no you
banned you have a problem right
none of y'all are screaming about this
with your PlayStation y priorities is
screwed up watch out because you don't
know if you are next and I think the
Banning dudes are going around like
Goldberg like who's next I'm you next be
careful for y'all getting banned I think
this this has much to do with the
hackers remember when the hackers told
Sony yo pay up for the ransom I remember
that yeah and and it was like nah man we
don't deal we don't deal with terrorists
we don't negotiate with terrorists
negotiate they was like yo your
customers your
customers is going to get the WRA for
this and they said we don't care about
the customers they know we don't care
about them they know we don't care and
they thought they call a bluff they say
yo we gave y'all to
midnight that's oh they push the button
on them they push the button on them
they gave him to midnight and they
said initiate all the
66 say y think this is a game
yeah y not gonna send me the bread y
you're not g to send me the bread
execute him oh man and and y'all got the
ban now I'm not laughing because it's
not really funny this this is really
scary and sad scary stuff scary stuff
it's scary and sad that when one of the
guys called uh text into customer
service and told him the issue that he
was having yeah customer service
basically gave him the runaround and
told him that he couldn't help him m
at all I don't know what tear he was
because you know in the
PlayStation cuz you know in the this
this is where it's really bad if you not
tier
five they not picking up your was a te
situation with the a weird Scarlet
Letter thing going
on exposing the dude teer number when
when he call up with a call ID oh man
you hitting him up and you like yo I've
been banned EXC me sir what te are
you I got it worse I got it worst I got
it by your phone number so you call they
already know they head it depending on
who's calling if it's king and you in
that high tier hello loyal customer how
can I help you if it's someone that you
got that L cheer hey broke boy how can I
help you no they don't even answer the
phone call they just look at it they
look at it oh that's a t one that's
that's when you get the the overseas
customer service oh not the Florida oh
don't do it like that now you know how
when they go um hi my name is
John you BL your name is not John oh man
my name is John I like
X may I help you hey you go um yeah man
I've been banned um what what seems to
be the problem I I've been I've been
banned on my PlayStation what did you do
did you play Call of
Duty CU you know right now in Call of
Duty they have this wir tap joint going
on in the background now King King talk
like you you the preium person how that
how do they handle that
person
hello it seems like I've been
banned on my
PlayStation yes yes I am tier five yes
yeah I am tier F got shot out they tear
uh yes I do have 15
platinums okay it's in the mail honey
that's sending me a new
PlayStation yeah courtesy a gim
yes he send over cookies baby he send
over C with his face on
it and all they do to to the lower tier
people send a picture of a
PlayStation yo I just want to say it
suck and it was just a cute little thing
that I wanted to talk about give some
laughter this is the end of the year and
um you guys showed up strong today we
had 1,200 people here and uh I'm I'm a
proponent for going for the whole year
but not this time yeah we gotta we need
we need the mental break it's been we
been this time yeah C Cog hit me this
morning normally he calls me in the
morning right before the show yo you up
you good and I was so out of
pocket his number came came up I you
know how the text come up at the bottom
the you hit me with the auto text yeah
he like please do not call me right I am
in the middle of something right now
like what is this I said I text you
later I was like yo I'm up I'm
good but you know I was I was taking
care of some stuff but um yeah this this
we we rolling into the next year and
we're going to get the game I guess we
get some time off on Sunday get some
sleep get some rest because my only day
off is uh Saturday anyway so now I get a
chance to rest um for Sun day but um you
guys are the best it is uh a wonderful
thing sharing stories with friends um
sharing um moments and you know I look
forward to the future so I do appreciate
each and every last one of you guys
and I'm truly blessed I'm I'm really
truly blessed for the community for you
guys and for us for this journey and and
the fact that your nephew can Google our
um our
finances I was like where did you get
this
number salute yeah but he was he looked
at me with a straight face he was like
you're not that
popular I'm like damn bro damn bro I
like this look man I agree with K if we
we rapping um yeah this has been a
tremendous year it has been phenomenal I
mean for me personally selfishly you
know it was there was some highlight
moments as far from a guest standpoint
you know we had Peter Mo in the in the
realm y'all Peter Mo twice you know um
and he was eager to do it and he was him
and he was Cliffy be was every it's one
of the times you meet your You Meet Your
Heroes and he lives up to exceeded when
your Heroes exceed you know I mean we've
interviewed many developers we had John
Johannes Rush shout out to Harold
Goldberg New York game
awards Cliffy be y we did that that was
that was a that was a difficult one to
get yeah yeah we had that um I want to
get Mikey bar of course that that's
always on the list right you know him
shout out to the homie um Patrick Ren
from Halo infinite to then should I
Survivor you know me personally I know
how much I'm a fanboy of turnbas and
XCOM you know me and addict to have Jake
Solomon you know on that was again
another dream King me and you
interviewing Chris aaki from me the
legendary you know what I'm saying all
that from for a team that's my first
time I fan boyed out yeah yeah man it it
it it's been a tremendous lost my
composure so for
realos going to the shows meeting
everybody you know me personally this
was a very rough year you know
physically you know in transition
jobwise doing going back and forth doing
all this other stuff and um just to see
the love for the community getting that
Health as wealth movement I got to
promote it a little bit like getting
everybody being honest with the
community what I'm going through when
I'm in my dark time to see them tell me
yo Co we been through this or you help
me with that that was huge um just
tremendous gr me and adct up late all
the night thinking about how to make the
show better and you know just to y'all
just give y'all your flowers like the
attic show and then Xbox front line
right and then let's not forget s like
hold the lot was a
thing like like Aaron greenber bro we
had Aaron Greenberg bro like there's
nothing nobody can say to me that's why
when I see any type of negative comments
or whatever of people usually console
and platform based anger but like at the
end of the day like I am so proud of
what we doing here because it's like
these are moments you can't take from us
and and it I know for a fact this may
sound arrogant we push the culture on
some things and we we we have an organic
thing here that people respect and can
resonate with and that means a lot the
support that we get we do not take for
granted that's why we read every Super
Chat that's why we talk to every
developer we have people on we have
different opinions on and and it's dope
man in 2023 was was an amazing year we
we definitely need some rest so you can
come in 2024 you know solve I know
you've been through a lot let you get
the floor as far as everything that's
been going on with you and just the type
of year that we've been having and I'm
very thankful for you because you know
there's so much behind the scenes that
solved us that keeps us legally correct
Keeps Us in check with our fiduciary UH
responsibilities Keeps Us in check with
planning and going to shows and trips
and you know what I'm saying shout out
there last thing I got to say shout out
to Lords of gaming.net man cuz at the
end of the day it's been a crazy year
for us a lot going on behind the scenes
and the loyalty to see people continue
to write from an independent website
that means a lot you know tremendous
editorial team tremendous riding Team
every single one grinding and and we're
going to do better we have to improve
that stuff I y'all holding me
accountable I have to improve but it's
it's just it's um we're blessed we're
blessed as much as this is work when we
come here it feels fun and we have a
good time and 6 hours went past I quick
you know that's crazy but so I'm going
let you get the full 2023 as we roll
into 2024 yeah man I mean again it's
just a you know finally hitting that 20K
right and to get that number right and
and thinking about you know the first
couple of days in here and and first
couple of podcasts and like like you
said we about around September the
24th we H 20K so you know and that that
was huge because we remember the first
you know couple of months man it was
like you arguing with your boys like you
you would show up today like you wer in
there we joke about it but it's the
truth it was like yo man we need people
in the chat you wasn't of the 10 he was
one of the 10 what's going on me me and
King cut dudes off we know in real life
I cut family members off facts I was
like me and my P going have bro you
ain't even listen to the podcast I want
that part right there yeah I talked I
had to check Pops I had to check poog I
I did that I did that to my Pops I did
that to my moms I did that to one of my
boys and I'm like yo I got a dude that's
in Germany that supports me more than
you shout out to Iceland that that that
that's crazy but what I what I found out
in this whole
thing is that the people closest to you
but really won't support you but it be
yeah but it'll be somebody facts that's
in Japan with a Hold the Line shirt on
shout out to my man Anthony lamb out
there in um Whata call it not too far
from Liverpool and Shout out the country
big UK like you know what I'm saying the
love hit different bro it hit different
it's so many people but I'm sorry I
interrupt you kid no no it's
just I get humbled at it and and I know
I let a I had a moment of weakness when
somebody had said something you know the
other day it was just yesterday and you
know I just really had got upset but I
am truly blessed because a lot of other
people was like man I wish I could
afford one of those statues that you got
up there or whatever and then you know
some dude that some stuff did go or
whatever but C K and solv and addict no
I'm a real personal person and I and it
it takes a lot for me to even be like
help yeah like you know help here so
when I did it and it was like damn I was
vulnerable and I exposed myself for it
and then for somebody to to do that I
was like this is the reason why I don't
right type of thing but again there was
more love than that one ignorant comment
and I got to sit there and continue to
understand that I remember when it was
only seven people in the chat and I have
a thousand people coming through yeah we
may not have 50,000 subscribers or
100,000
subscribers but the people we do have
the realest is really I listen I put the
the realm up against any Community like
I don't see that level you know what I'm
saying how they show out for us they be
in the chat early we having fun together
and they rocking you know what I'm
saying so to me like that you were you
can't quantify that that that's
something that's just we know we got
something and we never want to take it
for granted right but I want to get at
it it's like what was 2023 for you man
as we look at 2024 my brother we always
late night brainstorming and talk for
hours on the phone about what we could
do to improve and stuff like that what
was it for
you uh you know it just the amount of uh
grinding that we did this year is unreal
yeah uh me what's funny is I did like so
I remember like the the Montage of the
episode thing like we only I only did
like five or six and C's like you
wouldn't kill me I'm like well he's like
I want every
five but you be coming up with them
ideas man I'll be like's just do it we
going do it let's do it and then what's
funny is CG's not like quick on the
trigger like that so he's like I'll help
you man and I'm doing like six his one
and so I catch up and he's okay okay I'm
on nine I'm like I've already did nine
just
go it just you know it's it's been a
it's been a crazy year you know I want
to give like a a little statistic thing
at the beginning of this year we started
at
13,500 subscribers wow uh we almost
doubled our wow our subscriber rate and
that's all because you guys now
obviously around October November we
kind of like started slowing down less
guests you know just us cuz uh mentally
getting driven out I want to thank y'all
for that because that was a decision I
asked for because I know a lot of people
in room like yo when am I going to come
on but like I did this was like in the
height of me with the job and all the
stuff going on and I asked my brothers I
was like look y'all know when I have a
guest on I like to roll out the red
carpet do it official do the research do
all that but it does take a toll out of
me and I asked my brothers like yo is it
okay if we could pull back on the GU and
make it sometimes just the Lord
was like bro you ain't got to say less
was like say less he said we don't have
to have no guest for three weeks I said
all right okay too eager with yeah he
was eager with it he and I was just like
so if you notice towards the end of the
second half of the year we it was more
just the Lords a lot and and and I think
it helped because one for my mental
sanity juggling all the things I'm
juggling and then for the guys that we I
thought to be honest I thought we bonded
more when it's just us four a lot of
people tell us that in the past but
continue I think the beginning of the
year we get get a new audience and the
end year we maintain that audience yeah
cuz the shows like you know we are
podcast without the without these crazy
guests and yes uh we we we are ramping
it back up next year I've already
reached out to six or seven you know we
got things cooking good good guest I
think you guys are GNA really enjoy that
I want to do more collabs too with other
podcasts I think you know that's fun uh
I do want to have uh hip hop back on we
got get hiop back on you know things
going on I got some good
me and King kind of went into it but
we're really uh going to we're going to
try our hardest to go to TGs next year
Tokyo game show that's the plan that's
the plan in Tokyo we're we're gonna try
to to do a live stream a podcast
straight from Tokyo like that live for
the live for the I the sh we got to try
to save
up side I just hope they got chairs my
side I'm in the boat with you but um My
Hope for next year is to have Phil
Dominus Maximus put it in the universe
in in the realm of Phil that needs to
happen it's time pH time we love you
it's time the deal is done come on home
um also I would like to have Sarah B
definit like to have the shooter on Matt
booty oh yeah yeah got a chance M booty
got come through when I see you bro I'm
going give you the biggest hug I me
afraid you're going to get the biggest
hug because you that
dude need to know you you you that dude
um also I want Kai sonat
um oh that's gonna be a crazy I'm saying
I want I want somebody to clip this tag
this and tag uh Kai in it let him know
you from the town
bro ready for that I'm be real with you
I don't know if for that I'm ready for
it but you from the town bro and I ident
identify with your story yes and your
hustle and your grind I truly respect it
your circumstance and
everything I love this kid yeah and and
and I really would love to just have the
conversation with him because he plays
shout out wait hold on I see my man in
there shout out to Lord py TV setting up
our P brother PAX East getting it
popping we will be back out there for
next year top of the Year shout out to
flame in there a lot of Lord Lords and
g.net is going to be rolling through so
pull up pull up for sure watch out IGN I
see I see it always got sh I See Kai
like as a different type of Mr Beast
like evolving in different areas and
doing stuff people ain't never
done this the last one so they get this
and then we take a break yeah Kai did
something where he like everyone pretend
to be in jail for like a week that was
the craziest thing I've ever seen no
one's ever done that I've never seen
that speaking of Kai I want to shout out
my brother Lord Kai B oh I want to shout
out the behind y'all be in the comments
where's the time that's my brother doing
an all audio platform Spotify iTunes the
whole bit then giv it to me put it up on
YouTube please put respect on my brother
he does so much behind the scene to make
my life easier as a host it is very
stressful after doing a six-h hour
podcast to then have to go file through
do time do all this stuff he does it
with kid he doesn't ask her down and
that is my brother I love shout out to
Citi shout out to valon Channel 5 The
Originals who still support all Chan 5
that I see y'all in the chat cuz y'all
know it means a cuz we actually for real
know each other in real life play games
in real life and they still our brothers
so I want to Sal salute the home team
you know what I'm saying on that part
but I'm sorry adct and S you to get I'm
putting in the chat this is really
important guys go over there and retweet
that giveaway that's on social media
right now uh the reason I even if you
don't uh enter it which I don't know why
you wouldn't enter it
most PC you know nzx
it's it's a let's be real NZXT is not
going to give you not the computer like
it's a genuine giveaway giveway yeah and
we're talking like a very prominent PC
something that especially if you even
remotely want to get into content
creation you get that sucker You' be
good for like six seven years man I want
to thank everyone everyone man all year
uh you know me and King are still going
to be doing stuff uh for the for the
rest of the year uh but we will be back
as as a podcast I think I am going to do
something for IOP this Sunday It Won't
Be Live I think I'm going to make like
I'm gonna make something special and
premere during the time saw so we'll see
so we still give a little something
while we right or I Outsource that
sucker if I don't have
time so what about you what's your recap
of the Year man I didn't I feel like I
got enough bars from you man I mean
again it was like I was I got to give
you guys a shout out because you guys
again uh you guys
always do above and beyond like the fact
that you know adct with his own channel
doing all the stuff behind the scenes
for for for us King King now taking on
the the extra burden and responsibility
of maintaining a channel um and seeing
all that stuff grow and shine and
addition to us finally you know growing
and seeing and seeing more more eyes on
us and stuff like that and you know
seeing the people that we bring in and
all of it is due to you guys in the chat
like you guys
again you come in here every single week
you laugh with us you cry with us if
need be even the people that come in to
be like ah it's just an Xbox whatever
the case may be but you're here and you
know that you're welcome here no matter
what nobody you could you could not you
can come in here and not like what you
hear or whatever you don't want to
listen to you know to to us ranting ra
whatever but you know no matter what if
you come in there you voice your opinion
if you're respectful when it's
disrespectful to you we we're going to
handle that we're going to make sure we
create the best environment for you to
be in here it's oh it's going to be you
know we going to be back and forth you
got a lot of Xbox people here whatever
the case may be but at the end of the
day it's about the love of the games uh
the fact that we here all of us except
for adct pushing 50 years old and we can
sit here talking about games somebody
told me I was 60
D was that my nephew cuz that my nephew
he about smoking us I guess that's
what so um it's just really exciting to
see where we're going again like the guy
said we're going to be at PAX East once
again with pretty much the entire team a
good a good portion of the team and
that's going to be great um and then
obviously trying to get to to Tokyo
where it's all started right um when we
first well it it started over there in
some ways and over here in some ways as
well so but just to be there you know
the home of Mario
play started where Sega is from oh yes I
I can't I would love to like just the
the backdrops they have for podcast
there yeah that sick that would be sick
that'll be that would be awesome what
are the what do they call the stuff that
you wear over there we got all Gotta
Wear one everybody wearing kimonos
kimonos oh my Lord me and AD have a ball
I'm going over there in the Godzilla
suit and we going to kill we are not
doing that but with some of the standout
shows what's the stand out what's for
you uh having Jean in here at Jean Park
uh that's the homie Jean is like he's
he's he's a brother like you know like
the things he's been through the things
he's done he part with 36 ma in the club
he get really is him and Harold oh
Harold remember Harold stories oh Harold
stories about janary New York game War
we're gonna be there yeah we're gonna be
there as well New York game awards um
yeah those two really really stood out
to me I I forgot Jason ruin was this
year was it early this year Jason Ruben
L yeah it was so yeah exactly talking to
Jason Ruben and getting all that history
about naughty dog and just kind of the
craziness of the uh the industry back
then all that stuff all those
perspectives uh I just love what we've
become and what we've evolved into what
we continue to evolve into um because we
out here we we've been doing this for
all our lives basically we love games we
love to talk about them think we're
pretty knowledgeable right and and we
and we manag to be fun and funny too so
um it's it's just a joy to be
here Pak but it is you know it is being
able to to to have those moments again
that we had when we were kids having
that so yeah so do you do you want me to
to say the exclusive interviews that we
had because there's only like seven or
eight of
them
year don't spoil anything that's when we
interviewed we interview John on high-fi
Rush we had cliff
on came on uh we did the exclusive
interview of Harvey Smith we had Cliffy
be Harvey
Smith yo I got to spit IC te bars to
Cliffy be I was lit we we also
interviewed uh you know like Cliffy B we
interviewed uh Patrick when it come
TOA we interviewed Jake solom we
interviewed y yay y yay we interview was
dope we interviewed Peter
twice and then we interviewed remember
when he brought out the Dreamcast trip
at the end bro yeah we we
interviewed the Chris from U from for of
Motorsport yes Chris Zaki crazy man
again tremendous shout out shout out to
rago's on khif ah khif yes khif we had
khif about oh bro homie never forget
about him f is let's go baby bro and
then salute to the you know this was the
year of was the the the Call of Duty the
ABK fiascos and when is it going to come
and the kiab his moments when it you
know what saying when it goes down and
always those Call of Duty episodes were
always crazy and keep in mind we
couldn't get the majority of those
interviews without you guys yeah backing
us up on Twitter because the cliff would
not have happened if you didn't show
engagement straight up the real straight
upet Peter Mo was partly in real to I
shot the shot but everybody was like yo
and you got to understand when you guys
do that it gets people to look at the
content and say you know who are these
guys that everyone's telling us we need
to be on and then something happen so
you know hopefully more more stuff
planned for next year but continue
something was Paris lockart this year
too lockart was before before that
was and jaffy I went to our exclusive
interviews and read 11 months up yeah no
fine and jaffy came back this year think
shout out Jeffy everything between me
and him right and then look how look how
things work right and and see how was a
blessing to have him and King now up in
there with the remember they would doing
the tag team with the
suits oh that was hilarious we we grew
like 8,000 Subs like that's a lot yeah
shout out to um Bill what's all the
king's
characters you talking about shout out
to the general Buck yes was Jamaican Jim
retired this year don't Jamaican Jim was
retired retired this year
Jamaican Jamaican Jim been retired like
real Jim yes yes yes like real Jim he
gone oh man crazy man but yeah thank you
realm again everybody enjoy your holiday
enjoy whatever you celebrate space man
king was in the oh with the Starfield
was wild funny you know what I'm saying
but now bro you nothing will Top Advance
Hold the Line though that was a that was
is a moment for the culture like yo stop
it they almost made me do it again today
with this blade stuff yeah yeah like but
bro you you are the voice of the
voiceless like the things that people
want to say but they're afraid to say
sometimes and you just BRAC no trouble
you no trouble say and standing on it
and I tell you all the time they like
King I don't I'm be like yo he a lot of
time believe what he said like he he
standing on it you know what my most
memorable part of the Year probably was
what was your very when Scar Enix bent
the knee with Xbox oh with the ports
yeah yeah that was crazy remember when
the court hear the court hearing when
they they admitted that that Sony pays
to keep Final Fantasy off of Xbox my my
jint was
probably when he kicked it with
Starfield when Starfield won MPD I
didn't expect that that was another big
moment where a company gave all four of
us a review shout to I got forget that
was lit we did a five person review F yo
that I love that moment that was
lit I got to tell you man I really
expected you to come in today and gloat
at the yeah he give me the spoke get
your smoke off no no not that not not
that part cry your um no no no what part
that Sega had a huge
presence and Pana
6 what it talking about and it ain't on
your
C remember remember when we were doing
our predictions for the show yeah I did
I believe I was like you know what it
could very well happen we got a Persona
6 announcement at this show and it
didn't happen and then none of y'all
believe they like no it's not happening
and it didn't happen but maybe it's a
little too early to talk about Persona 6
but um yeah that that will be big and I
will give up those
needs oh shout out to the guy let you
finish if it happens if it happens it's
fa shout out to the realm for the
messiness that be hilarious sometimes
the pauses the birth of
beefy that King
instigated all of that was this year all
that was this year we became the iron
Lord pause cast cast this year yeah yep
you know what I'm sad at and and I need
y'all to go find him because I miss my
buddy oh fre Kelly I miss I miss free R
Kelly because I thought Kelly I thought
you was a stand up dude I thought I
thought you was a stand up dude now that
I'm styling on you you know here and I
think you just lurking I think you
lurking now and you understand that I'm
on your head man
PA sh shout out to all these companies
that took a chance on us this year
because because this is one of the first
years where companies actually came out
of their comfort zone and gave a smaller
podcast an opportunity
and and for the SE 600 742 people in
here I I need you to go on uh on Twitter
and tag uh Elgato and say work of
I we gonna make a video and I need you
guys to put pressure on shout out to
valari to thei Bro every partnership and
sponsor was huge for us yeah NZ tari
shout out shout out to prediction shout
out to M mobile shout yeah shout out to
listen man you know giv independent
smaller Channel
manscape yeah yeah we got to go so look
this is it um I get F worlds anybody
enjoy your
your we got super chats and then we
we'll close out superat
superat Ty kasaris $3 Super Chat it's
nice to know the Lord's last along time
wow going out to
I see you shout out for bird dogs for
let adct show his slap SP theair spend
the chair debut and backto back debut
was crazy this year and
andang yes
oh hayth we well fun we
said
hathor we said it wrong again somebody
said that was you you did that to me he
word cuz we we'll call him howorth for a
while I know right so let me see uh $2
super you boy still going longest show
ever no we not still not there but we're
not getting that get there either yes
there we got one bad mother all my homie
$10 UB Jack congratulations on another
incredible year friends you've made
Sundays better for years wishing good
health and an even more and even more
prosperity in 2024 have a feeling it's
going to be a great one oh that's what's
up yo one bad mother that's that's we
think very similarly love his intake
he's always there salute to him salute
to his team also brother come outside if
you at one of the events man I got to
meet you cuz you're really cool dude man
salute that absolutely then we got
Spartan 661 member of Po months Lord
bronze thank you guys for this great
show have a happy holiday vacation and
we will wait for your return to the
realm we will hold and Advance the line
until then salute salute blessings bless
then we have King goris $5 Super Chat
which one of y'all trying to cast these
hands next month in Tekken joke I suck
at fighting games Arena sign up the
channel Arena we going started up it's
it's going to be it's going to be fire
be we took over his
channel now you know how it feels when
you said I'm holding King behind the
line we we're doing tournaments on your
channel in the arena that's right that's
right C catch this at attic Arena
catch that's where we at with the street
fighter I'mma get I'mma show you you my
D yo one bad mother yeah PS East we
going to be there Boston pull up one bad
mother come outside shout out to Philly
Eagles fan yeah oh that pulled up for
real for real yes be we going be rolling
deep this year bro anybody who pulled up
on any event on me and LSM fam also last
media fan lot of love theing Duke fan
lot of love man so I appreciate y'all
y'all really inspired me when I was
going through a tough time appreciate
y'all then we have n Omar
gold congrats on another amazing year by
the greatest part around thank you
brother appreciate salute then we have
Mr two opinionated $5 Super Chat I'm
proud of you guys I know Cel and dizzy
would be too oh that's
OG so continue your grind and don't
forget who you are you know who this is
facts rest peace I want everybody to
remember
um uh what is it um cal cal dizzy
Optimus cold Optimus C we lost some
people yeah we lost some people um
Nintendo oh yeah yeah the guru salute to
the guru for real that was the guy yeah
man good people good people and love
love love the energy that all of them
brought and some debuted on this the
platform so that that's whiskey um
whiskey for sure I I want
everybody during this holiday season
this this this this month in particular
M check in on your loved ones yes uh
just just give a call yeah if you
haven't spoke to your friends or
whatever just Reach Out speak you know
sometimes a kind word or checking in on
somebody goes a long way factual salute
to the Lords man salute to everybody
let's get out of here all right we got
anything else anything else Super Chat
we got dip down anime for four months
Lord bronze thanks for every opportunity
fam all of you are truly inspirational
thank oh love man blessings I need you
to hold your weight in fortnite oh damn
oh damn n n he be holding his weight oh
okay okay salute salute to the dip D and
once again um here is the the link to
the addict Arena yeah get on there I'll
be doing using that channel a little bit
over the break but it's mainly just a
testing area for next year yeah for
Mortal Kombat one and stuff like that I
I'll try I will jump in a Mortal Kombat
thing and try it January y I'm telling
you right now if I be any of you I'm
talking mad as you you should and you
should you should so come over over and
and we're gonna play there we go here's
a good example when I beat king at PX
East that's what you would get if I beat
any of you yeah it's cool it's cool yeah
when I beat him in noru his joint it
still lost moving on so he had a bad
memory this guy this is we not trying to
go to 8:00 let's go I think we're good
hours actually actually my super chat
from the other night I super chated it
at the end of the live stream of the
game awards it got lost so I think I
said something like seven times oh oh
seven times Crow your lord Champion all
right I'm sending you guys to fwn F has
had a very rough week yes L parents
please y IOP raid show him some
love throw him some super chats throw
some likes give dude all the love you
the way y showed love s f love he had a
rough year man and it's a condol
both yeah he's going through a a tough
time send all the love over there F
gaming look we will see y'all next year
ad what's the you know the date off top
we we we return I think this let me look
at January Sunday January what Sunday
January 7th the round will return the
New Year re-energize bless everybody be
safe out there we're going to miss you
guys don't get too crazy and we out of
here everybody enjoy peace don't drink
or drive yes don't do that
[Music]
peace